docker is an important open source
platform for building deploying and
managing containerized applications
dockers simplify the delivery of
distributed applications and have become
increasingly popular
similarly kubernetes provides an easier
way to scale up your application
compared to virtual machines it keeps
code operational and speeds up the
delivery process kubernetes api allows
automating a lot of resource management
and provisioning tests and much more we
will begin this full course video with
what docker is then we will look into
the services and components of docker in
detail next we will see what docker
container is and what are the basic
commands of a docker container then we
will focus on docker swarm and docker
compose after that we will discuss
everything about docker networking then
we will see how to install docker on
ubuntu and windows 10. next we will talk
about 12 crucial docker interview
questions and answers for beginners and
experienced candidates finally we will
conclude this video by discussing the
differences between the two famous tools
which are docker and kubernetes
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your docker career related
queries will have been answered let's
dive deep and learn about these
important tools of devops so without
further ado let's get started hello this
is matthew from simply learn and today
we're going to cover what is docker and
why it should be of value to you as
somebody who works in devops
so let's take a little scenario of a
developer and a tester before you had
the world of docker a developer would
actually build their code and then
they'd send it to the tester but then
the code wouldn't work on their system
the code doesn't work on the other
system due to the differences in
computer environments so what could be
the solution to this
well you could go ahead and create a
virtual machine to be the same of the
solution in both areas we think docker
is an even better solution so let's kind
of break out what the main big
differences are between docker and
virtual machines as you can see between
the left and the right hand side both
look to be very similar what you'll see
however is that on the docker side what
you'll see as a big difference is that
the guest os for each container has been
eliminated docker is inherently more
lightweight but provides the same
functionality as a virtual machine so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons of a virtual machine versus docker
so first of all a virtual machine
occupies a lot more memory space on the
host machine in contrast docker occupies
significantly less memory space the boot
up time between both is very different
docker just boots up faster the
performance of the docker environment is
actually better and more consistent than
the virtual machine docker is also very
easy to set up and very easy to scale
the efficiencies therefore are much
higher with a docker environment versus
a virtual machine environment and you'll
find it is easier to port docker across
multiple platforms than a virtual
machine finally the space allocation
between docker and a virtual machine is
significant when you don't have to
include the guest os you're eliminating
a significant amount of space and the
docker environment is just inherently
smaller so after docker as a developer
you can build out your solution and send
it to a tester as long as we're all
running in the docker environment
everything will work just great so let's
step through what we're going to cover
in this presentation we're going to look
at the devops tools and where docker
fits within that space we'll examine
what docker actually is and how docker
works and then finally we'll step
through the different components of the
docker environment so what is devops
devops is a collaboration between the
development team the operation team
allowing you to continuously deliver
solutions and applications and services
that both delight and improve the
efficiency of your customers if you look
at the venn diagram that we have here on
the left hand side we have development
on the right hand side we have operation
and then there's a crossover in the
middle and that's where the devops team
sits if we look at the areas of
integration between both groups
developers are really interested in
planning code building and testing and
operations want to be able to
efficiently deploy operate a monitor
when you can have both groups
interacting with each other on these
seven key end elements then you can have
the efficiencies of an excellent devops
team so planning in codebase we use
tools like jit and geara for building we
use gradle and maven testing we use
selenium the integration between dev and
ops is through tools such as jenkins and
then the deployment operation is done
with tools such as docker and chef
finally nagios is used to monitor the
entire environment so let's step deeper
into what docker actually is so docker
is a tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in a
lightweight container so the application
can work efficiently in different
environments
now it's important to note the container
is actually a software package that
consists of all the dependencies
required to run the application so
multiple containers can run on the same
hardware the containers are maintained
in isolated environments they're highly
productive and they're quick and easy to
configure so let's take an example of
what docker is by using a house that may
be rented for someone using airbnb
so in the house there are three rooms
and only one cupboard and kitchen and
the problem we have is that none of the
guests are really ready to share the
cupboard and kitchen because every
individual has a different preference
when it comes to how the cupboard should
be stocked and how the kitchen should be
used this is very similar to how we run
software applications today each of the
applications could end up using
different frameworks so you may have a
framework such as rails
perfect and flask and you may want to
have them running for different
applications for different situations
this is where docker will help you run
the applications with the suitable
frameworks so let's go back to our
airbnb example so we have three rooms
and a kitchen and cupboard how do we
resolve this issue well we put a kitchen
and cupboard in each room we can do the
same thing for computers docker provides
the suitable frameworks for each
different application and since every
application has a framework with a
suitable version this space can also
then be utilized for putting in software
and applications that alone and since
every application has its own framework
and suitable version the area that we
had previously stored for a framework
can be used for something else now we
can create a new application in this
instance a fourth application that uses
its own resources you know what with
these kinds of abilities to be able to
free up space on the computer it's no
wonder docker is the right choice so
let's take a closer look to how docker
actually works so when we look at docker
and we call something docker we're
actually referring to the base engine
which actually is installed on the host
machine that has all the different
components that run your docker
environment and if we look at the image
on the left hand side of the screen
you'll see that docker has a client
server relationship there's a client
installed on the hardware there is a
client that contains the docker product
and then there is a server which
controls how that docker client is
created the communication that goes back
and forth to be able to share the
knowledge on that docker client
relationship is done through a rest api
this is fantastic news because that
means that you can actually interface
and program that api so we look here in
the animation we see that the docker
client is constantly communicating back
to the server information about the
infrastructure
and it's using this rest api as that
communication channel the docker server
then will check out the requests and the
interaction necessary for it to be the
docker daemon which runs on the server
itself will then check out the
interaction and the necessary operating
system pieces needed to be able to run
the container okay so that's just an
overview of the docker engine which is
probably where you're going to spend
most of your time but there are some
other components that form the
infrastructure for docker let's dig into
those a little bit deeper as well so
what we're going to do now is break out
the four main components that comprise
of the docker environment the four
components are as follows the docker
client and server which we've already
done a deeper dive on docker images
docker containers and the docker
registry so if we look at the structure
that we have here on the left hand side
you see the relationship between the
docker client and the docker server and
then we have the rest api in between now
if we start digging into that rest api
particularly the relationship with the
docker daemon on the server we actually
have our other elements that form the
different components of the docker
ecosystem so the docker client is
accessed from your terminal window so if
you are using windows this can be
powershell on mac it's going to be your
terminal window and it allows you to run
the docker daemon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open so you can actually use your
terminal window to create instructions
on how to build and run your docker
images and containers if we look at the
images part of our registry here we
actually see that the image is really
just a template with the instructions
used for creating the containers which
you use within docker the docker image
is built using a file called the docker
file and then once you've created that
docker file you'll store that image in
the docker hub or registry and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a docker
environment that you've created the
syntax of creating the image is fairly
simple it's something that you'll be
able to get your arms around very
quickly and essentially what you're
doing is you're creating the option of a
new container you're identifying what
the image will look like what are the
commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have a
definition for what your image will look
like so if we look here at what the
container itself looks like is that the
container is a standalone executable
package which includes applications and
their dependencies it's the instructions
for what your environment will look like
so you can be consistent in how that
environment is shared between multiple
developers testing units and other
people within your devops team now the
thing that's great about working with
docker is that it's so lightweight that
you can actually run multiple docker
containers in the same infrastructure
and share the same operating system this
is its strength it allows you to be able
to create those multiple environments
that you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that docker image
and to get access to that image we use
the docker registry which is an open
source server-side service for hosting
and distributing the images that you
have defined you can also use docker
itself as its own default registry and
docker hub now something it has to be
very mind though is that for publicly
shared images you may want to have your
own private images in which case you
would do that through your own registry
so once again public repositories can be
used to host the docker images which can
be accessed by anyone and i really
encourage you to go out to docker and
see the other docker images that have
been created because there may be tools
there that you can use to speed up your
own development environments now you
will also get to a point where you start
creating environments that are very
specific to the solutions that you are
building and when you get to that point
you'll likely want to create a private
repository so you're not sharing that
knowledge with the world in general now
the way in which you connect with the
docker registry is through simple pull
and push commands that you run through
terminal window to be able to get the
latest information so if you want to be
able to build your own container what
you'll start doing is using the pull
command to actually pull the image from
the docker repository and the command
line for that is fairly simple in
terminal window you would write docker
pull and then you put in the image name
and any tags associated with that image
and use the command pools so in your
terminal window you would actually use a
simple line of command once you've
actually connected to your docker
environment and that command will be
docker pull with the image name and any
associated tags around that image what
that will then do is pull the image from
the docker repository whether that's a
public repository or a private one now
in reverse if you want to be able to
update the docker image with a new
information you do a push command where
you would take the script that you've
written about the docker container that
you defined and push it to the
repository and as you can imagine the
commands for that are also fairly simple
in terminal window you would write
docker push the image name any
associated tags and then that would then
push that image to the docker repository
again either a public or a private
repository so if we recap the docker
file creates a docker image that's using
the build commands a docker image then
contains all the information necessary
for you to be able to execute the
project using the docker image any user
can run the code in order to create a
docker container and once a docker image
is built it's uploaded to a registry or
to a docker hub where it can be shared
across your entire team and from the
docker hub users can get access to the
docker image and build their own new
containers so let's jump into our first
section of life before kubernetes so the
way that you have done work in the past
where you may be doing work right now is
really building out and deploying
solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a data center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is to blame code
out to virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployment that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and your code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime and errors within the
infrastructure of your entire
environment there's going to be problems
with resource allocation and you're
going to have air issues where
applications may be running effectively
and not not effectively and not load
balance
effectively across the environment the
problem that you have with this kind of
infrastructure is that it gets very
expensive uh you can only install one
piece of software one service on one
piece of hardware so your hardware is
being massively under utilized this is
where virtual machines have become
really popular with a virtual machine
you're able to have better resource
utilization and scalability at much less
cost and this allows you to be able to
run multiple virtual machines on a
single piece of hardware the problem is
is that vms or for virtual machines are
not perfect either some of the
challenges you run with vms is that the
actual hardware and software need needed
to manage the vm environment can be
expansive there are security risks with
virtual with vms there are security
risks with vms there have been data
breaches recorded about solutions that
run in virtualized environments you also
run into an issue of availability and
this is largely because you can only
have a finite number of virtual machines
running on a piece of hardware and this
results in limitations and restrictions
in the types of environment you want to
be running and then finally setting up
and managing a virtualized environment
is time consuming it can take a lot of
time and it can also get very expensive
so how about kubernetes well kubernetes
is a tool that allows you to manage
containerized deployment of solutions
and inherently kubernetes is a tool that
is really a next level maturity of
deployment so if you can think of your
maturity curve as deploying code in
directly to hardware in a data center
and then deploying your solutions to
virtual machines the next evolution of
that deployment is to use containers and
kubernetes so let's kind of go through
and look at the differences between a
virtual machine and kubernetes we've got
a few here that we want to highlight and
you'll get an understanding of what the
differences are between the two so first
of all with virtual machines there is
inherently security risks and what
you'll find as we get dig through the
architecture later in the presentation
is that kubernetes is inherently secure
um and this is largely because of the
legacy code the legacy of kubernetes and
where it came from we'll talk about that
in just a moment but kubernetes is
inherently secure
virtual machines are not easily portable
now with that said they they are
technically portable they're just not
very easily portable whereas with
kubernetes it's working with docker
container solutions it is
extremely portable that means that you
can actually spin up and spin down and
manage your infrastructure exactly the
way that you want it to be managed and
scale it on the demands of the customers
as they're coming in to use the solution
from a time consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a virtual machine a few other
areas that we want to kind of highlight
from differences virtual machines use
much less isolation when building out
the
encapsulated environment than kubernetes
does uh for instance with a virtual
machine you have to run hypervisor
on top of the os and hardware and then
inside of the virtual machine you also
have to have the operating system as
well whereas in contrast on a kubernetes
environment because it's leveraging a
darker container and or container like
technologies it only has to have the os
and the hardware and then inside of each
container it doesn't need to have that
additional os layer it's able to inherit
what it needs to be able to run the
application this makes the whole
solution much more flexible and allows
you to run many more containers on a
piece of hardware than versus running
virtual machines on a single piece of
hierarchy so as we highlighted here our
vms are not as portable as
kubernetes and kubernetes is portable
directly related to the use of
containerization and because kubernetes
is built on top of containers it is much
less time consuming because you can
actually script and automatically
allocate resource to nodes within your
kubernetes environment because it allows
the infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
why we are running into a solution where
kubernetes had to come about because the
demand for having more highly scalable
solutions that are more efficient was
just really a natural evolution of this
software deployment model that started
with pushing out code to physical
hardware and then pushing code out to
virtual machines and then needing to
have a solution much more sophisticated
kubernetes would have come about at some
point in time i'm just really glad it
came back when it did so what is
kubernetes let's let's dig into the
history of kubernetes and how it came
about so in essence uh kubernetes is an
open source platform that is allows you
to manage and deploy and maintain groups
of containers and the container is
something like docker and if you're
developing code you're probably already
using docker today consider kubernetes
as the tool that manages multiple docker
environments together now
we talk a lot about docker and as a
container solution with kubernetes the
reality is is that kubernetes can
actually use other container tools out
there but docker just simply is the most
popular container out there both these
tools are open source that's why they're
so popular and they just allow you to be
able to have flexibility in being able
to scale up your solutions and they were
designed for the post-digital world that
we live in existing today so a little
bit of background a little bit of trivia
around kubernetes so kubernetes was
originally a successor to a project at
google and the original project was
google board um google borg it does
exactly what kubernetes done does today
but kubernetes was rewritten from the
ground up and then released as an open
source project in 2014 so that people
outside of google could take advantage
of the power of kubernetes
containerization management tools and
today it is managed by the cloud native
computing foundation and there are many
many companies that support and manage
kubernetes so for instance if you're
signing up for microsoft azure aws
google cloud all of them will leverage
kubernetes and it's just become the the
de facto tool for managing large groups
of containers so let's kind of step
through some of the key benefits that
you'd experience from kubernetes and so
we have nine key benefits and the first
it is highly portable and is 100 open
source code and this means that you can
actually go ahead and contribute to this
code project if you want to through
github uh the ability to scale up the
solution is incredible um what's um the
the history of kubernetes being part of
a google project for managing the google
network and infrastructure
kind of really sets the groundwork for
having a solution that is highly
scalable the
out of the high scalability also comes
the need for high availability and this
is the desire to be able to have a
highly efficient and highly energized
environment that also you can really
rely on so if you're building out a
kubernetes management um environment you
know that it's going to be available for
the solutions that you're maintaining
and it's really designed for deployment
so you can script out the environment
and actually have it as part of your
devops model so you can scale up and
meet the demands of your customer then
what you'll find is that the um load
balancing is extremely efficient and it
allows you to distribute the load
efficiently across your entire network
so your network remains stable and then
also the tool
allows you to manage the orchestration
of your storage so you can have local
storage such as an ssd on the hardware
that the kubernetes is
maintaining or if the kubernetes
environment is pulling storage from a
public cloud such as azure or aws you
can actually go ahead and make that
available to your entire system and you
can inherit the security that goes back
and forth between the cloud environments
and one of the things you'll find
consistent with kubernetes is that it is
designed for a cloud-first uh
environment um kubernetes as well is
that it's it's really a self-healing
environment so if something happens or
something fails kubernetes will detect
that failure and then either restart the
process kill the process or replace it
and then because of that you also have
automated rollouts and drawbacks in case
you need to be able to manage the state
of the environment and then finally
you have automatic bin packaging so you
can actually specify the compute power
that's being used from cpu and ram for
each container so let's dig into the
final area which is the actual
kubernetes architecture i'm going to
cover this at a high level there's
actually another video that you can
that simply learn has developed which
digs deeper into the kubernetes
architecture and so the kubernetes
architecture is a clustered-based
architecture
and it's really about two key areas you
have the kubernetes master which
actually controls um and all of the
activities within your entire kubernetes
infrastructure and then you have nodes
um that actually are running on linux
machines um outs that are controlled by
the master so let's kind of go through
some of these um areas so if we look at
the kubernetes master uh to begin with
um then we'll start with uh etc this is
a tool that allows for the configuration
of information and the management of
nodes within your cluster and one of the
key features that you'll find with all
of the tools that are managed within
either a the master environment or
within a node is that they are all
accessible via the api server um and
what's interesting about the api server
is that it's a restful based
infrastructure which means that you can
actually secure each connection with ssl
and other
security models to ensure that your
entire infrastructure and the
communication going back and forth
across your infrastructure is tightly
secured scheduler goes ahead and
actually as you'd expect it actually
manages the schedule of activities
within the actual cluster and then you
have the control and the controller is a
daemon server that actually manages and
pushes out the instructions to all of
your nodes so uh the other tools really
are the uh the infrastructure and you
can consider them the administration
site um of the master whereas controller
is the management actually pushes out
all of the controls via the api server
so let's actually dig into um one of the
actual nodes themselves and there are
three key areas of the nodes one is the
docker environment which actually helps
and manage and maintain the container
that's actually inside
of the node and then you have the
kubelet which is responsible for
information that goes back and forth and
it's going to do most of the
conversation with the api server on the
actual health of that node and then you
have the actual kubernetes proxy which
actually runs the services actually
inside of the node so as you see all of
these infrastructures are extremely
lightweight and designed to be very
efficient and very available for your
infrastructure and so here's a quick
recap of the different tools that are
available and it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node the
kubernetes master has the instructions
of what's going to happen within your
kubernetes infrastructure and then it's
going to push out those in structure to
an indefinite number of nodes that will
allow you to be able to scale up and
scale down your solution in a dynamic
way today i'll be taking you through the
installation process for docker so now
let's begin with the demo we'll be
installing docker on an ubuntu system so
this is my system i just open the
terminal so the first thing you can
start with is removing any docker
installation that you probably already
have present in your system if you want
to start from scratch so this is the
command to do so sudo apt get remove
docker
docker engine docker dot io enter your
password
and docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install docker
once again
before that i'll just clear my screen
okay so before i install docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo apt get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type docker install
and that by itself will give you the
command you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
docker dot io is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we will execute the suru
snap install docker so sudo apt install
docker dot io first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have
sudo snap install docker so snap install
docker installs a newly created snap
package
there are basically some other
dependencies for docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire docker i o
it will take some time
great so our docker is installed the
next thing we do as i mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install docker
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version
and as you can see docker version
17.12.1
ce has been installed
next thing we do is we pull
an image from the docker hub
so docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a docker image which
is present on the docker hub docker hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now
the command to check this
is sudo docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository
this is present on our system currently
so the image has been successfully
pulled onto the system
and this means that our docker is
working
now we'll try out another command
sudo docker ps minus a
this displays all the containers that
you have pulled so far so as you can see
here there are three hello world images
displayed and all of them are in exited
state so i did this demo previously too
which is why the two hello worlds which
is created two minutes ago is also
displayed here and the first hello world
which has been created a minute ago is
the one we just did for this demo now as
you have probably noticed that all the
hello world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for docker ps
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running state you can
simply execute sudo docker ps
suru
docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running state welcome everyone to our
one another demo on which we are going
to see that how exactly we can do the
installation of docker on the windows
platform specifically on windows 10. now
docker is something which is available
for most of the operating systems
different different platforms so it
supports both the unix and the windows
platform as such so um linux through
various commands we can do the
installation but in the case of windows
you have to download the exe file and a
particular installer from the docker hub
websites you can simply google it and
you will get a kind of a link from where
you will be able to download the package
so let's go to the chrome and try to
search on for the windows string uh
particular installer you will get a link
from docker hub you download it you get
the stable version you get the edge
version whichever version you want you
wish to download you can download it so
let's go back to the chrome so here you
have the docker desktop for windows so
you can go for this table or you can go
for the edge right so you also have the
comparison that what is the difference
between these two versions right so um
the particular edge version is something
which is getting releases every month
and uh the um stable version is getting
the releases every quarter so they are
not doing much of the changes to the
stable version as compared to the edge
there so you just have to double click
on the installer and that will help you
to do the installation of the process so
let's get started so you just click on
the get instable version so when you do
that the particular installer is going
to install now it's going to take like
around 300 mb there so that's the kind
of installed which is available so uh
once the installer is downloaded so what
you can do is that you can actually go
ahead and you can uh proceed with the
doing the double click on this installer
when you double click on that you have
to proceed with some of the steps like
you know from the gui itself you are
going to proceed with these steps so
we'll wait for 10 to 20 seconds more and
then the installer will be done and then
we can do the double click and the
installation will proceed
so another thing is that uh there is a
huge difference between the installer
like for example in case of unix the
installer is a little bit less but in
case of windows it's a gui is also
involved and there are a lot of binders
which is available there so that's the
reason why you know the huge size is
there now it's available for free that's
for sure and it also requires the
windows 10 professional or enterprise
64-bit there so um if you are working on
some previous version of operating
systems like windows 7 and all you have
the older version called docker toolbox
so they used to call it as like docker
toolbox earlier but now they are calling
it as in docker desktop with the new
docker
windows 10 support as such here so
another couple of seconds and then the
installer will be done and then we will
be able to proceed with the installation
so let's see that how much progress is
there to the download so we'll click on
the downloads
and here still we have some particular
installations or some download going on
so we'll wait for some time and once the
installation is done then we'll go back
and we'll proceed with installation
so couple of seconds
so it's almost done so i'll just click
on this one you can go to the directory
to the downloads and you can double
click on that also but if you want to do
the installation you can click on this
one also and it will ask for the
approval yes or no you have to provide
now once that is done so um a desktop a
kind of a gui component will open there
so it will start proceeding with
installation so it's asking whether you
want to add the desktop the shortcut to
desktop so you can say okay i'm going to
click on ok so it will unpack the files
all the files which is required for
docker to successfully install that is
getting unpacked over here so it will
take some time to do the installation
because it's doing a lot of work here so
you can just wait for till the execution
of the installer to be completed and
once the installer is done you can open
your command line and start working on
the docker
so taking some time to extract the files
now it's asking us to you know do the
close and do the restart so once that is
done you will be able to proceed further
and you can just you know run the
command line and any docker command if
you can run so that will give you the
response whether the docker is installed
or not so you can see here the docker is
you know something which is installed so
you can run like docker version you will
be able to get a version of the client
when you do the restart of the machine
then at that moment of time the docker
server will also be started and then
this particular error message will go
off right now the docker daemon is not
up and running because the installation
requires a restart and when you close on
this one and go for the restart the
machine will be restarted here so this
is the way that how exactly we can go
for a docker installation and we can go
on that part now let's start with what
exactly is in devops all about here now
devops is nothing but a collaboration
between the development and the
operations teams over here which enables
continuous delivery of the applications
and services to the end user so it's a
combination or collaboration between the
two teams development and operations
which helps us to go for a further
implementation of various processes like
continuous integration continuous
deployment continuous delivery all these
things are possible with this
collaboration over here now why exactly
docker is important for us as such
in a city far away from this one so a
developer decided to develop a tons of
software on a single vm now he can put
up applications he is having a big
server and he wants to host the multiple
application on a single machine but for
him these virtual machine got a crash
because definitely if you are putting up
more uh different different applications
as such on the on a single vm uh it's
not able to take up that much kind of
load over there so in order to avoid
this situation how exactly he can do the
various options or what he can
implement to have this uh issue resolved
so ultimately docker is something which
is the solution of him so if he really
wants to host multiple applications
on a single virtual machine or you want
to have different different applications
then docker is the ultimate solution for
him to do that and by doing so
there will be no issues as such when we
talk about that the errors or the
uh virtual machines cannot be crashed
and but there will be no impact on the
virtual machine as such so why exactly
docker is important so let's talk about
the comparison between the docker and
virtual machine there are very few
reasons why exactly uh the docker is
being chosen open a virtual machine
because virtual machine is a
full-fledged component which can take up
any kind of load but some of the reasons
are still that in which case we will be
preferring the docker instead of the
virtual machine here the very first one
is the memory users so docker is having
a very less memory uses because there is
no concept of guest operating system
whereas on the other hand the virtual
machines are going to take a huge amount
of ram uh resources in order to keep
that particular operating system up and
running second one performance because
uh if definitely if you have less
utilization and the users is less the
performance will be better but for some
reason if you are taking up more
resources and you will not be able to
deliver that amount of performance as
such over there and then again we have
portability so portability is also quite
easy when we talk about the virtual
machines in case of docker it it's quite
portable as compared to the virtual
machine and then the last time is that
the boot up time so virtual machine boot
up time is probably in minutes but uh in
case of docker it's in seconds so if we
summarize it on this one so the memory
utilization the boot up time the
performance everything is better in case
of docker as compared to the virtual
machines
right for a classic example let's say
that what about the memory user 9gb of
memory uh you know is something if you
can see that f1 f2 and f3 is there so
green and red color represents the
occupied memory and the wasted memory
now
there is a particular uh utilization of
let's say that um you know a server
which is available there and uh you know
3 gb of
ram is something which is wasted and 4
gb of ram is something which is being
occupied there so app2 is using like 2gb
and then you can see that the specific
2gb of ram is occupied and 3gb is
occupied and the wasted one is 1gb so
vm can see over there that uh you know 9
gb of ram is used and the remaining 6 gb
of uh unused ram cannot be used because
if for example i allocate like 4 gb of
ram to the virtual machine it's there
itself it it gets locked on so
it's not like okay uh i'm using only 4gb
ram out of this
9gb of ram then the next uh 5 gb of ram
will be totally wasted so you cannot
reuse it for any purpose
so this is a problem with the virtual
machine that if you allocate some memory
to the uh specific virtual machine if
you are not using that much uh resources
or that much memory the remaining memory
will be simply wasted because this is
hardcorely allocated to a virtual
machine and you cannot utilize this
unused memory as such over there so this
is the limitation from the memory
perspective but in case of docker
definitely if you know out of the 9gb of
ram if we are using uh only 3gb of ram
so whatever the unused memory is there
so we can actually use it to for the new
containers so it's not dedicatedly
allocated to the virtual machines if you
are using
out of 9gb if you're using 1gb 2gb 3gb
or 4gb whatever the remaining
memory is available that you can simply
use it for the other containers also
this ensures that you always go for an
optimal utilization of your resources
and unnecessarily there is no wastage of
the different different resources or the
different components over here in this
one so that's the reason why the docker
containers are quite
efficient in terms of memory when we
compare it with the virtual machine next
one is the performance now um in a
virtual machine we know that you know on
the infrastructure on the physical
infrastructure on top of that you put up
a kind of operating system a base
operating system is there and then on
top of that you have the hypervisor and
this hypervisor then is used to create
the virtual machines which is having a
kind of guest operating system inside it
now the issue over here is that you have
two operating systems over here so the
guest operating system is also going to
take some particular resources and uh
for example the memory or a space a
processor so in every terms in every
resource terms it is going to
go ahead and say that okay i'm going to
use the
particular some of the resources now
problem is
that if you're hosting a very small
application you will end up in having a
more consumption because of this guest
operating system will take more more of
the resources and then you are just
using some small very small resources
for your application in an uh real world
so docker container on the other hand
does not have a concept of the guest
operating system and that's where
what happens that the docker engine is
more than sufficient to handle the
docker containers and inside the docker
containers there is the application
which is being hosted over there now
with this one definitely the performance
is quite better as compared to any
virtual machine because of the terms
that there is no unnecessarily wasted of
the resources because in the previous
case virtual machines a full-fledged
guest operating system is up and running
you need some resources to be allocated
to that but in case of containers you
don't need to have that particular
functionality implemented then
portability so um you know having a
portability or moving an application
which works on a system a does not means
that it will work on the system b also
this is a similar problem which we face
that you know the usually the
application works perfectly fine in a
lower environment and when it goes to
the production environment it sometimes
fails and uh it does not comes up
properly so this isn't portability issue
which we have when we talk about the
virtual machines but when in case of
containers when we got a container up
and running in a lower environment and
once the container is prepared you don't
have to do the changes on modification
to that depending on the environment the
same container can be deployed to
production environment and it's very
easy so whatever container prepared in
the lower environment in a dev
environment the same will work in
production environment without any
issues because it contains all the
dependencies and executables everything
inside it so you don't have to do any
kind of modifications or changes to
these containers as such over here and
the last one is the boot up time so
the boot up time of the virtual machines
is in minutes and whereas the boot up
time of the
docker containers is in seconds or
probably in milliseconds so these are
the reason why we consider the virtual
machine as an uh resources
based uh environment but on the other
hand docker is something which is quite
light and fast as compared to virtual
machines so
let's see that what exactly is in docker
all about here so in this one you can
see uh we have the physical
infrastructure on which we have
the host operating system now we don't
have the hypervisor and the guest
operating system instead of that we have
the docker engine which is taking care
of managing the docker containers and
inside these docker containers you have
the applications and all the required
binaries and the libraries here so there
is no concept of the gift operating
system these docker engine is the uh
person or is the process which is taking
care of all the requests which is going
on and if this docker engine is up and
running then all the containers will
also be accessible and will be available
now docker is nothing but a os level
virtualization
software platform that enables
developers and id administrators to
create deploy and run applications in a
docker container with all its
dependencies so docker is a very
important tool nowadays if you want to
look forward to the host your
application because of its portability
uh benefit that you don't require much
of the changes uh depending on the
platform or depending on the environment
so whatever the developers are able to
build up the same thing will go till the
production environment now let's talk
about what exactly is in docker
container here now docker container is a
lightweight software package that uh
includes all the dependencies whether
it's a
base operating system uh some frameworks
some libraries it's it's something which
is a part of this one so that if you
will be
if you want to host your application you
will be able to do that so it's a
complete package so both the source code
and the dependencies is what you put up
inside the docker containers
now
within these docker containers you can
have multiple applications there
multiple programming languages multiple
frameworks can be hosted there in fact
the databases also can be hosted within
these docker containers you can host
them as such over there now one of the
different advantages of docker let's
talk about that now the first one is the
rapid deployment so a rapid deployment
is the very first
advantages which we are getting over
here second
quick and easy configuration
better efficiency
portability
scalability and security over here now
there are different ways in which we can
understand the uh benefits or we can
have the understanding about the
docker here
so uh these are some couple of
benefits now let's take up uh take them
one by one the for the first one is the
deployment part so
it's it supports the rapid deployment
now
just like a web application for instance
i want to deploy to websites so there
are some couple of steps which
needs to be done across different
different environments like for example
if i have five environments i have to do
the deployment the same steps in all the
five environments at the different
period of time now when we talk about
docker containers we don't have to run
those steps multiple times because once
those steps are executed in one docker
container the same docker container goes
till the production environment so you
don't have to actually do a rebuild of
the docker containers and you can simply
say that okay i have got the docker
container here so you can just run one
or two couple of commands and that will
help you to host your docker containers
so you don't have to redo or rework on
any kind of the deployment work into the
production environment or into the
higher environments and then we goes for
the uh quick and easy configurations so
uh the configurations of docker
containers is quite easy you can have
your own custom docker images built out
the docker files so these processes can
be integrated within the jenkins also so
cicd is quite possible with the help of
docker if you want to really do that and
uh then we have better efficiency yes
they have a better efficiency and reduce
resources management as compared to the
virtual machines portability uh we have
already thought about that that it's
easy to move from one environment from
one system to another in fact it's easy
from the developer also so from one
machine from one developer to another
developer it's very easy to move these
uh different docker containers
then we have scalability
scalability is also possible with this
docker containers just like multiple
virtual machines you can also create
multiple containers and you can share
the traffic out of that so but that
scalability and all is possible with the
orchestration tools uh then security is
there so
you can have your best practices of the
security implemented because um it's
just a kind of a virtualization just
like a virtual machine so you have all
the uh different uh possibilities which
is available which you can explore when
you talk when you want to make this
stock container secure right so these
were some of the benefits which was
there for the docker here now let's talk
about the installation of docker here
now installation of docker is pretty
common and uh whatever platform you want
it's available over there so it's
available for ubuntu windows
it's available for mac operating system
so for ubuntu you have to run the
commands on the open to part operating
system to download it and for windows
it's actually having a
a particular exe file so you can go for
the installation of exe file and then we
have the mac operating system so for mac
operating system you have the dmg files
and when you do the dmg file so it will
uh help you to install the
component over there so mac you can also
use the home view wants to do the
installation of that particular
component
now next one is the architecture of
docker
now the architecture of docker is pretty
straightforward there are key components
which is available there in the
architecture of docker here the very
first one is the as the client facing is
the docker client now docker client or
you can say that docker cli is available
there now this is the component it's a
command line interface which takes up
the request from the end user like for
example i'm running the command so it
will take all the requests from me as an
end user and it will send those
particular uh things or the requirements
to the docker daemon to the server using
the rest api interface so this docker
daemon is something which keeps on
running on the server and it's a
background process it gets deployed as
an service there in case this docker
demon is not available or it's not up
and running you will not get the proper
response from the docker command line
here so in order to get all your
activity or your uh procedures
implemented you need to have the docker
server or docker daemon up and running
in fact this docker cli can be
configured to connect to any other
servers or any other different server
docker daemon also so it's a
connectivity which is happening over the
rest api interface where all the
requests are processed are sent to the
docker demon and whatever response is
coming back that is given back to the
end user so what are the different
components of docker here let's talk
about that so docker client consists of
the cli company uh like we have already
discussed so that is something which is
uh going to take up all the requests
from the end user then um it's using the
rest api interface which is there to
have the connectivity with the docker
daemon so docker daemon is something
which is always up and running so if you
run a couple of commands like docker
pull push and also that activity you are
actually sending the request to the
docker demon and docker daemon is
actually doing all the work so it's not
a docker client which is doing it just
taking its kind of interface which will
take the things up and send it back or
send it forward to the docker day
right so it's a background process which
keeps on running on the server on the
operating system and uh it's the same
process across all the infrastructure
all the different platforms whether you
use mac operating system use windows or
you use linux everywhere this is the
basic functionality and it keeps on
listening to the rest api interface so
uh whatever the request new request
comes in it immediately process it and
whatever the response whether you are
stopping a container whether you are
running a container according to that
the action will be taken and the
response will be sent back to the rest
api to the docker client so a docker is
a process or it's a command line which
is used to start the docker daemon
when you run the command like service
docker status on the server you will be
able to see the command which is getting
executed in the back end so there you
can see that uh docker is the process or
is the command line which is used to
initialize the docker daemon and of
course there is a kind of configurations
which you have to pass it on as a
parameters so even if you run psyphonyf
command you will be able to know that
what process is running from the docker
perspective and the third component is a
a particular docker registry so we have
a ready-made uh cloud service which is
available known as the docker hub so you
can actually store the docker images on
these docker registry so there are a lot
of ready-made uh docker images which is
available there but of course you can
have your own docker image also over
there or you want you can have your own
custom
registry docker registries also for
example in jfrog you can have your
private hosted registries also so all
these are different repositories you can
use with your docker containers so
docker containers is having the
flexibility that whichever registries or
repositories you want to connect or you
want to establish the connectivity you
can always do that now let's talk about
the docker image over here
in detail
now a docker image is nothing but a
template of instructions it's having a
couple of instructions in which you will
be using these instructions to create a
final dock container so docker image
is uh nothing but uh for example i want
to have a tomcat apache docker image so
what are the instructions i have to do
so the very first thing is that i have
to pick up a base operating system then
on top of that i will be installing the
jdk or some prerequisite packages and
then on top of that we will be
configuring on to the tomcat apache
there so these are the steps these are
the different instructions step by step
procedure which we are implementing so
that at the end of the uh activity we
will be able to have a docker container
ready which we can deploy to host tomcat
apache so it's a template which is
having all the uh particular
instructions in order to build a docker
image you require a file called docker
file which is uh of course having all
these different uh
instructions embedded in that so when
you run the docker file it acts like a
build tool so whatever the instructions
you are putting up over there all those
instructions are getting uh processed
and you are able to get a end result
then these docker images are actually
comprised of multiple layers so multiple
layers are available there so step by
step so you will be first of all having
a base layer from which the image starts
on top of that another layer for example
you did the installation of jdk so
another layer will be there and then you
did the configuration
of of the term kit apache and then
another layer will be there so it's a
multi-layered in uh component which is
available and these layers are in
incremental order so definitely the
oldest one will be known as the base uh
layer and then on top of that all the
latest changes will be done in the
latest layers there so this is an
example now here you can see that uh
there are four instructions and these
four instructions are also known as the
four layer docker image so whatever the
final docker image you will get in there
you will be able to see four layers of
uh the uh docker image here now the very
first is ubuntu so ubuntu 18.04 we are
pulling up and then we are pulling like
uh the file over here and uh then we are
running the make utility and uh once
that is done then we are running that
file dot uh python file over here in
this one so these are four instructions
which is available right so uh which
will definitely help us to do that how
exactly we can make or we can
perform the different activities right
from the base so in this case the base
layer will be like uh the one two one so
one two one will be the base image and
the moment the final cmd attribute or
cmd
attributions are processed and executed
after that you will be able to get a
final full-fledged docker image over
there so this will be a full complete
docker image or docker container which
you will get once the whole build
process is completed
now in this case you have
you can see that the previous docker
file which we processed so the base
layer is ubuntu 18.04 we are not
building that actually it's
automatically so it's by default getting
downloaded as in full base layer after
that only we have like layer one layer
two layer three added up because those
modifications we are doing it after the
because from does not means that you are
doing any kind of layer modifications
it's just like you are importing some
base operating system or base image so
the modification or adding up the layers
is only done after the base layer there
so whenever a user creates a container a
new uh layer is something which is
stopped on top of the image these layers
are known as the containers layers so
one to one the very first instruction
does not comprises it is it's not a kind
of uh container layer we can call it as
an base image layer there so every
container has a separate read write
container layer and any modification in
a container is reflected upon the
container layers only so layer one may
be having some different of uh
instructions later maybe having
different instructions so like that is a
step-by-step processor
in case
you know whenever a container is deleted
the top layer also gets deleted over
there in that one so if i delete some
particular containers and that is
something which is gone so it was
supposed having like three layers so the
top layer will be simply deleted because
the container is also deleted for that
particular part now docker uses a copy
and write strategy with both docker
images and docker containers
so uh whenever we uh perform any
activity or whenever copy on uh right
strategies and strategy to share and
copy files for better efficiency so
it's something which is being used to
increase the overall performance of the
docker containers it also makes docker
efficient by reducing the uses of disk
space because whenever uh required okay
whenever is needed only at that moment
of time it's actually performing the
copy and uh it definitely reduces the
overall disk utilization and this is
very important also because when you
have so many docker containers up and
running so you have to worry or you have
to make the utilization of a disk or
your disk users or resources also
minimum so that is also you need to make
sure that it does not exceed a
particular value
so once the utilization is also less
then definitely the overall performance
will also be better and improved over
here in this case
so uh let's talk about some of the facts
here so the base layers are something
which is purely read-only format so you
cannot do the modifications union file
system saves the memory uh you know by
avoiding the duplications of the files
uh the layers can be combined in a union
file system to create a single image so
all these mail layers are combined and
got a final product or called you know
you can call it as docker image or
docker containers
and this allows a file system to appear
as a writable
so
now let's talk about the docker history
very important component because even if
you prepare the docker image locally and
uh you don't have the collaborative tool
or you don't have the uh tool where you
can share these images definitely it's
not easy for you to port these docker
images from one system to another so
docker registry is very important for
the portability feature of docker so
docker registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among users so
uh it can be built up by one user and
multiple users can use it for example
i'm using a jenkins one so um schenken's
uh image is prepared only once but it's
being used by different people as such
docker registry uh again it's a
repository is a collection of docker
images so in a repository you will be
having like different different uh
docker images as such
so in registry a user can distinguish
between the docker images with their tag
names so uh for example jenkins is an a
kind of a single image there might be
different type of images there let's say
that okay let's talk about uh jenkins uh
jdk8 so there will be image called
jenkins the name of the image will be
same but the tags will be different so
one tag could be like jdk8 one tag would
be like jk9 and one tag would be
dedicated so the difference between all
these three docker images is that that
jdk81 is prepared on jdk8 it's running
on jdk8 and if you want to use jk9 in
that case you have to pull down the the
docker image of jenkins with the jdk 9
installed so depending on the frameworks
or depending on the runtimes so with
these tags different tags are processed
so you can have the distinguished
between the
docker images and whichever docker image
you feel you want to use you can
implement according to your requirement
and uh docker
by default is having its own
cloud-based registry called as docker
hub which gets automatically connected
when the moment you do the docker
installation but in case you are working
into your private infrastructure so in
that case uh you may use the
repositories uh docker repositories on
the uh specific jfrog artifactory or the
private repositories also can be hosted
but docker hub is something which is
having a public and private repositories
both so you can create either the public
and private repositories you can use uh
push and pull activities to interact
with these darker images you want to
download a docker image so you can run
pull if you want to push your docker
image to the docker registry in that
case you can run the push activity so in
both the cases you are doing the
interaction with the uh docker hub so
when you run some build process or when
you run the containers there may be some
docker containers which is getting
pulled down from the
specific registry from the docker hub
and uh if that specific image and tag is
available definitely pull command will
be successful but in case of push
command you are pushing your custom
docker images uh you cannot push the
ready-made docker images which is
available you can
publish your own docker image only to
the docker hub and then you can further
on do the poll and push activity
accordingly to those repositories so
whatever the ready-made and third-party
images which is available you can only
do the pull activities to them you
cannot do the push activities push
command scenario will only come when you
are looking when you are interacting
with your custom docker image next one
is the docker container now docker
container is an executable package of an
application and its dependencies
together so when we prepare a docker
container we actually combine both the
dependencies and the uh application
source code inside it so the docker
container don't have to look for the
dependencies on the host machine on the
server so this is one of the benefit
where we see that the portability is
very easy because whatever i'm building
up on one system everything is inside
the docker container so i don't really
need to do any further activity on other
machines so whatever works on one system
can be easily worked on in the system
so it's very lightweight also so it can
be easily deployed and executed on you
know on their particular uh servers
because it does not take that much
utilization like a virtual machine so if
you are looking forward for having your
application hosted into your local
system you can easily do it within the
donors will not have any interaction
unless and until we do we set up that
the containers to have the interactions
now there is uh data volumes where which
can be shared and uh be used among the
multiple containers so um you have the
uh capability over here that you know if
the there is some on
used uh space that can be easily shared
across the multiple containers here so
uh it is uh built using the docker
images so uh using the docker images the
docker containers are built up and
docker run is a specific command which
is used to build a docker container so
if you got a docker image let's say that
i have prepared a docker image a custom
docker image using the docker file now
if i need to create a docker container
out of a docker image i have to run a
docker run command so docker run command
is nothing
but it initializes or creates an
instance of a docker image now next
component is the docker compose
now typically when we work with the the
docker containers so we have to run like
if i want to run like five six
containers i have to initialize like
five six times or i have to run docker
and commands five six times there so um
and if you want to create a relationship
between the containers then definitely
that is something which you need to
manage using the docker commands but
sometimes it's not an easy task for you
to run those commands manually or
remember those commands so docker
compose is a utility over here using
which you can actually run multiple
containers with a single service
you just got off
a kind of a single file you just run it
and all the containers definitions and
relationships everything is inside this
docker file here so you want to run two
containers that's totally fine instead
of running two commands now you just
have to run one file and that will do
take care of that now
you may be having more than two
containers five six seven whatever
number of containers you have that can
be easily deployed without any um manual
activity or without any maintainers onto
the server
so
these containers totally run in
isolation but yes you can establish the
interaction that how they want to
interact with each other and that
interaction you can put up in these
docker compose files so docker compose
file is something which is written in
the vml format and in this you define
that okay i need two containers and this
in this image should be there these are
the parameters which you need to run and
if you want to have the interaction or
the linkage between the images that also
you can establish within this yml files
or this in within this docker compose
file here right so let's say for example
i want to have an application which
requires apache web server and mysql
database now i can create a docker
compose file which can run both
containers and uh without you know you
don't require to restart or start them
separately or initialize them separately
so i will be having a final docker
compose file which is having like uh
you know containers like apache
containers and mysql containers both
inside a single docker compose file here
so that's the benefit you're going to
get because now you don't have to run
them separately separate apache and
separate via mysql so you can get it
done with the help of a single docker
compose file here now what exactly is
the docker swamp now docker swamp
is a inbuilt or it's a default uh
orchestration tool which is being
provided by the docker itself it's a
service uh for containers which allows
the id administrators and the developers
to create and manage a cluster of smart
nodes so um in a typical world when you
do the installation of docker there is a
limitation that you some of the features
like high ability multiple uh instances
or scalability all these things are not
possible as it is with the core docker
now on top of that you require the
organization tools like docker swamp
where you have a swam of node machines
uh five six known machines are there on
which you can have your highly available
application infrastructure implemented
now this one means that if i want to run
my
applications five containers six
containers and seven containers for that
purpose we are using the docker spam so
each node of docker swamp is having a
docker daemon which is uh used to for
performing the interaction so there will
be a master node which is available so
uh it will be interacting with all the
known machine on the all the client
machines and this interaction will be in
such a way that it will let them know
okay i want to deploy the
container or onto the note 3 so it will
perform that activity and the container
will be up and running on the note 3
there so a swamp consists of two type of
nodes one is the manager node and one is
a worker node so manager is the master
node which you can refer
and the worker node is the one which is
actually doing most of the work so uh
the manager node is not something which
is expected to host
anything apart from the main component
but yes
you can always configure
if you feel that you want to only deploy
the container on the worker node so that
also you can
do during the deployment of the
containers so manager will will keep on
connecting to the different worker nodes
there and whenever new request comes in
so it will basically try to connect and
see that okay i just want to go ahead
and deploy a container so it will do the
deployment of the container on the
worker node so the main work will be
done by the worker nodes and manager is
just doing the management of all these
resources the worker nodes will be
definitely receiving the request from
the manager and
it will be proceeding and performing
those activities and uh
if for some reason worker node is not
active or online so the master node will
not be able to deploy the containers on
that server so right now let's talk
about a demo in which we have to create
a darker image using a docker file on
the open220 so uh you want to use a base
operating system as an ubuntu 20 there
and using that we will we are going to
create a custom docker image
so let's connect to our virtual machine
and see that how we can do that okay so
as part of this demo here we are going
to prepare a docker image and uh in that
we are going to use a base image of
ubuntu so uh let's take an operating
system of ubuntu 220 20 is the latest
version of the ubuntu operating system
so i have got a server so let's see so
first of all we have to install the
docker.io package which will install the
docker package and then we can
enable the
service we can make sure that the docker
service is up and running because if the
service itself is down then we will not
be able to perform any activity and then
our sample if you run docker run hello
hyphen volt so that is going to pull a
docker image from the docker hub and a
particular activity will be done to you
so once that is done so we can say that
okay the container is up and running and
everything is got uh you know over there
up and running and then you can also try
some of the ubuntu uh docker image also
if you feel that you want to try you can
do that but the main uh demo which we
need to do over here is that we need to
prepare a custom docker image and in
this one we will be having like we will
be using an ubuntu base operating system
on top of that we will be installing php
engine x all these different components
so we are going to have a php based
website hosted onto the apache web
server as an nginx and then we will be
able to access that application so the
very first thing which we need to do is
that we need to create a folder uh let's
say that i just create a particular
folder called nginx hyphen image and
then i create a docker file over there
so docker file uh content we are going
to take from this one so let's go to the
server and see that how we can go ahead
with the activity
now uh what we can do is that what we
have got a server over here
now in this server what i'm going to do
is that i'm going to proceed with the
installation of docker first now when i
do the docker installation first so what
will happen that i will be able to have
my docker installation completed and
then further on i can take the further
steps of having the accessibility of uh
going through the understanding that
what is this uh particular platform or
how to prepare different different kind
of containers
so i have got a particular container
over here so what i can really do is
that i can simply say that okay i have
got a
server so this is a one-two server so i
am going to run the command called app
update first now this will do the update
locally so all the links and everything
will be updated now the whole idea about
doing the updates is that so that i will
be able to ha establish the fact that
i'm trying to connect i'm trying to uh
connect to the ubuntu url so that at any
moment of time i should be able to fetch
on the latest packages now once that is
done so i'm going to run the command
called apt install docker.io now the
moment i do this what will happen that
it will try to download some packages it
will ask for the confirmation you can
give your confirmation and i can say yes
the moment you give the confirmations
the download of the packages will
proceed over here step by step it will
download the packages and the
installation will go on now once the
installation is done so what you can do
is that you can see that docker is
deployed into your system or not you can
run docker version command or you can
also use this service command to check
to make sure to ensure that the docker
service is always up and running if the
service is not up and running you have
to make sure you have to enable it you
have to start that service so these are
some couple of steps which you need to
do in order to make sure that your
connectivity or your environment is
ready for with the docker installation
and once the docker installation is done
then only you will be able to proceed
further with the further activities like
preparing the containers preparing the
images and all that stuff but if you
don't have the docker installed prior to
that then definitely it's going to be a
problem so
just make sure that before even doing
any kind of activity before even doing
any kind of steps we ensure that the
docker is fully up and running so it's
going to take some time to download the
packages and we will wait for that and
once the installation is done we will
continue further on that part
okay now once the installation is done
so you can run the command call service
docker status and when you do that
it will let you know that whether the
docker service is available there or not
so uh you can start the service
in case you don't get uh the proper
response and uh now you can see that
it's showing up that a process is
running so earlier it was not uh up and
running it was inactive but now it's
active and you can see here that dark
ride is the process which is running
over here as an process to initialize
the docker damage so docker demon is up
and running now and we are good to go
here so now uh if we go and say like
docker
run
hello hyphen vault so we are doing a
validation to our docker instance that
whether our docker instance is working
fine as expected or not because uh if
there is any kind of problem with the
docker daemon and docker demon is not up
and running properly we would be able to
get an error message over there but
right now there is no error message
which represents that
yes you are
pretty much running the docker image and
it's giving you the proper response so
you will be able to see the uh
docker images when you run so you will
be able to see that the docker image is
pulled down to your system and
definitely you have executed that and it
got you the response now the next thing
which we need to do is that we need to
run a particular
ubuntu one so for example if i go for
docker
run hyphen i t
open to bash so what exactly we are
doing in this one is that we are pulling
down a one to docker image and we are
running the bash executable on top of
that the whole purpose of doing that
activity is that so that if i want to do
some uh process or i want to perform
some activity i should be able to
connect to that docker image so the
moment i do this first of all if this
docker image is available locally that's
great it will immediately create the
container if the docker image is not
available locally the very first thing
which it will perform over here is to
pull down the docker image the correct
one and as you can see here that it uh
definitely pulls down the darker image
and once it is done so it got a terminal
for you now you can see it shows that
root at the id uh root and the rate of
one id is there this id is nothing but
it's a container id which we are getting
here so definitely you are inside the
docker container and when you run the
docker when you run the exit command you
will see that you have come out of the
docker container over here and the
moment you run docker ps hyphen a
command you can actually see also that
how many container you deployed so far
so you ran hello world you ran the one
to one both of them are stopped there
you can see the exit zero in the uh
status over here because both of them
are something which you ran in the
interactive mode so they are done so if
you want to keep your container up and
running you need to have a container
which runs in the dash mode and always
up and running but for that you have to
go ahead to the level where we need to
create a custom docker image and do the
setup accordingly so let's see that how
we can do that now i'm going to create a
particular folder called nginx hyphen
image
you can pretty much give any name
whatever name you feel you want to
perform you can do that now in this one
i'm going to put up a file called
dockerfile so let's see that what
content we need to put as such when we
talk about the docker file because
whatever content you put over here that
is what according which the docker image
will be prepared
now here
we have to talk about so first we have
to see a base image so we are saying
that okay 0.220.04 is what i want to use
then we are giving some labels now these
labels are used to give some information
like
what is the version who is the
maintainer
what is the description uh you can do
the customizations to this one so uh
these labels are actually defined and
utilized so that i will be able to give
an information that okay so and so
developer is something which we can
contact so if there is any kind of
problem with the uh dockerfile or will
this build script we have to reach out
to that specific person so this is what
we typically do with the labels here now
um we also have to
set up a parameter like deviant
underscore fronted as in non-interactive
because whenever we talk about any build
process in docker file it it cannot be
there in the interactive session it
should be there in the non-interactive
and definitely a typical uh scenarios
like you can run app update command and
then we are installing the php engine x
super supervisor all these things we are
doing we are doing the installation uh
we are using the run attribute run a
particular step and in there whatever
the commands are executed these
statements will be executed when we will
be doing the build process and then we
are using some environment variables
okay so nginx we are virtual host php
underscore conf engineering centers for
conf and supervisor underscore conf
these are the different environment
variables which we configuring over here
now next thing which we have is that uh
we have to transfer some files like
probably nginx and the virtual host file
we may have to transfer from our linux
server to the destination to the
docker container so for that we are
going to run some copy commands copy
statements so that we can do that stuff
and uh then definitely we are
transferring the supervisor
configuration file also to the server so
that we can have that configurations uh
setup over there and uh these are config
uh supervisor underscore config and all
these different variables we have
already established where we are seeing
that what exactly configuration we are
looking forward over here and then we
are uh you know creating some folder
structure we had www html folder
structure we are creating so that we
will be able to push some content over
there and then we have the volume
configurations so whatever the volume
configurations are there we are putting
up so that uh you know we will be able
to have all the uh specific direct
directories mounted on the host machine
on the host server so that we can even
talk about locally also and then the
star.search is something which we need
to run because that's uh that will go
into the command statement which needs
to be executed because when you want to
run your process when you want to run
your nginx process or your docker
container some process should be up and
running that's where
if any interactive process will run then
only the docker container will be hold
up so that's what you can
do or you can configure over there so
i'm going to copy this whole content now
this whole content represents the
complete docker file so uh we have
already gone through this content one by
one but uh if we combine all these
content together till the exposed part
that's where we come up into these one
so expose we are doing 80 and 443 over
here
right after this one we have to create
the host file virtual host file
supervisor d file and the star.search
file so let's go back to the server here
now
in this one you have to uh you can use
whatever editor you feel you want to use
you can do that so this is what i will
my
master file will look like you can see
i'm running some run commands uh these
are the environment variables i'm using
then further on these variables i'm
using just to define the paths okay so
you can see that this default file we
are copying from the uh host machine
from the server to the docker container
and then second file is super wiser d
not con file and then we have star dot
sh file so these are the different files
which we want to configure here so once
this file is prepared we have to uh type
in or we have to create a default file
over here in this current directory so
in this current directory we have to put
up a file called default now in this one
we will be having the default virtual
host configuration config so we need to
put our server attribute
saying that we have to look forward for
index.html or index.php and these kind
of files from the www.html directory
there so i'm just going to copy this
content
and
put it up into this one
so this is how my final file look like
so i'll save it
and then we have a supervisord dot com
file so
so i'll just copy the content of this
one
i'll copy it and we have to create a
file called
supervisord.confile
now names we can double check because we
are referring these names into our
docker file so
we can double check that
so once this is done
save it
and uh we can check the docker file we
can grab
so you can see okay this one so super
wiser d so the name is correct that
scroll so we got default we got
supervisor d now we have to create the
star dot sh file because in this one we
will be configuring that how we want to
start our process of this nginx or this
web server so in this one again we have
to run the uh supervised process over
here and a configuration file so we are
going to put this one
and we'll go here and put this content
right so we got the supervised config
also available so that's also there and
the moment is done so you are going to
give the execute permission to this one
because um you can see that into our
docker file that we are having the
attribute where we want to run this into
the dots
slash there so if you want to refer in
that mode you have to change the
permissions in case that
change mode you have to give the execute
permission to the start dot sh here now
once this is done
so what you got is that you got a
particular uh components like you got uh
some couple of commands you have uh you
know uh got docker file super isd.com
default all these files are there now
the only thing which we need to do next
is that we need to build to the build
process
so uh if we look forward for the build
process what happens that docker build
is the command which we need to use and
uh enginix iphone image is the name
which you want to refer now you can
totally use this custom name whatever
name you feel that you want to use you
can always use that there's no
restriction on that part and once that
is on so you will be able to list down
those images that you got a new custom
docker image here so you can see that
you got the ubuntu as a base image which
is built down and the nginx iphone image
is also prepared over there
and once that is done so you are going
to create a web root folder and uh you
can run the docker run command to see
that if you really got connected with
that particular one so let's go back and
uh see that how we can create
uh the docker custom docker image here
so the moment i do this so it will pick
up the docker file over here and start
performing the activities uh the package
installations all those configurations
ones will be performed over here in a
non-interactive mode there is no
confirmation which will be asked from
the user because you cannot put that
confirmations so the command should be
in such a way that it should not take
any kind of confirmations at all from
the
end user so because tomorrow you may be
putting up these things in the jenkins
so that will not be a feasible thing for
you to put up the commands and put up
the uh confirmations during the
execution so so it's trying to run do
the package installation for the php so
fbm packages are getting installed and
here we go so we caught the
successful message now you can see it
says successfully tag this one this
means that there is no issues at all
with the docker image and when you run
the darker
images or darker images ls you can run
these two couple of commands so when you
do that you got a 203 37 mb of the size
of this image that represents that this
docker image is fully ready to run to a
secured so now what we are going to do
is that we are going to map a volume
over here with the www.html directory
during the execution of this container
because i really want to deploy some
pages and web pages there if you have
the web pages now as part of the build
process as part of the docker file you
can do a git clone also of some
repository but i don't want to do that
uh during the preparation of docker
image i just now got an environment
where the nginx is set up properly and
it's up and running there now it should
be upon me that how i want to put up my
content and all so that's the reason why
i'm putting up a kind of a folder
structure over here and sharing it with
the docker container so that the moment
i put the html files or the php files
into that local folder i should be able
to get some web page up and running
there so that's what i'm going to do
over here in this one so i'm going to
create a folder structure saying slash
web root here okay so there is a folder
structure which is created now in this
web root i will be putting up some files
and then same files will be redirected
inside the docker container with the
help of docker volume so let's go back
to the document now here
you have to run uh the uh once like i
said that
you are going to connect on that part
okay so uh you can use this port as an
at also but here edt is used so whatever
port you feel you want to use you can do
that and we are giving the container
name as test and iphone container that
also you can change and generic hyphen
image is the one which we are using so
if you use some different uh particular
image you can also use that and uh you
can see that the web root is something
which we are connecting with the www
html directory so the moment you put
some file in the web root the same file
will be reflected into the
wwhtml directory there so i'm going to
run this command and once this is done
so you can see that for the testing
purpose we are putting up some content
in the html one so i'll come to that
point also and we'll validate as of now
we should be having our container up and
running over here in this one now i'm
going to copy that command
okay and hit on so if the at port is
used so you have to make sure that port
gets uh you know gets stopped
automatically or it should not be up and
running so just double check whatever
port you're using that should be free
now when you run the docker ps command
so uh you will be able to see a docker
container up and running but if you see
like docker psyphony that gives also the
stopped and running both the containers
are there but the main thing which we
want to run is that we want to run the
docker ps command and you can see that
this is a container which is running so
8080 is the container which is running
and test hyphen container is the name
now you've got a container up and
running so you can actually do a call on
localhost colon 8080 so um this is a way
to get the content
you can get the public ip also and uh in
the browser you can put up and you can
have the content there but right now uh
we are getting the response at least uh
it's showing his 403 error formatting
error but that's fine we will be putting
up some web pages there in the rwb html
directory or we can say in local web
root directory so that we will be able
to have some content so what we can do
is that we can have some echo commands
executed so that we can have some added
some content added up into the uh
particular uh files there so let's see
that what different contents we can do
so uh you can use the vi mode also to do
a uh you know couple of files so
i'm just using this eco command
so um
the moment i go for this execution so
what happens
that a file will be created into that uh
slash web route there so um
i'm expecting that i have put up a
index.html page so if you feel that you
want to put some different page you can
always do and the moment you do the curl
now you will be able to see the same
response so whatever the things you put
up in the index.html file the same
content is going to pop up when you run
the curl command now um you want to use
some php files you want to put up some
php content all that stuff you can do it
now what i'm going to do is that rather
than just a html static content i'm
going to put some php content that
is going to help me to get a file so my
web root will have now two files so
if you feel
uh that index.html file should have some
meaningful content you can always do
that you can pull some of the websites
also you can put that into the you can
do a git clone in the web root and the
whole application will be started and uh
now
if you feel that i got a info.php file
so i can use the nut name into the url i
have to modify the url because uh
index.html file is the what as in
default name page you do if you want to
put up some different name you can
change the server configuration of nginx
and according to that it will work
so um when i do this so you will start
getting the output so this is the php
content output which is there it's a
complete information now it may look
like a very bulky content to you but
when you put up this one into the
browser into the web browser that will
be a meaningful information probably in
terms of some tables or something like
that right so um let me scroll to the
top here so you can see that it's
showing an error sorry showing in the
output and this output represents that
you got a particular php content here so
this is how we will be able to have a
container and uh you know this container
is up and running you can modify to at
any level you feel that you want to
prepare a darker image with the code
embedded also
you can have the git clone or you can
have this configuration into some git
repository have the source code also
there and then
prepare a complete bundle altogether so
this is what we have in this demo how we
can deploy a container and a container
up and running in case of the docker
here
so that was the demo right
which we took to create a docker custom
docker image on using the dockerfile on
ubuntu 20. let's have a look at what we
have in our current environment so today
when you actually have your standard
machine you have the infrastructure you
have the host operating system and you
have your applications and then when you
create a virtual environment what you're
actually doing is you're actually
creating virtual machines but those
virtual machines actually are now
sitting within a hypervisor solution
that sits still on top of your host
operating system and infrastructure and
with a docker engine what we're able to
do is we're able to actually reduce
significantly
the different elements that you would
normally have within a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the bins and the so we're able to
get rid of the guest os and we're able
to eliminate the hypervisor environment
and this is really important as we
actually start working and creating
environments that are consistent because
we want to be able to make it so it's
really easy and stable for the
environment that you have within your
dev and ops environment now critical is
getting rid of that hypervisor element
it's just a lot of overhead so let's
have a look at a container as an example
so here we actually have a couple of
examples on the right hand side we have
different containers we have one
containers running apache tomcat and
with java and second containers running
sql server and microsoft.net environment
third container is running python with
mysql these are all running just fine
within the docker engine and sitting on
top of host os which could be linux it
really could be any host os within a
consistent infrastructure and you're
able to have a solution that can be
shared easily amongst your teams so
let's have a look at an example that
you'd have today if a company is doing a
traditional java application so you have
your developers working in jboss on his
system and he's coding away and he has
to get that code over to a test and now
what will happen is that tester will
then typically in your traditional
environment then have to install jboss
on their machine and get everything
running and cool and hopefully set up
identically to the developer chances are
they probably won't have it exactly the
same but they're trying to get as close
as possible and then at some point you
want to be able to test this within your
production environment so you send it
over to a system administrator who would
then also have to install jboss on their
environment as well yeah this just seems
to be a whole lot of duplication so why
go through the problem of installing
jboss three times and this is where
things get really interesting because
the challenge you have today is that
it's very difficult to almost impossible
to have identical environment if you're
just installing software locally on
devices the developers probably got a
whole bunch of development software that
could be conflicting with the jboss
environment the tester has similar
testing software but probably doesn't
have all the development software and
certainly the system administrator won't
have all the tools that the developer
and tester have their own tools and so
what you want to be able to do is kind
of get away from the challenge you have
of having to do local installations on
three different computers and in
addition what you see is that this uses
up a lot of effort because when you're
having to install software over and over
again you just keep repeating doing
really basic foundational challenges so
this is where docker comes in and docker
is the tool that allows you to be able
to share environments from one group to
another group without having to install
software locally on a device you install
all of the code into your docker
container and simply share the container
so in this presentation we're going to
go through a few things we're going to
cover what docker actually is and then
we're going to dig into the actual
architecture of docker and kind of go
through what docker container is and how
to create a docker container and then
we'll go out through the benefits of
using docker containers and then the
commands and finalize everything out
with a brief demo so what is docker so
docker is as you'd expect because all
the software that we cover in this
series is an open source solution and it
is a container solution that allows you
to be able to containerize all of the
necessary files and applications needed
to run the solution you're building so
you can share it from different people
in your team whether it's a developer
tester or system administrator and this
allows you to have a consistent
environment from one group to the next
so let's kind of dig into that
architecture so you understand why
docker runs effectively so the docker
architecture itself is built up of two
key elements there is the docker client
and then there is a rest api connection
to a docker daemon which actually hosts
the entire environment within the docker
host and the docker daemon you have your
different containers and each one has a
link to a docker registry the docker
client itself is a rest service so as
you'd expect a rest api and that sends
command line to the docker daemon
through a terminal window or command
line interface window and we'll go
through some of these demos later on so
you can actually see how you can
actually interact with darker the docker
demo then checks the request against and
the docker components and then performs
the service that you're requesting now
the docker image itself all it really is
a collection of instructions used to
create container and again this is
consistent with all the devops tools
that we have the devops tools that we're
looking to use throughout this series of
videos are all environments that can be
scripted and this is really important
because it allows you to be able to
duplicate and scale the environments
that you want to be able to build very
quickly and effectively the agile
container itself has all of the
applications and the dependencies of
those applications in one package you
can kind of think of it as a really
effective and efficient zip file it's a
little bit more than that but it's one
file that actually has everything you
need to be able to run all of your
solutions the actual docker registry
itself is an environment for being able
to host and distribute different docker
images among your team so say for
instance you had a team of developers
that were working on multiple different
solutions so say you have a team of
developers and you have 50 developers
and they're working on five different
applications you can actually have the
applications themselves the containers
shared in the docker registry so each of
those teams at any time check out and
have the latest container of that latest
image of the code that you're working on
so let's dig into what actually is in a
container so the important part of a
docking container is that it has
everything you need to be able to run
the application it's like a virtualized
environment it has all your frameworks
and your libraries and it allows the
teams to be able to build out and run
exactly the right environment that the
developer intended what's interesting
though is the actual applications then
will run in isolation so they're not
impacting other applications that using
dependencies on other libraries or files
outside of the container because of the
architecture it really uses a lot less
space and because it's using less space
it's a much more lightweight
architecture so the files the actual
folder itself is much smaller it's very
secure highly portable and the boot up
time is incredibly fast so let's
actually get into how you would actually
create a docker container so the docker
container itself is actually built
through command line and it's built of a
file and docker image so the actual
docker file is a text file that contains
all the instructions that you would need
to be able to create that docker image
and then we'll actually then create all
of the project code with inside of that
image then the image becomes the item
that you would share through the docker
registry you would then use the command
line and we'll do this later on select
docker run and then the name of the
image to be able to easily and
effectively run that image locally and
again once you've created the dock image
you can store that in the docker
registry making it available to anybody
within your network so something to bear
in mind is that docker itself has its
own registry called docker hub and that
is a public registry so you can actually
go out and see other dock images that
have been created and access those
images as your own company you may want
to have your own private repository so
you want to be able to go ahead and
either do that locally through your own
repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of docker hub where you
can actually then share those files now
something that's also very interesting
to know is that you can have multiple
versions of a docker image so if you
have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that within your docker
registry environment okay so let's go
ahead and we're going to create a docker
image using some of our basic docker
commands and so there are essentially
really you know kind of just two
commands that you're going to be looking
for one is the build command another one
is to actually put it into your registry
which is a push command so if you want
to get a image from a docker registry
then you want to use the pull command
and a pull command simply pulls the
image from the registry and in this
example using uh nginx as our registry
and we can actually then pull the image
down to our test environment on our
local machine so we're actually running
the container within our docker
application on a local machine we're
able to then have the image run exactly
as it would in production and then you
can actually use the run command to
actually use the docker image on your
local machine so just a you know a few
interesting tidbits about the docking
container once the container is created
a new layer is formed on top of the
docker image layers called the container
layout each container has a separate
read write container layer and any
changes made in that docking container
is then reflected upon the particular
container layer and if you want to
delete the container layer the container
layer also gets deleted as well so you
know why would using docker and
containers be of benefit to you well you
know some of the things that are useful
is that containers have no external
dependencies for the applications they
run once you actually have the container
running locally it has everything it
needs to be able to run the application
so there's no having to install
additional pieces of software such as
the example we gave with jpos at the
beginning of the presentation now the
containers are really lightweight so it
makes it very easy to share the
containers amongst your teams whether
it's a developer whether it's a tester
whether it's somebody on your operations
environment it's really easy to share
those containers amongst your entire
team different data volumes can be
easily reused and shared among
multiple containers and again this is
another big benefit and this is a
reflection of the lightweight nature of
your containers the container itself
also runs in isolation
which means that it is not impacted by
any dependencies you may have on your
own local environment so it's a
completely sandboxed environment so some
of the questions you might ask is you
know can you run multiple containers
together without the need to start each
one individually and you know what yes
you can with docker compose docking
compose allows you to run multiple
containers in a single service and again
this is a reflection on the lightweight
nature of containers within the docker
environment so we're going to end our
presentation by looking at some of the
basic commands that you'd have within
docker so we have here on the left hand
side we have a doctor container and then
the command for each item we're actually
going to go ahead and use some of these
commands in the demo that we're going to
do after this presentation you'll see
that in a moment but just you know some
of the basic commands we have are
committing the docket image into the
container kill is a you know standard
kill command to you know terminate one
or more of the running containers so
they stop working then restart those
containers but suddenly you can look at
all the image all of the commands here
and try them out for yourself so we're
going to go ahead and start a demo of
how to use the basic commands to run
docker so to do this we're going to open
up terminal window or command line
depending whether you're running linux
pc or mac and we're going to go ahead
and the first thing we want to do is see
what our docker image lists are so we
can go sudo docker images and this will
give us well first we'll enter in our
password so let's go enter that in and
this one that gives a list of our docker
images and here are the docker images
that have already been created in the
system and we can actually go ahead and
actually see the processes that are
actually running so i'm going to go
ahead and open up this window a little
bit more but this will show you the
actual processes and the containers that
we actually have and so on the far left
hand side you see under names we have
learn simply learn be unscored cool
these are all just different ones that
we've been working on so let's go ahead
and create a docker image so i'm going
to do sudo
docker
run
dash d
dash p
0.0.0
go on 80 column 80
ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run
an ubuntu
image and this will run the latest image
and what we have here is a hash number
and this hash number is a unique name
that defines the
container that we've just created and we
can go ahead and we can check to make
sure that the container actually is
present so we're going to do
sudo docker.ps and this actually shows
some there so it's not in a running
state right now but that doesn't mean
that we don't have it so let's list out
all the containers that are both running
and in the exit state so let's do sucker
ps dash a and
this lists all the containers that i
have running on my machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running state and in the
exit state and here we see one that we
just created about a minute ago and it's
called learn
and these are all running ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and
there we go
so let's change that to that new doc
container to a running state so scroll
down
and we're going to type sudo
docker
run
dash
i t dash dash
name
my
um
so this is going to be the new container
name it's going to be my docker so this
is how we name our docker environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
ubuntu
and bin dash bash
and it's now in our route and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my docker container so sudo
docker
start
my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker
return and that started that docker
image
and let's go ahead and check against the
other running docker images to make sure
it's running correctly so sudo docker
ps
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side you actually see my
docker along with the other docker
images that we created that's been
running for 13 seconds
quite fast so we want to rename the
container let's use the command sudo
docker
rename we can take another docker image
this is grab this one and we'll put it
in rename
and we'll rename
and put in the old container name which
is image and then we'll put in the new
container name and let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
proved something called image is now
called purple
so do sudo docker
ps
to list all of our docker images
and we scroll up and there there we go
purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop containers so we're
going to write sudo docker
stop
and then we have to put in the container
name
and we'll put in my docker the container
that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and what you see is that it's not listed
in the active images it's uh not on the
list on the far right hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still
there as an image is just
not in an active stage it's what's known
as in an exit stage
so here we go
and there's my docker it's in an exit
state so that happened 27 seconds
ago so if we want to to remove a
container we can use the following
command
so sudo docker
rm
remove
my docker
and that will remove it from the exit
state
and we're going to go ahead and
double check that
and
yep
yep
it's not not listed there under exit
state anymore
it's gone
and there we go
there that's where it used to be
all right let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do sudo kill and
then the name of the container
i think one of them is called yellow
let's just check and see if that's gonna
kill it
oops no i guess we don't have one called
yellow so let's find out name of the
container that we actually have so sudo
docker
kill
oh we're going to list out the ones that
are running oh okay there we go now
yellow isn't in that list so let's take
i know let's take simply learn and so we
can actually go ahead and let's write
sudo docker
kill
simply learn
and that will actually kill an active
docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now that
they simply learn container is not
active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
docker container
did you know before docker and
containers were introduced companies had
been deploying their software either on
a bare metal or in a virtual machine
but they had been facing a lot of
challenges in managing orchestration of
services instant deployment of services
on different platforms and maintaining
multi-host applications
all these issues were solved with the
help of docker and its containers
in this docker and container tutorial
session we will give you the conceptual
exposure to docker and its containers
consider an example where a company
develops a code on oracle weblogic
software
in the company a developer installs
oracle weblogic software on his computer
system
once the application is developed he
shares it with the other team for
testing the code
now the tester repeats the weblogic
installation process which was done by
the developer earlier on his system
later the same application file is
shared with the production team
to host the application the system admin
must install oracle weblogic on his
system
let me ask you an important question
here
have you noticed that the same weblogic
installation process was done thrice
but what could be the reason behind it
due to the difference in computer
environments web logic doesn't work on
the other systems so installation is
done separately on three different
computers
but this process of installing the same
software on different systems consume a
lot of time and effort in order to avoid
these problems docker containers were
introduced before we start with the
concept of docker containers let me
explain you what a docker is
docker is an open source platform that
helps a user package and application and
its dependencies into a docker container
to develop and deploy software docker
provides suitable frameworks for
different applications
since every application has a framework
with an appropriate version this space
also can be utilized for a new software
application along with its required
framework
as a result docker makes more efficient
use of system resources
containerization includes all
dependencies frameworks libraries etc
required to run an application in an
efficient and bug-free manner
with docker containers applications can
work efficiently in different computer
environments
after this let's talk about the benefits
the benefits of docker containers show
up in many places
containers are widely used because of
their services
since it's lightweight it can be easily
deployed and executed on other computer
environments regardless of their host
operating system or configurations
containers take up less disk space and
relatively faster in executing
applications
containers run applications in isolation
and also share the operating system
kernel with other containers
by default containers are entirely
secure
container policies ensure all
applications are highly secure including
the docker infrastructure containers are
highly portable and can run anywhere
across the docker ecosystem
multiple software can be encapsulated in
a single container and can be easily
deployed to different platforms
as soon as a container is created it can
be deployed into any other system where
docker is already installed
on that system the application will
perform exactly as it did in the
previous environment
containers take less boot up time
these containers save time in the
deployment process of an application
here comes the next important concept
virtualization
virtualization is the technology of
running a virtual instance of a computer
system or running a virtual version of a
computer resource like hardware software
storage devices and computer network
resources on the cloud
a virtual machine is an isolated
computing environment that allows
developers to use an operating system
via a pc or computer system
let's now talk about some of the
significant benefits of using docker
containers
the first benefit is the lack of
external dependency
containers have no external dependency
for applications to run
containers will just be used to host and
run the applications
as containers are lightweight they are
quickly shipped to other computers and
executed in different computer
environments regardless of their host
operating systems
containers are lightweight they share a
kernel across containers and therefore
use less memory space the next benefit
is the volume
volumes are also a convenient way to
share data within the docker ecosystem
volumes can be more safely shared among
other containers
and the last one is isolation
containers run application in isolation
and share the operating system kernel
with other containers
in containers the host operating system
provides isolation along with the
applications microservices can also be
more easily isolated
next comes the most important topic of
the session
that is
containerization versus virtualization
containerization and virtualization are
two different ways to deploy
applications and microservices in a
computer environment in vms a hypervisor
is a firmware layer that enables
multiple operating system to run side by
side
a virtual machine has unstable
performance as multiple running vms run
simultaneously on the same machine
also the efficiency of hypervisors is
not as good as that of the host
operating system due to the extra layer
in vm an application takes quite a long
time to start
as you can see there are two
architectures on the screen
on the left hand side is vm and on the
right hand side is the docker
on the left hand side as you see there
is one host operating system a
hypervisor and guest operating system
shared by all containers along with
their dependencies
in vm guest operating system occupies
more space and leads to unstable
performance
guest operating system makes virtual
machines less efficient than the
physical machines
guest operating system makes a vm slow
because they access the hardware
indirectly
on the other hand docker is efficient
unlike vms docker doesn't have a
hypervisor or guest operating system
docker consists of containers
these containers are efficient and are
easily portable across different
platforms
in vms the hypervisor has a scalability
issue
the hypervisor creates a security risk
as well
well
did you know that according to vitana
the chances of experiencing a data
breach while using virtualization are
high
well that could lead to a major problem
for companies who are still using
virtual machines
next
let's have a closer look at the docker
containers
in case you are unsure what kind of
applications can be added to a container
then look on the right hand side
a container can package apache tomcat
and its dependency that is java
programming language in a single file
later a user can ship the container to
another computer environment and run the
code without any issue
it's usually challenging to understand
the differences between container and vm
so let me explain to you the differences
in layman terms
as shown the virtual machine is compared
to a bangla and the container is
considered as an apartment
in a bungalow amenities like water lift
roof etc cannot be shared with the
neighbors
likewise vm is less efficient it doesn't
share its resources with other
applications
on the other hand containers share their
amenities binaries and libraries with
the neighboring containers just like a
person who resides in an apartment
the bank law is owned by a single person
it cannot have tenants
likewise virtual machines cannot run
multiple applications
on the other side docker runs multiple
containers just like numerous tenants
reside in a single building
next let's look at the table in which we
have made a direct comparison between
virtual machines and containers
in docker containers data volumes can be
shared and reused among multiple
containers
either docker cli or docker api manages
the volumes
also the volume drivers give the
facility of storing volumes on remote
hosts or cloud providers
vm is a container based model it
utilizes user space along with the
kernel space of an operating system
so data volumes cannot be shared
containers have a better performance as
they are hosted in a single docker
engine
docker provides the most substantial
default isolation capabilities among the
other configuration tools making the
performance better
virtual machines run multiple vms at a
time which leads to unstable performance
docker is much more efficient than
hypervisors
docker enables developers to wrap ship
quickly and run applications as a
lightweight and portable container
on the other hand virtual machines are
less efficient
docker containers can run multiple
containers on a system but virtual
machine can run only a limited number of
vms on a system
multiple software can be encapsulated in
a single container and can be easily
deployed to different platforms
containers are easily portable across
other platforms but virtual machines
have compatibility issues while porting
others across different platforms
moving on to the next one
let's have a look at the architecture of
docker
a docker or docker engine consists of
two major components
docker client and docker demon
these two components are connected to
each other with the help of the rest api
now let's take a look at the
architecture
a docker client has no components but a
docker daemon consists of a docker host
docker daemon docker registry
and docker images
docker client is a service that uses
rest api to send commands to docker
demon through cli commands
rest api is a primary mode of
communication between docker client and
docker daemon
docker engine or docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using docker
components
docker daemon checks the client's
request and communicates with the docker
components to perform a service
docker engine or docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using docker
components
docker image is also one of the
essential components of docker
a docker image is a file of instructions
that are used to create containers
a docker image is built using a file
called dockerfile
a docker image is a template of
instructions that is used to create
containers
coming to containers
a docker container is a portable
executable package that includes
applications and their dependencies
docker containers are lightweight
because they do not require an extra
layer of a hypervisor and run directly
on the host operating system
there is a service in docker called
docker compose
a docker compose is used for running
multiple containers as a single service
in compose service each container runs
in isolation but can interact with each
other with no limitations
talking about docker registry it is a
service used for hosting and
distributing docker images among users
docker registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among users
let's move on and understand how to
create a docker container
first ensure to set up your development
environment then you can begin to
develop containerized applications
for that you need to create a docker
image a docker image can be created
using a dockerfile a docker image is
created using a build command
you must build a docker image that
contains the code of what your
application needs to run
in simple terms a docker image contains
all the project's code
with docker image you can run the code
to develop docker containers
once the docker image is created ensure
to store it in the docker registry using
the docker push command
once a docker image is created you can
either store it in a docker hub or in a
repository docker also has its default
registry called docker hub
there are multiple docker images
available in the registry and all can be
retrieved through the dockable command
as soon as a docker image is retrieved
from the docker registry you can build
new containers
moving on to the next one let's
understand how docker containers work
in docker a dockerfile is used to build
the image using the build command and
that image is stored in the registry
using the push command
when you run the pull command docker
image is retrieved from the registry
while a single container is built using
docker image through the run command
did you know that a new layer is formed
on top of the docker image layers called
the container layer when a container is
created
this new layer consists of the
application and its dependencies
in docker each container has a separate
reader write container layer
any modifications done in a docker
container are reflected upon the
container layer
suppose a container is deleted the
container layer also gets permanently
deleted
this was the simple functionality of
docker and containers
in this one we are going to see that how
we can make use of the docker files to
prepare a docker image and using which
we can create a docker container now
let's talk about what exactly is in
dockerfile here now uh dockerfile is a
concept which is being used as in build
script so it's being used so that we can
have a build a script there so this will
definitely helps uh to see that how we
can go for a build of a docker image a
custom docker image
now when we are using the dockerfile uh
concept so it really helps to prepare a
kind of docker image
so doc image is the end result when you
are going for the mechanism when you're
going for the docker file build up here
so dockerfile is a build script which is
available for preparing the custom
docker containers because not every
docker image is available on docker hub
so some containers you have to use some
images you have to use to work on that
part
now docker file is a very simple
straightforward text file which is
available there and it's basically used
to build up custom docker images so
docker file is basically used to prepare
a once so when you're running the docker
build so it's actually going to build up
a particular custom docker image and
that will be given to you
so docker
image is the whole build process which
is being done
so it's a custom
process which is available and being
done over here in this case
so you got a docker file you run the
docker build command and that's how you
will be able to get a docker image so
whatever these steps you are having in
the docker file that will be processed
one by one and as a end result you will
be able to get a full flesh docker image
over here in this case
right now let's talk about the syntax of
the docker file so docker file is equal
to commands commands and the arguments
so whatever the things you want to put
up so in the docker file you can do that
and as a part of the execution so you
will be able to get a particular end
result
now it's a kind of a mechanism where we
feel that how the execution and the
modifications can be done
so uh the uh comments which we are
trying to do over here is that you know
we can put up the whatever the comments
we want to put in the case of docker
files we can do that comments is a
standard process in uh preparing any
particular file or any kind of code
because it helps us to understand that
for what reason we are preparing that
particular line then uh we have the uh
particular run statements the commands
are there so you can see that we are
running a particular command called eco
so using the run attribute we are
basically going ahead and running a
particular command into our system as
part of our docker file over here
now how to build up the docker images
using the dockerfile so um you know
docker file is uh just a template which
is available there where we are putting
up that what are the different steps we
want to follow and these steps when we
follow one by one step by step so that's
where we will be able to get a
particular final docker container over
here
so docker image is getting converted as
a docker container and we are getting a
docker container as an end result
now um docker file is being built up and
uh stored in the version control system
and uh this particular docker files uh
when we are processing so it prepares a
respective a specific uh
image layer over here and this image
layer is something which is uh
benefiting us that how the executions
can be done and how we can manage on
that part
so
that really helps us to see that how the
executions and the things can be managed
and that can help us to see that how the
management of the things can be
performed as such
so uh dockerfile is a very good concept
which is there using which you can
prepare any kind of custom docker image
and it can be very easily handled also
and it's in fully automated mechanism
you can use it in inside the cicd
pipelines for automating the docker
images
right now it's uh docker image is a
layer by lay mechanism which is there in
which we have multiple layers each and
every layer we are doing some specific
uh entry some specific task or some you
know changes we are trying to deploy in
part of our these layers right so uh
you can use the uh particular docker
build command to perform the executions
and you will be able to get any
particular response an output will be
given back to you so docker file is
basically helping you to see that how
the executions can be done and you will
be able to get an end result over here
so the docker image is the final result
which we are getting when we are talking
about the docker file here
right so these are all read-only formats
which are available you cannot modify
these directly but yes with the help of
docker file you can do whatever the
changes you want to deploy on these
docker images
right so uh this is a small example
where we are using a base image as an 1
to 18.04 so we are using the from
attribute to specify that yes we are
going to use the ubuntu 18.04 here then
we are pulling our
the file into the directory we are
transferring a particular file inside
the docker container and then we are
running our make command and then cmd
attribute is there using which we can
run the command on the runtime on the
docker container so these are a very
basic example but eventually when we are
done with this docker image we will be
able to get a four layer uh docker image
over here because there are four steps
and then hence it will be providing you
a particular four layers in your final
docker image over here so layer by layer
these changes will be done during the
build process and in fact using the
docker history command you can see that
layers these layers information also
right so layer one is ubuntu 18.04 layer
2 is pull
and the third layer is there where we
can run the
make command to you know run this file
which we have pulled on and then the
finally the last one is there where we
are running like using the cmd parent so
the difference between run and cmd is
that cmd will run only when you run a
docker container so run attribute will
be executed during the docker build part
so this is a pretty much is a way that
how we can go for the execution of a
docker file and how you know we can go
for the build up of a custom docker
image over here so these are the for
some couple of attributes which we are
using in the docker file here
right now let's talk about the entry
point over here now entry point allows
you to specify a command along with the
parameters right so uh let's say that
you want to run a particular command uh
over here in the docker container so
entry point is something which you can
use to refer to that so application is
the command which you're trying to run
and then you can give some arguments to
that and argument one is what you are
trying to run over here
so entry point is very important because
that eventually helps to see that how
the executions can be done and the
implementations uh will be done over
here in this case
right so you can see like you can run a
command called eco and then you can use
the parameters also it's not like only
the commands can be used but you can in
fact use the arguments also now add is
an attribute which is available in the
docker file which is primary used to see
to uh transfer the files from the host
machine inside the docker image
now let's see that you are trying to
prepare your own custom docker image
apart from the dependencies you need the
source code also right so the source
code needs to be transferred inside the
docker image and for that reason we can
use the add attribute so add attribute
requires a source and destination source
will always be the path on which on the
testing on the host machine the files
are present so we can give that and
destination is the folder which is
available inside the
particular docker container where we
want to store the files so you can use
the example over here just like this you
can use and you can give two entries one
is the source one is the destination and
once that is done so you will be able to
see your files being uh stored up in the
destination directory once the final
docker image is prepared
then we have enb attribute uh now enb is
something which is used to set up some
environment variables
which is required of course for the
docker image uh for the application
which is running inside the docker image
now environment variables are something
which you can hard core during the
docker build one but using the when you
are running like when you're creating
the docker container at that time also
you can overwrite the these environment
variables so environment variables are
very important because uh first during
the build process you can hard code some
values but if you really want to change
them during the run time that also is
being supported by the environment
variables
so
most of the times we use it as an kind
of a keep value pair just like in linux
we use
we use to set up a particular
environment variable so the key value
pair is being used in case of enb
attribute
maintainer is there where we can
describe that what is the details about
the author these are the fields which is
available in the top so where we can
give the the author name and the author
you know details like email id and all
so that we know that who is the person
who is maintaining this particular file
and we can reach out to them in case any
issues are there for the docker files am
right so that is what we have here in
this one so now we are going to see that
how we can go for a small demo and
docker file and we can go for the
implementation of this
particular docker file and prepare a
custom docker image so let's just wait
on that part
so let's see some demo here now in this
one we have got two examples one is the
python one is the notice one so first of
all what we need to do is that we need
to process the python one here so this
is the sample docker file which we have
got here for the python now all this one
requires a python file which is already
present on the server and we are going
to transfer we are going to copy this
content over here that will this is the
specific docker file content which is
available to us and all we need to do is
that we need to put this content across
the server so that we will be able to
build our custom docker image so let's
go back to the server so here we have
already got the python file which is
present so we have to create a docker
file here which will have the steps
related to the docker image preparation
over here so we will be including some
steps over here that these are the
different steps we want to configure we
want to set up over here in this one so
python 3.6.4 is the version of the
python which we want to configure and
then we are going to transfer some files
into slash app we are also setting up
the working directory as slash app and
ultimately we are running a command
called pip install flask to do the
installation of flash package and then
we are starting the uh specific
applications on that part so i'm going
to save this file and once i save this
file so all we need to do is that we
need to create a custom docker image
right so right now there is no image
which is available over here and it's in
complete md installs so i'm going to run
a command called docker
build
hyphen t
hyphen m dot so docker build is the
typical command but hyphen t is for the
tag that what kind of docker image you
want to build and then we are giving a
image name and then we are specifying
dot over there now once we are done with
that so it will pick up all the things
one by one the basic docker image is
being pulled down then some sequence of
steps is being executed so it's a
step-by-step process which is happening
over here in this case and we are then
transferring some files in the slash app
and then ultimately we are going for the
pip install flask so it's installing
those packages and at the end the final
docker image will be prepared and will
be given back to us so we will be able
to get this uh docker images over here
when we run that command we will be able
to find out that we got our custom
docker image also available and as you
can see that the base darker image is
also available in this one but yes we
have added up like around 10 mb of work
we have added on top of this python
based docker image here so that's how we
are able to do the processing over here
in this case in this setup so that's
what we
can do to prepare a custom environment
of python with the help of the docker
file here now let's see that we will be
uh proceeding on with the node.js to see
that if the node.js uh kind of setup
also can be done now for node.js again
of course we got uh the uh specific
dockerfile which is present so we can
process that but let's create a new
folder over there so i'm going to create
for a new
node.js folder so that we can create the
work all together in this one so i'm
going to run a command called npm minute
which is the command to initialize any
empty project in case of node now you
can typically bring down some real code
also or you can say that i want to
process an empty a project so you can
give the configurations you can give the
custom names but i want to process with
these as default name itself so
ultimately it's going to create an
entries like you will be able to see
like all these uh values which we are
not providing these standards value will
be picked up for the specific code and
at the end you will be able to get a
package.json file created over here in
this one now you can actually bring down
the steps that how you can perform or
you can build up a custom node.js based
docker image now these docker files is
giving you the capability that you can
convert a full-fledged application which
is deployable on the virtual machine you
can actually convert them in the format
of the docker containers over here in
this one so that's what we are going to
get over here with this uh particular
setup are these mechanisms
so let's go back to the document and see
that what exactly we can copy the docker
file
so we have got this docker file over
here so all we can do is that we can
copy this one so once we copy this uh
specific file here so all we can do is
that we can transfer uh these files into
the onto the server we can convert it
into the docker file there so that we
will be able to set up the
configurations and we can perform the
setup around that so docker file is
again we want to create and we want to
set up on that here so let's go back to
the server
so here we want to create a docker file
and we want to set up the files inside
that these are the different files which
is being available which is being
configured over here in this one so we
are running like node server.js which is
a master file so we are doing an expose
of 8080 then of course we have a copy
commands which is there then npm install
command is there and then package.json
file is also there now what you need to
really do is that you need to go for a
server.js file which is available in
which you can configure that how the
setup needs to be done and how the
configurations should be performed there
because that's a command that's a script
which is going to be executed within the
container so let's copy the content now
i'm going to copy this content over here
which is like a sample node.js code
which is available so i'm just copy this
one and transfer it to the server
so
server.js file we have to create here
just like we did in case of the python
because this is the source we want to
transfer inside the
docker container
so this is what we have got now i'm
going to uh transfer like uh i want to
change this port value from 5000 to 8080
because that's what it's configured in
the dockerfile of course you can
configure 5000 also depending on your
requirement you can do that
configurations
now you have got uh these two files over
here in this one so all you need to do
is that you need to run like docker
build
hyphen t nodejs hyphen app and dot so it
will automatically pick up like what
exactly it will uh you know go for the
node.js basic docker image over here so
that will be processed over here in this
one so step by step it will be able to
do the configurations
so first of all it will download the
basic docker image which is um quite uh
more incisive over here in this one once
it's downloaded onto your system then it
will proceed further with the build
activity on
processing the docker file performing
the execution so all that stuff will be
performed with this help of this docker
build process over here so it's going to
process it one by one in this one
and it's going to the next step where
it's transferring some of the files like
creating some working directory
transferring the files uh putting up
there and running the npm install
command
and then ultimately it will expose the
port and then it will have the
cmd attribute configured over there so
this is basically typically trying to
portrait it how a particular docker
image can be built up and of course once
the build is successful you can validate
it with the help of docker images here
so this is the app docker image which
has been prepared of 911 mb and uh we
have got it like a final package where
the runtime is also there and the code
base is also available now you can
pretty much
experience it like with other actual
source course like you can generate the
download some pre-configured node.js
websites or the source codes here and
you can try to run them onto the docker
container so that you can get the full
uh the complete idea about that how it
goes on but right now the uh these are
the basic docker image which you can
prepare and you can build up over here
in this one so that's how it really
works on for you let's dig into what a
docker swarm is so a docker swarm is
essentially a tool that allows you to
very easily create and schedule
multiple docker nodes so really two or
more docker nodes and you can have quite
a large number of docker nodes in a
single swarm
each node itself is actually a docker
daemon and that demon is able to
interact with the docker api and have
all the benefits of being a full docker
environment one of the other advantages
you have is that the each docker
container within the swarm can then be
deployed and managed but as a node in
that entire clustered environment so
what we have here is a breakdown of the
five key elements within a docker
environment you have the docker
container you have the daemon the docker
images and the docker client and docker
registry so the docker game itself is
what does all the work interacting with
the actual host operating system to be
able to manage the docker containers so
if we look here here we have set up an
environment where we have three docket
containers being run with docker and
what we want to be able to do is it be
able to interact with the environment
because what would happen if we actually
have something changed in our
environment so we have the environment
set up as a docker swarm and one of our
containers fails what we're able to do
is use the swarm to be able to correct
that failure so the docker swarm manager
is able to come in and reschedule
containers and as you would imagine the
actual swarm note has full backups and
full redundancy for any kind of failures
that would happen and we would do all of
this work through command line interface
so let's go through some of the features
that you have within the actual docker
swarm itself so a key feature for docker
swarm is that it is fully decentralized
which means that it makes it very easy
for teams to be able to access and
manage the environment as you would
expect as well is that the communication
that happens between the manager and
client nodes within the swarm is highly
secure and of course this is really just
a fundamental that you should have for
any kind of solution but it is good to
know that docker swarm has that built in
there is also auto load balancing within
your environment you can actually script
that into how you write out and
structure your swarm environment and
that load balancing then also allows you
to then convert that swarm environment
into a highly scalable infrastructure
and then rollback task allows you to be
able to roll back environments to
previous safe environments so if say
something does get pushed out and
something breaks you're able to
immediately roll back into a safe
environment so each of the containers
are pushed out and and are controlled
using services and they actually have to
be breast services which make it very
easy for you to be able to integrate
within your environment
and each of the different services
contains a group of containers of the
same image now by having this structure
it allows you to be able to scale your
application appropriate to the demands
on your service so if you have a service
that needs to have a significantly
larger number of services for it to run
you can actually scale that
appropriately and they can be either geo
or demand based one of the requirements
for setting up a docker swarm is you
must have at least one node deployed so
the way that the architecture is set up
is that you have a manager node and a
client node and there must be one of
each for the entire environment to be
able to work effectively so you know
here we are just jumping ahead of sales
a little bit we have two types of nodes
in the docker swan we have the manager
node and we have the worker node which
is the client that does the actual uh
execution of the tasks the manager node
very similar to other systems that we've
talked about on simplylearn allows you
to actually control and manage the
actual tasks that are being executed by
the worker nodes and the working nodes
as you can imagine and then actually
execute the instructions that the
manager are sending out to it so here we
have a situation where we can illustrate
what would happen with a manager node
sending out commands to different worker
nodes the manager is fully aware of the
status of the entire swarm environment
at all times this is because of the
two-way secure communication that's
going from the manager to the worker
environment the workers as you'd expect
are accepting tasks that are being sent
from the manager so the manager sends
out a task saying that you need to be
running as a my sequel environment then
the worker node will then convert to my
sequel environment and all of these
environments are scripted and controlled
by you as the manager the actual worker
nodes themselves actually have a client
agent and that client will then
communicate all different states of the
infrastructure back to the manager so
that any time the manager node is in
full control of the entire swarm the
manager is the controller of this
environment and so you always want to be
able to ensure that the manager has full
access to all the work that's happening
within the swarm and this allows you as
the manager to be able to control your
swarm and very quickly be able to react
to any changes without having to rely on
manual installations of software and
hardware and as we covered earlier on
there is a rest api that uses the
communication over http from the manager
to the worker node it's interesting to
note that it is a rest api because if
you wanted to you could actually
integrate that api into custom
applications and even then create
automated docker images to be created on
demand from third-party solutions that
you may want to create so one of the
things that's a really a big advantage
with having a swarm is that once you've
actually created the swarm any of the
services that you create can be accessed
by any node of the same cluster one of
things you do have to do though is you
have to specify what container image
that you're going to use when you're
creating a new service and you can do
that either through a centralized docker
hub environment or through your own
private docker hub environment one of
the things that's interesting is that
you can set up commands and services to
be either global or replicated a global
service will allow you to run a service
consistently on every node within the
swarm whereas a replicated service will
only push out functionality and tasks to
specific worker nodes within a swarm so
you may be asking yourself hey isn't a
service and task the same thing no
they're they're kind of not in the
docker world and the difference is is a
service is a description of a task for
the state whereas the actual task is the
work that needs to get done and that's
the differentiator here so what you can
do as a docker user is you actually
create services and then you can then
define when you want them to start as
tasks now what's interesting is that
when you do assign a task to a node that
same task cannot be assigned to another
node also what's interesting is that you
can actually have multiple managers
within a docker swarm environment if you
do however go down this part you have to
elect one manager to be the primary
manager and the other managers to be
secondary managers in many ways those
secondary managers are really
similar in concept to worker nodes in
which they have the capability of a
manager but they are dependent on that
single primary manager to be able to
provide the right instructions and for
services and tasks to the entire swarm
environment so if we kind of recap some
of these we have a command line
interface which allows us to create and
connect via apis and that those apis
that we connect to in our small
environment allows us to do
orchestration via tasks and services the
task allocation allows us to allocate
work to tasks via their ip address which
allows them to execute them on the work
and then the worker nodes themselves
have to connect to the manager node to
be able to check when tasks come in so
that they are keeping a consistent
communication back and forth across the
entire swarm and then the final stage is
to actually execute the tasks that have
been assigned from the manager note to
the work note so that you have a
successful execution of the solution
you're looking to build all right so
with that said let's go ahead and we're
going to do a demo so we're gonna go
ahead and do a demo and showing how you
can run docker swarm for this you'll
need to have both a virtual environment
running your manager and your working
environment so here we have our worker
and uh here we have our manager so we're
just going to open up terminal window
and we're going to go into the manager
for terminal window
so the following command here is used to
initialize docker swan we're just going
to type this in so sudo docker swarm
init
and we purchase the ip address for the
network we're connecting to
and open in our password
and here we have now connected
and this is our manager node and what we
want to be able to highlight is the
specific token which identifies the
docker swarm environment and this is our
token right here so we're going to copy
that
because we'll need to use that for our
worker environment so here we are in the
work environment and we'll use the token
that we just copied and as a way to be
able to connect to the manager and
connect to the docker swarm environment
and so sudo
we'll paste in the docker swamp and
we'll join that
and now here we shows that we have
joined the swarm environment as a worker
and now
we're in the manager we can actually
show that we actually have
that worker in the environment so
there's docker node ls to list out all
of the
items in that environment
sorry we actually did them in the wrong
area so we're on the right pseudo docker
node ls to list out
all the nodes in the swarm
and there you are you see we've actually
connected the worker to the manager node
and both
are active and the manager is the leader
and the worker virtualbox is in the
swarm
okay we're going to go ahead and create
a new service so docker swan create and
we're going to just change the name
to hello world for the new service and
we use the alpine image from docker.com
it takes just a moment for it to run
there we go
and there we go services converged
so what we have now is a new service
that has been created
let's go ahead and we'll list out the
services
and here we have our new hello world
service
and we go ahead and check the duck in
containers and we're going to do
docker ps and
here's our alpine it's running the
latest image
and that's the docker container id
and we can see that it was just updated
and so we're going to do is use the same
command in the worker node
and make sure everything is working over
there
so go over to our worker paste that in
so what we see here is there is no image
or container created because it's not in
the worker node it would be in the
manager node
so we can go ahead and create the new
service
and we'll make the mode global and that
way the service is available across all
of the swarm
so we're just going to execute that work
it takes a moment
and
there we are
done work has been completed and we have
the two different ids which shows that
two different services are running and
if we go back to the worker mode and we
run sudo docker ps again and there we
are now we see that we have the hello
world
new virtual environment has been added
with the image of alpine and we also
have the new token id for that
if we want to kill a node from the swan
we can use the following command which
is suitable docker swarm leave dash dash
force
and that will force the nodes to leave
the swarm one of the questions that will
come up though is what if you want to
use two containers in a single service
and an example this might be like a web
server that is using a database but the
database may be in one container and the
web server may be in another container
which is very typical for your own web
and database infrastructure so very
similar um scenario but how would you do
this with doc app so by using just
docker itself it's actually very
difficult to do this you can do it but
it's just very time consuming and just
not a very good use of your productivity
but with docker compose you can actually
do the whole process quite quickly and
easily and hence the reason why we have
docker compose to allow you to have two
or more docker containers running in the
same environment being able to
communicate as if they were running in a
production environment so let's dig into
what docker compose is so let's consider
a scenario that you'd have today so
mintra is a
fashion website similar to amazon and
you go to mentor with your web browser
and
on that website you would go through a
number of activities such as logging
into your account browsing a catalog
you'd have your checkout application
server and you go through the
process of building out an application
behind each of these services are
different products such as you know to
have an account database you'd have a
product database different checkout
processes and these would all be run
behind the scenes and each of these can
be considered a micro service so the
more microservices you build into your
environment the more complexity you're
adding and the more of value it would be
to have each of these services in their
own container but as a developer you
want to be able to jump from one
container to another container so your
login account can then be passed on to
your product catalog and then be able to
move through the whole process so the
environment that you would see today
would be small like what we're showing
right now where you'd have your server
and your database and you may have a
server running on apache tomcat or a sql
server you'd have different databases
and you'd want to be able to have each
of those in their own containerized
environment so the way that duck compose
runs is that it works as a single
service so you have the docker compose
running multiple containers but the
perception is of a single service run
the thing that's great though is that
each of those containers will run in
there in isolation and but they can
interact with each other so unlike a
normal docker environment where you have
multiple docker images running
completely in isolation of each other
these are images that will run in
isolation but can interact with each
other the doc compose files are very
easy to write they're all written with a
scripting language called yaml and yaml
is an xml based language it actually
stands for yet another markup language
but it's an xml based language and it's
very easy to use the great thing about
learning yaml is that a lot of open
source tools in the devops environment
use yaml as the scripting lane and then
finally in docker compose as a user you
can actually go and and trigger all your
services within the containers to start
with a single command as you can imagine
this dramatically reduces the amount of
work that you as a developer have to do
so let's take an example of if you're
running a container one with a ninjx
server and one with the redis database
uh you can create a yaml docker compose
file that actually has the instructions
on the containers needed to build out
both environments and then you can run
each of those environments separately
but have them connected as a single
service so the benefits of docking
compose is that you have a single host
deployment environment you can run this
all on one piece of hardware you can
have a quick and easy configuration
using yaml scripts the productivity that
you get as a developer significantly
increases because you're not having to
have time wasted trying to configure
just traditional docker containers by
themselves you now have a way of being
able to interact with those containers
and then finally security is at the
center of all of these containers so
each of those containers are completely
isolated from each other and they are
controlled with the same level security
that you'd have with a traditional
docker image but there is a question
here around docket compose isn't it
similar in concept to dock a swarm
because at a high level it kind of seems
like both do the same thing and the
answer is well actually no they're
different there are similarities but
there are also differences and
particularly for a developer these
differences will really start coming out
in scale as you start working on your
solutions so let's look at docker
compose right so docker compose will
allow you to create multiple containers
on a single host and that's the
important part having a single host
which is maybe your development pc with
docker swarm it also allows you to
create multiple containers however you
have to manage those multiple containers
on multiple hosts which makes a lot of
sense if you are running an operations
environment but not so much if you're
doing a development environment and
docker compose is scripted with yaml
which is very easy for you to be able to
control your scripts docker swamp
doesn't have a scripting technology like
yaml so it's a little bit harder to work
with so what we have here is just some
basic commands that allow you to get up
and started working with docker compose
and in our next demo we're going to take
you through how to use all of those
commands so we're going to go ahead and
do a demo on how to use docker compose
um the first thing you want to do is
check that you have docker installed so
what we're going to do is we're going to
open up the command window and we're
going to type in docker you'll be able
to see now that we have docker installed
uh if you don't have docker installed go
ahead and install docker you can go to
google search to install docker and
they'll give you the instructions for
that we also have videos that we've
already done if once you have docker
installed then you want to do a google
search on docker compose or go to the
docker.com website and select for the
compose section and look for the install
docker compose instructions so we
already have another tab which has the
instructions already installed you'll
see on the left hand side there are a
number of docker tools you want to
expand the docker compose section select
install compose and then on the right
hand side you'll have different install
options for mac windows and linux uh if
you're installing on those platforms
make sure you copy the correct command
line so there's a couple of command
lines you want to
copy copy the first one over and we
paste that in and it's going to go ahead
and download all of the files for
compose it takes a while but uh we have
to get another file so while it's
downloading we'll go get the other
command line just go back and grab it
real quick it was a little faster but
we'll copy that over there was a second
command instruction and post that
command yep there's the command right
there and that will apply the
appropriate binary and once you've done
that you can actually go ahead and
validate that you have the correct
version of docker compose installed and
for that you want to write the command
docker dash compose space dash dash
version and that will then give you a
version build once you know that you
have a version built that means that you
have everything installed correctly on
your machine so you can see here that we
have a version number which means we
have everything installed you might see
a different version number depending on
how old the video is when you're
watching it but we're using real uh
content at the moment let's just go
ahead and clear the screen and now what
we're going to do is create a folder
where we're actually going to install
the ammo file that will have the
instructions for our docker components
environment so we're moving the cursor
to the desktop and on the desktop we're
going to create a new folder and uh
using the mkdirf command and we'll call
this one docker compose f for file and
then we'll move the cursor into that new
folder by using cd command and now we
are in the folder called docker compose
f and you can go look at your desktop
and you'll see it's there and now you
want to select
pound touch docker dash compose.yml and
they'll actually create the new yaml
file for you and you can use the ls list
command ls docker compose.yaml and
they'll allow you actually now to step
in and edit that file so let's go ahead
and hit return and that allows to go in
and edit the file so now i'm in the
editor and i'm going to write some
instructions um so i'm i'm going to put
a couple mistakes in these instructions
so we can see how dr pose catches those
mistakes um so but most this is going to
be fairly correct so you can just type
this out so we're going to start with
surfaces colon and we do web colon and
then we create image colon and we'll do
nitrix and then we'll do a database
colon and we call the image redis and so
what you can see because we have two
reference images we're actually calling
two different images two different
containers that will be created by
docker hub so what we're going to do is
uh where we can actually show you um how
that's pulling in you can go to docker
hub and you can actually see the
references to the images that we've just
created so go to docker hub which is
hull
hub.docker.com and you'll see that uh
ninjx
redis those are the default names for
the images so you could do
other images like http for apache web
server if you wanted to there are a lot
of images in docker hub so suddenly have
a lot of fun building uh tools from that
environment so we're going to save those
files um in the dock image we're just
going to do colon wq to exit this screen
save the text and this is going to run
our yaml file and you'll see the two
different error messages that will come
up so we can do cat docker dash compose
yml and here we have a display of the
text that we just wrote and now let's go
check the validity of the file that we
just created so we'll do docker dash
compose config and we should get an
error message and there we are error
message and the reason why we have an
error message is because the spacing is
not correct in the yaml file itself so
let's go to the actual yaml file that we
created let's go through and we're going
to use uh just the file finder and
you'll actually open up the yaml file in
your text editor your favorite text
editor and here we have um the code that
created it and let's use the correct
spacing so that everything is spaced out
appropriately in the image and so this
is the spacing that you'd expect to see
a space a line between surfaces and the
first image and the first image is a tab
in and then it referenced what the image
is and let's go ahead and clear the
screen and we'll see whether or not
we've got that all correct it click um
this clear screen and we're going to
check that everything is running
correctly and we're seeing we're still
getting an error message and the reason
why we're getting another error is that
there's still a config error in this the
actual yaml file so one of the things
you have to do when you're creating a
yaml file for docker composers you
actually have to have the appropriate
version
number in there so what we have to do is
we have to go and find which is the
appropriate version and there are three
major versions one two and three
depending on the age of docker that you
have installed on your computer uh so if
you have the very latest version of
docker 18 and newer you would put 3.7 as
the version number and what we're going
to do is we're going to just check on
the version that we have installed and
so just clear the screen and then we'll
just do docker version and what we have
is our version of docker's 17.12
now this is the version of docker not
docker compose uh it's your main docker
environment and so if we go back to our
web browser we'll actually see that
version 17 should align with version
number 3.5 yep there we are version 3.5
so what we want to do is go back into
our yaml file the very first line that
we want to put in above the services is
the version number and that version
number we're going to put in is 3.5 so
we type in version version and we'll put
colon and then version number is in
brighton quotes and you save that and
now what we can actually do is we can
actually go ahead and use the
single line instruction to run both of
these uh
two images that we've created because
everything is configured correctly or
just one note you'll see that the
version number is actually at the bottom
of the list and that's just the way that
docker compose works it pulls out the
services and the images that you'd
create and then press the image the
version number at the bottom of the list
so in the presentation we talked about
how you can use one line to trigger two
or more images and so to do that we're
going to do sudo docker dash compose up
dash and it's going to create the two
environments we have the web environment
and the database environment and let's
use pseudo docker ps to actually list
out that all the processes that are
running right now and there we are we
actually see all of the images are
running we have the names the commands
the images and everything's up and
running and if we want to close both of
those images we can actually use a
single line of command as well and that
command will be sudo docker dash compose
down and that closes both of the images
and we can see that all the databases
and the web services images have been
closed and sudo ps where she lists that
there is nothing running and that's how
to use docker compose why exactly the
docker network is important
let's talk about some scenario over here
so my application is something which
totally works perfectly fine into my
system and there is no issues on there i
ran it perfectly fine and i got it as
far as i'm able to interact everything
i'm able to do but the same application
does not works on the other person's
system now what could be the issue
because it's working on one machine and
it's not working on another machine now
the application does not work on another
system because there is a difference in
the computer systems maybe one system is
having a different machine and another
system is having a different machine and
you may be having some of the
differences maybe in the uh term of
hardware maybe in the terms of software
so the differences are possible in two
different machines so how we can get a
solution that uh we don't get this kind
of problems and once the container is
prepared it should be able to run it
across different systems so docker
networking is the ideal solution for
this uh problem over here with docker
networking the application works totally
fine and
it's something which can work on any
system you don't have any dependency
that it will run only on a specific
machine or a particular system so what
exactly is in docker networking all
about so docker networking enables a
user to link a docker container to as
many as networks a you know he or she
requires so you can actually connect a
docker container to a specific network
the docker networks are used to provide
complete isolation to the docker
containers so you can have it like okay
i want to run some couple of containers
in a different network and another
containers i want to run it into a
different networks so you can do that
isolations and the whole purpose of
doing that isolation is so that we will
be able to have a proper networking and
proper executions and all that stuff so
docker networking is a very important
concept when we talk about or when we
come up with the interaction on having
the docker containers isolated so it
resolves most of the problems okay so um
you can have like uh multiple containers
in running in same network you can have
a different particular networks also
there so a specific network
have its own attributes and then you can
use those attributes to connect to that
containers and to access that containers
but the whole idea is that the
containers are something which is uh
specifically running in a set of
servers or in a set of uh platform so
whenever i'm trying to look forward to
that particular container
it has to be there into a swim network
if you don't run it into your custom
network then whatever the default
network present it will be hosted in
that network there so how does the
docker networking actually works so you
got a decker file so using the
dockerfile you got up a custom docker
image and from this docker image you
have to actually go there and uh you
know put up like the docker container so
um you can also store this docker image
to the docker hub so that the same
docker image can be shared across
different users and they can also pull
down their docker image and they can
have the container running in their
systems so for the collaborating the
docker image you require the docker hub
and the container is the ultimate thing
or object which we need to create out of
the docker image when we go with the uh
particular process when the whole
process goes on over there so what
happens that the instead of the docker
hub you can use your own private
repositories also that's something which
totally relies on to you that how
exactly those things works on so a
dockerfile creates a docker image using
the build command
a docker image contains all the project
source code all the dependencies uh
using this docker image you can actually
run the source code in order to get a
docker container the moment you
initialize or running stance of docker
image you will be able to get a docker
container you can actually use the
docker hub for collaborating or for
sharing the docker image so you can
store the docker image on docker hub and
then different people can actually go
ahead and download or pull this docker
image onto their system and they can
also run their specific containers so
what are the different advantages we get
with the docker networking very first
one is the rapid deployment portability
better efficiency of faster
configuration scalability and the
security over here so these are some of
the advantages which we get when we talk
about the docker networking here now
let's talk about the container network
model here so what is the network model
we are looking forward from the
containers perspective now this is a
kind of architecture here now in this
one let's see that how it actually works
on now you have a docker engine which is
a main component which takes up all the
things and all the important components
are actually integrated with each other
now the network sandbox is the one in
which you will be having your container
running up and running now every network
is having its own attributes the uh
particular different gateway ips the ip
addresses the range of ipads the cidr
blocks also everything can be different
to for two different networks so the
whole point is that you will be defining
okay if you don't define that i want to
run this uh particular container into a
specific network then definitely that's
going to run into a default network
which is which gets created the moment
you do the installation of dockers but
anyhow any network is required for
running a docker container so there are
different network drivers which is
available there so if you feel that you
want to create a network so you have to
choose a particular
networking or the connectivity over
there and uh it really helps us to
understand that how the configurations
and how the different modifications and
those changes can be really done here so
a lot of changes are actually going on
and uh you know performing there and
this really helps us to understand that
how the things are being done as such
over there so network is something which
is very important from the containers
perspective so the network sandbox isn't
kind of a isolated sandbox that holds
the all the network configurations of
the containers so you will be requiring
a at least one docker container network
if you want to run a container inside in
that particular sandbox so sandbox is
created when a user requests to generate
an endpoint on the network so that's
where the sandbox gets created uh it can
have severals and points in a network as
it represents a containers network
configurations like ip address mac
address dns name so every container will
be having its own unique ip address
right so that can be a particular
endpoint to connect to that container
and it can have it like different uh
endpoints and different different
networks so that's always the
possibilities which is available there
now the endpoints
establishes the connectivity for the
container services with other services
also so the moment you work on the uh
particulars uh endpoints so that can be
used for having okay there is a service
running in a container so how you can do
that so if you in order to connect that
you require these endpoints so that you
can establish the connectivity with the
container services whatever running
inside these docker containers
right now the network is something which
provides the specific underlining
network attributes like the networking
support to the docker containers because
these uh network sandbox uh boxes will
definitely have a requirement of the
network so how you're going to get that
that you will be only able to get when
you go okay i will be looking forward
for the connectivity and i can go for
the communications and i can give the
hardware because although it's a os
level virtualization but still you
require some interaction with the
hardware from the networking perspective
and then docker engine is a the base
engine which is installed on the host
machine and it's actually the main
component which make sure that the
docker containers and the corresponding
docker services are always up and
running and he uh using the network
drivers you can actually create multiple
networks onto your system and you can
have those uh configurations
now the network architecture is
something which helps us to provide the
connectivity among the endpoints points
that probably belongs to the same
network and uh it's something which is a
kind of isolated network so different
different networks can be isolated uh
networks and we can have the end points
to them so uh there are different ways
in which we can establish the
connectivity and this is a complete
network architecture which is there so
you have a network drivers you have the
networks you have the network sandboxes
in which internally the docker
containers are running and then these
network sandboxes are having their
respective endpoints there to access
them to establish the connectivity now
let's talk about the network drivers now
there are five type of network drivers
which is available first one is the
bridge
host none overlay and mac vlan so these
are the different uh particular network
drivers which is available over here uh
first one is a bridge it's a private
default network created on the host if
you go there if you go to the
installation of a docker this is the
default driver which gets installed onto
the system onto the host the containers
linked to this network will have an
internal ip address through which we
they can actually communicate with each
other on the same machine also you can
establish the connectivity you can
connect to the containers using that
private ip address but outside the
server you will not be able to have the
communication but internally you can
connect to the containers and containers
can also interact with each other they
can also communicate with each other
with this one uh the docker daemon
creates the uh docker zero so if you run
the ipconfig config or if config on the
system you will be able to see a docker
zero kind of ethernet bridge network
which is created using which you can see
that okay this is the network which is
created by default it's a default
installation or default configuration
which automatically happens the moment
you set up a docker instance so you
don't have to go into the configurations
or in the setup of there it will be
already available on that particular
installation board there and the next
one is the host one so it's a public
network so when we go with the public
network it's actually uses the host iprs
and a tcp port in order to
interact with the service running inside
the docker container so if you are
looking forward that i want to reach out
or i want to connect to the container
but i want to use an
ip address which can be accessible from
outside world probably some other server
should be able to resolve that in that
situation the host network driver comes
into the picture so it
effectively disables the network
isolation between the docker host and
the docker containers which means that
using this driver a user can actually
run multiple containers you know it's
it's not possible for the user to run
multiple containers on the same host
because of the fact that you are using
the host ip address now when we were
talking about the bridge connection at
that moment of time we were getting the
private ip addresses which was totally
isolated and totally unique so there
were actually if you create a using the
bridge connection multiple containers so
you will see that if there are five
three containers everyone will be having
a different private ip address but the
moment you go for the host one so in
that situation the ipads is not going to
change so you get some restrictions okay
because the combination is of iprs and
port so iprs and 8080 can happen only
once it cannot happen multiple times so
that's the limitation that you cannot
run multiple containers on the same host
due to this restriction and the next one
is the none so in this network driver
the docker containers will neither have
any access to the external network or it
will not be able to communicate with the
other containers also total isolation
and total private containers are being
done when we use this driver so if you
these options are usually used when you
want to
disable so this is not doing nothing but
disabling the total networking
functionality for a specific container
that's what it happening over here next
one is the overlay so this one is uh
utilized for creating an internal
private network to the docker nodes in
the docker swamp cluster so overlay does
not comes up in case of a standalone
docker installation the moment you go
with the particular docker swamp cluster
at that moment of time the overlay type
of network is created so docker uh swam
is an orchestration tool so
that requires a overlay kind of uh
driver which can uh you know help them
to achieve the networking in case of
cluster because in case of docker spam
you have a master node manager node
worker nodes different different
machines are there so in that situation
overlay is the
main component or is the main type of
driver which is used and then we have
the mac vlan so it simplifies the
communication processes between their
containers
this network assigns a mac address to
the docker containers with this mac
address the docker you know servers will
route the network traffic to a router so
it's not on the basis of ip address it's
actually on the basis of mac address so
on the specific mac address the network
this docker server will redirect the
network to a specific router
right it's usable when a user wants to
directly connect uh the containers to
the physical network rather than the
docker host so that's where this
communication works on so it's a direct
connectivity between the host network
and uh the docker container so there is
no virtualization which is happening
over here so uh it's something which is
you know giving a direct access to the
networks but it's definitely on the
basis of mac address which on which the
communication is happening now let's
talk about the networking implementation
and we'll see that how we can go for a
particular bridge network implementation
there so let's go back to the virtual
machine so i am connected to a
particular system here so i can check
that if the docker is available to me
and i can just run the docker version so
it says that okay the client and the
server component both is available there
now we are going to see that what are
the different uh containers which is
what are the different docker containers
network which is available there so i'm
going to run a command called docker
network ls now the moment you do it over
here you will see that none host and
bridge these are the different
containers uh network which is available
there and uh you can see their network
ids the names the drivers but drivers is
also very important because that's what
we are going to use here so it's a very
good one here so the default one you can
see that the bridge is available and uh
it's a default one whenever you create
any container by default whether you
give the container attribute or not it's
something which gets created into the uh
terms or in the uh basis of the
container only in the default network
only so how we can get that we can
always get that part by
you know having the understanding that
what network we are using so i'm going
to run a couple of containers or small
container and we can see that how
exactly uh the containers can be
executed and uh can be done over there
right so let's see so i'm going to run a
command
docker
run hyphen d id
iphone iphone name
alpine1
alpine
image is what i am going to use
and usage
so it uh pulls down the alpine image
that's what it happened and the same
thing i'm going to run but this time i'm
going to run
alpine 2 because uh i want to create two
containers
right so with this one what will happen
that i will be having a like two
containers available here so i can say
like darker ps so i can see that two
containers that are unique one is the
alpine and one is alpine two right so
now what happens that we will see that
how the connectivity happens and what
other network details so what i'm going
to do is that first of all i'm going to
do an uh inspect over there onto the
bridge connectivity so that i can get
the detailed information
so um this is the name of
the particular ones of the network so
this is the network which is available
and this is the default one so if i
scroll up you can see that this is the
name of the bridge connectivity and even
if you run the docker network list so uh
you will be able to see that the id also
so id also if you compare so uh e65
that's the one which is available now
this one is something which is using a
driver called bridge and here you can
see the subnet information now if you
scroll down you can see that two
containers are available here so i did
not provide any kind of network details
but uh definitely what happens that the
two containers which i deployed are
basically running inside this network
okay and you can see that uh the bridge
name docker zero is the internet or
network which gets created uh which
during the installation of docker gets
uh configured now
you can see that uh this is the ip
address this is the ip address here this
is the mac address and this is also a
mac address here so uh the ip address
you can see this is a
3.0.3 in the last and this is dot 2 over
here so you can see that the increase
the sequence is there so alpine 1 was
having an ip dot 172
and
alpine2 is having an incremented ipad as
like a different one as in three so you
can see that these different ip
addresses are there and uh represents if
you want to access them if you want to
connect on them you will be able to have
the connectivity accordingly so even if
you go inside these containers you can
actually see that what exactly uh the
connectivity you want to establish or
the connectivity you want to perform
here right so this is the way that how
the network usually works and uh the
networks which you are using over here
is the bridge once which definitely
helps us to understand that how the
configurations can be done now so uh
what we are going to do over here is
that we will try to see that how exactly
uh we can uh go ahead and uh we can
connect on there and uh we can also see
that if we are able to communicate with
each other because probably uh if i run
like ping command over here
and i'll put the containers like two
and i'm able to reach out there's no
problem in reaching out to these ips
because these are the private ip
addresses and i will be able to reach
out to them without any problem and
without any concerns so from the current
uh connectivity perspective there is no
problem as such and i have a connection
uh available over here but let's see uh
we'll go uh back to the containers we'll
see that how exactly we can talk about
we can reach out to the one container
with each other so i want to connect
alpine one within pine two so how we can
do that
so i'm going to use like docker
fine one
okay now i got a terminal so what i can
do is that i can go for the ipa in this
show
so with this one what will happen that i
will be able to know the ipad is so dot
2 is the one which is available over
here okay so this is the ip address now
i can uh simply do the uh small ping
command so i can say like ping
google.com so that will show me that if
i have an internet connectivity so that
is great so i got a connectivity with
the internet uh over there so i will be
able to reach out any websites or any
kind of that order now uh i have another
ip so dot three is remember we were
using three different ip so i can
actually do a ping also here so ping
hyphen c five
five request will put and uh three will
do here now we are trying to reach out
to the alpine two over there so although
we are connecting to the alpine one but
we have the connectivity with alpine two
also so from alpine one you can connect
to the alpine two containers so that
shows that since both of them are
running in the same container so they
are having the automatic
uh connectivity and you can easily reach
out to them and without any issues you
can do that and similarly the same thing
you can do it uh in case of uh
alpine two also so you get it connected
to the alpine two and uh you can uh just
follow the same thing so you can connect
it uh with the if you go to the alpine
two you can connect to the alpine one
also so if you come out the containers i
will be always up and running and you
will be able to have the mechanisms
there so the whole idea about these
things is that it will be basically
helping you to understand that how the
executions can be done and how we can
perform the activities as such over here
so this is the way that how we deal with
the networking and how the containers
gets created into a network and then
they can interact with each other right
so this was the demo on which we talk
about that how we can talk about a
bridge network implementation with the
docker containers did you know the
famous global researcher gartner
predicts by 2023 more than 50 percent of
the companies will be adopting docker
containers
however a serverless container like
docker will have a rise in the revenue
from a small base of
465.8 million in the year 2020 to
944 million in the year 2024 in this
video we will be doing a side-by-side
comparison of the docker containers and
the virtual machines what exactly is a
virtual machine it is an isolated
computing environment that enables a
person to use an operating system via a
physical machine virtual machines
provide the functionality of a physical
computer as you can see on my screen
there is a virtual machine and this is
how a typical virtual machine looks like
now let's look at what a docker is
docker is an operating system level
virtualization software platform that
enables software developers and it
administrators to create deploy and run
applications in a docker container with
all their dependencies
and a docker container is a lightweight
software package that includes all the
dependencies like frameworks libraries
and many more which are essentially
required to execute an application
this is the architecture of docker tool
now let's move on to our next main topic
for the discussion that is
docker versus virtual machine
when it comes to comparing the two we
could say the docker containers have
much more potential than virtual
machines
as you can see on the left and right
hand side
both the images look similar now let's
define the layers of virtual machine
from the bottom up let's begin with the
infrastructure
infrastructure could be a computer
system a laptop or a virtual private
server such as an amazon ec2 instance or
as your virtual machine or gcp virtual
machine instance
on the top of the infrastructure runs
the operating system an operating system
is a software that manages hardware and
software resources for the computer
programs
on your laptop this will be likely
windows mac os or linux flavored
operating system such as ubuntu next
comes the hypervisor a hypervisor is a
firmware that builds and runs virtual
machines there are two types of
hypervisors
type 1 hypervisors are hyperkit for mac
os hyper-v for windows and kvm for linux
operating systems and type 2 hypervisors
are virtualbox and vmware then we have
the guest operating systems consider an
example where you want to run two apps
on your server in total isolation
this process would require two guest
operating systems which will be
controlled by a hypervisor
virtual machines come with many
dependencies where each guest operating
system will at least occupy 512 mb of
your ram
this is worse because each guest
operating system needs its own cpu and
memory resources eventually this will be
expensive
then on top of that each guest operating
system requires its own dependencies
such as binaries and libraries since
every application has different
dependencies it requires its own set of
libraries
finally it's the application this layer
consists of the source code for the
application you've built
this was all about the virtual machine
on a server here's what the same setup
looks like when you're using docker
containers
here you'll notice that there are a lot
fewer layers docker doesn't require a
bunch of massive guest operating systems
let me break it down from the bottom up
again
infrastructure and host operating
systems are the same as we discussed for
the virtual machine coming into the
third layer instead of a hypervisor
docker uses docker engine
docker engine or docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using docker
components
next we have our dependencies
just like on the virtual machines here
dependencies are built into a template
called docker images as you can see on
the screen each application is still
isolated and occupies less space
now let's have a look at the significant
differences between docker and virtual
machine
let's start with the operating system
first
docker is a container based model where
containers are software packages used
for executing an application on any
operating system
on the other side virtual machine is a
container based model it utilizes user
space along with the kernel space of the
operating system a kernel space is where
the core of the operating system runs
and provides its services to the user a
user cannot modify the space and user
space is the portion of the system
memory in which the user's processes run
docker containers share operating system
kernels with other applications and
result in a higher server efficiency
hence docker provides the most
substantial
default isolation capabilities among the
other configuration tools
on the other hand virtual machines do
not share the operating system also it
does not provide isolation in the host
kernel
in docker multiple workloads can run on
a single operating system but in virtual
machine each workload needs a complete
operating system or a hypervisor
the next significant difference between
the two is the performance in the case
of docker they use the same operating
system without any additional software
like hypervisor
in case of virtual machines performance
issues are a major problem it can be due
to the several reasons like cpe
constraints memory allocation network
latency and many more
running multiple virtual machines lead
to an unstable performance
docker containers can start up quickly
and result in less boot up time whereas
virtual machines do not start quickly
and lead to a poor performance now let's
talk about the next difference which is
portability with docker containers a
developer can build an application and
store it into a docker image later he or
she can run it across any host
environment
but when it comes to virtual machines it
has portability issues virtual machines
do not have a central hub like docker
does and it requires more memory space
to store data
docker containers are smaller than
virtual machines due to which the
process of transferring files on the
host file system is easier on the other
hand dependency on the host operating
system and hardware makes virtual
machines less portable while
transferring files virtual machines
should have a copy of the operating
system
and its dependencies due to which image
size is increased and becomes a tedious
process to share data
the boot of time between the both is
very different the application and
docker containers start without any
delay since the operating system is
already up and running on the other hand
virtual machines take much longer time
than it takes for a container to run
applications
these containers were basically designed
to save time in the deployment process
of an application whereas in virtual
machines to deploy a single application
virtual machine needs to start an entire
operating system which would result in a
full board process
so those were the major differences
between docker and a virtual machine now
let's discuss the minor differences
between them
docker is not always in a running state
it stops when the stop command is
executed whereas the virtual machines
are always running in the background
which will result in huge ram
consumption talking about snapshots
docker has a lot of snapshots a snapshot
is an image that you can upload on a
private repository to access it on
another host but virtual machines do not
consist of any snapshots in docker
images can be version controlled just
like git they have local registry called
docker hub where users store and
distribute container images on the other
hand virtual machine does not have a
central hub they are not version
controlled
docker can run multiple containers on a
system
users can connect multiple containers
using user-defined networks and shared
volumes multiple containers can be
accessed on the same machine and share
the operating system kernel with other
containers each container is isolated in
user space also docker containers occupy
less space than virtual machines and
start instantly
virtual machine can run only a limited
number of virtual machines on a system
since each virtual machine requires a
certain amount of cpu ram memory and
other resources your physical systems
will have less space
multiple containers can be started at a
time on the docker engine the isolation
environment allows a user to run and
deploy several containers simultaneously
on a given host
virtual machines can run only a limited
number of virtual machines on a system
since each virtual machine requires
certain amount of cpu ram memory and
other resources your physical systems
will have less space now that i have
told you the differences between docker
containers and virtual machines let me
show you a real life case study of how
pcc uses docker
bcc news is a british news channel over
500 developers working across the globe
bcc news delivers broadcast in almost 30
different languages and with over 80 000
daily news in english alone the news
channel ran more than 26 000 jobs with
more than 10 continuous integrations
with sequential scheduling the company
had issues with identifying a way to
unify the coding process and monitor the
continuous integration consistently also
the existing jobs took up to more time
that is up to 60 minutes to schedule and
perform its task
docker allowed bcc news to eliminate job
wait times and run jobs in parallel it
also gave the users the ability to work
in a more flexible ci environment where
entire core processes were unified and
stored in a single place however docker
succeeded in spreading up the whole
continuous integration process in this
topic we are going to talk about what
exactly is the various docker commands
which we can use to interact with the
docker docker images docker containers
and some core components of docker is
what we are going to talk about in this
particular topic here now let's begin
with what exactly is in docker because
we are trying to explore that one of the
different docker commands we can
eventually run to interact with the
docker because uh you have the command
line interface which is available there
using which you can run some couple of
docker commands and internally you know
you will be able to have some particular
processing which is done at the docker
end now docker is in configuration
management tool it's being used as a
configuration management tool just like
the other configuration management tools
in the industry in the market now it's
pretty much used by the developers to
make sure that they
wrap or they package an application with
all its dependency
now normally in a virtual machine what
we do is that we host or we install the
dependencies separately
and then on top of that we host our web
applications or whatever the application
we have we host it on that particular
framework or platform
but here in this scenario we are talking
about like how we can wrap an
application all together with its
dependencies all the dependencies are
getting wrapped are getting uh packaged
up into a single entity
and you know that's what we call it as a
docker container so docker is in
configuration management tool and the
containerization tool which is there
which helps us to wrap or package both
the dependencies and the source code
within a single unit called docker
container and this is the docker
container which the developers use to do
the deployment across multiple
environments
so um as part of the process um when you
are working on the
hosting of your application onto your
docker so ultimately you are looking
forward for an entity called docker
container
so if you see if you go through the
diagram over here so in this one
this is in kind of a basic way uh
architecture that how the docker is
being architect and is getting uh
deployed
so initially you have an infrastructure
like a physical infrastructure is there
you have the particular cores memory
infrastructure all those things are
available there now on top of this
infrastructure you are hosting up a host
operating system
this host operating system is
responsible for taking up all the
requests and interacting uh providing a
particular interface between the uh
particular docker and the infrastructure
the core hardware so it acts like a
medium over here
so after the host on operating system on
top of that you are going to install the
docker engine docker software it just
like you got a virtual machine on linux
and on top of that you are installing
the docker software
once the docker engine is installed then
docker engine will take care of
management of the docker containers you
don't really have to uh do a lot of work
docker engine is going to take all the
internal work uh the communication
between the operating system and the
infrastructure so that needs to be done
by the docker engine so docker engine
make sure that the different container
gets uh up and running and you can see
that in this scenario in this diagram we
have container one container two and
container three and all these containers
are actually having its own applications
and the dependencies bind it up together
so that's the reason why we are saying
that with the docker we are getting a
complete package end-to-end package is
being given to us in which we have both
the uh particular source code and the
binaries and the executables embedded
inside that so it's a complete package
which uh is getting created in the form
of docker container and the developer is
responsible for preparing this docker
container so that these containers can
be deployed on the docker host and you
can get your application up and running
so this is what we have docker into our
particular and the architecture of the
docker here now let's see that what are
the different commands we have for the
docker here now the very first one is
that what are the different images
related to commands which is available
there the very first one is the
command which we typically use to
prepare a custom docker image now i can
uh easily go to the docker hub and i can
pull down a docker image which is
available there but let's assume that
you are working on application source
code so you want to prepare a docker
container for that now that docker
container you will not be able to have
it on the docker hub you have to prepare
on your own
right so in order to prepare your own
docker image all you have to do is that
you have to run docker build command now
in this case we have to prepare a docker
file which will act like a docker a kind
of a docker build script just like in
case of maven we have found xml file and
in case of and we have built.xml file so
here we have the dockerfile which is
available there and this dockerfile make
sure that whatever the steps are
mentioned in this dockerfile in the
build script it's going to perform a
series of steps and the build will be
done so docker build is the command
hyphen t is the tag that what exactly
name uh you know whatever the image you
are building so what exactly tag name
you're trying to provide over here so
here we are using a tag name called my
image and then after the column we are
providing that what version we want to
go here 1.0 2.0 5.0 so whatever the
version you feel that you want to
you know refer you can do that
now this is the exact way that how in
the actual world the darker images are
getting built up by the uh respective
vendors let's say that jenkins is born
and jenkins wants to prepare a docker
image so they will be preparing the
docker file in the same manner and
prepare these docker images and publish
it to the docker hub so all the docker
images are built up the custom docker
images are built up with the help of
docker files so docker build is the
command which will process the docker
file and give you a particular docker
image in the end
now how to list down all the docker
images so docker list
ls is something which is there so this
will eventually help you to list down
all the docker images which is listed on
or which is available into your system
so that will be listed out over there
for you
if you feel that you want to remove a
particular image in that case you can go
for docker image rm command and uh
whatever the image you want to remove
you can give the respective image name
and the tag name there so docker image
rm command is there using which you can
actually see that how the image can be
deleted from the host over here in this
one right so whatever the ways whatever
the you know mechanism is there so we
are making sure that how the image can
be built up and how we can go for the
uh built up and a particular image can
be deployed over here in this case so in
order to delete it in docker image so
you can go for docker image rm command
to remove a docker image completely from
the docker host
so these are some couple of commands
which is available there using which you
can actually interact or manage the
docker image because in order to prepare
or in order to run a docker container we
require a source and that source we are
going to get it from the docker image so
now we are going to see that how we can
execute these commands so first of all
what we need to do is that we need to
see that how docker build works for that
we require a docker file so i am going
to have a simple docker file over here
in which we are going to have a basic uh
docker image selected as an ubuntu after
that we are going to go for the one
attribute where we are going to do the
installation of a specific package like
let's say git and accordingly you can
whatever software you want to prepare
you want to set up you can do that and
put up the commands over here in this
docker file so i'm going to save this
file and after that what i need to do is
that i need to run like doctor images to
find out that how many images are there
there is no images present so i'm going
to build a docker image over here with
the name of
simply none or whatever the name you
want to give you can
give it over here in this case it's not
any kind of restricted word so you can
give the actual locker image name also
that what for what purpose you're
preparing this image and with that what
will happen that it will take up the uh
values whatever attributes you have put
up into the docker file so that will be
processed and that will be picked up and
once that uh docker file has been
processed has been uh you know prepared
you will be able to see that yes a final
product or a final docker image is
finalized and prepared over here in this
one so we just have to wait for the
whole process to complete and once my
docker image is prepared i will be able
to have a particular setup done or
achieved over here so that's what we
require over here in this one to be
performed
now once the installation is done so you
will be able to see like the final
docker image is being prepared over here
so it says successfully built which
means that uh the docker image is
prepared now if you run like docker
images you will be able to find out that
this image is available over here in
this one now you are seeing like two
images because one is like the basic
image which is being pulled down because
we are using a docker file to do that to
process that one there
now in case you want to remove it so all
you need to do is that you need to run
like docker
image
rm and simply learn
so if you do that what will happen that
your docker image which is related to
simply learn will be wiped off from your
system and in case you want to do like
removal of the ubuntu also so that also
you can do over here with the help of
docker images
rm
ubuntu and that will be removed from
your system so your docker images will
be removed from your system using the uh
particular command called docker
um image and then rm command to remove
the docker image from your system from
your host here so that's how you deal
with the different docker images
commands over here in this one now let's
go back to the document now the next
section over here is the docker
container commands over here so all the
commands related to docker containers is
what we are going to talk about over
here now the very first one is the uh
particular container so in order to
create a container so you can run the
command called docker create and the
image because for a container you
require a docker image that's a pre
request so once the docker image is
prepared you can just simply run docker
create command and that will help you to
create a container onto your system now
if you want to run a particular um you
want to create a container and you want
to run it also at the same time so in
that situation you can go for a docker
run command the main difference between
the docker create and docker run command
is that the docker run command is going
to uh run a container and uh it's going
to give you a response from the command
but
the docker create command is going to
create only the container so once the
container is up and running so that's
only being done by the docker create
command but the docker run command is
going to actually do the
uh preparation of the container also and
at the same time you are being given as
in particular
response also like you know what a
command you want to run so that response
also you will be able to get here and if
you feel that you want to rename an
existing container so for that you can
go for the docker rename command so
existing container you can rename it
with the new container and that's how
the uh particular rename of an existing
container will be done with on to the
docker host here so docker rename is the
command using which you can rename an
existing container and you can get a new
container over here in this case so
these are some of the options some of
the ways that how you can interact with
the containers how you can manage them
onto your docker host over here so you
can run it you can create it and you can
rename the containers also so now what
we're going to do is that we're going to
see that how we can work on this
particular container commands here so
first of all i'm going to quickly pull
down jenkins image so that i can create
a container out of that so it's in kind
of a 600 round uh mv docker image which
is available there now you can also have
a custom docker image prepared using the
dockerfile or you can have a ready-made
docker image pull down from the docker
hub also so this is going to pull the
latest version of the jenkins from the
docker hub so that we will be able to
proceed further on that and we will be
able to continue with the hosting so we
will be converting or running this uh
specific docker images in the form of
docker containers so that we will be
able to have uh instance of docker
container over here running in this one
so that's what we are trying to do here
so we will just wait for this pool
activity to complete because it's in a
heavy docker image so it may take some
time to download and once it's download
you will be able to see that docker
images is showing a specific docker
image of jenkins here now you're going
to create a container out of that so
you're going to run a command called
docker create and jenkins over here
so that will help us to do uh the
creation of a docker container and once
that is done so you will be able to see
like using docker ps command that if any
container is up and running and if you
go for docker psyphony you will be able
to see that yes a particular docker
container is in
created mode now this is not in running
mode because you see that when i ran the
docker ps command it was not showing it
in the running mode because i just
created a docker container here and the
created status also shows that yes the
docker container is created but it did
not run over here
so if
you want to run it so definitely you can
say like docker
start
and
you can give the container name and that
will help me to
start my container over here but of
course you if you feel that you want to
directly create a container and you know
you don't want to create the container
only you want to start it also so in
that case you can go for the docker run
command so docker run command is
something which can be used instead of
doing the execution so you can say like
docker
run
jenkins
and what it will do it will definitely
help you to get the
container created onto of the jenkins
over here
in this case it's not like only creating
a container but in fact it's actually
starting the container also so you can
see that it started over here into your
screen itself that whole jenkins gets
initialized over here in this one so
this is the way that how
you can initialize or you can create a
container now i can just do a control c
over here because it says that and
jenkins is up and running so you can
start using this one according to your
requirement over here right so i'm just
doing ctrl c so that it can be stopped
over there
right now
so this is the way that how uh typically
we can create the containers now we've
got like two containers over here and
one is up and running and one is
something which i just closed just now
over here
now if you feel that you want to rename
a container let's say like this is a
container which is available but it's
not having a meaningful name now i want
to convert into a meaningful name like
dev underscore jenkins so that you can
easily do with the help of docker rename
command because that will rename the
docker container name so that you will
be able to connect on to that and you
can go for the processing so that's what
we can get over here in this one so this
is how you can do the
various management of the resources over
here so let's go back to the main
content
now if you feel that you want to remove
all these top containers because what
happens that sometimes we simply stop
the container but we do not remove it
from the
docker hose because um we are not going
for the cleanup now clean cleanup is
very required because these containers
are actually taking up the disk space
also
so we need to make sure that we should
be using we should be having like
minimum amount of disk space utilization
so for that what we need really need to
do is that we need to run docker
container prune command so this will
basically help you to uh prune or do the
cleanup uh purge of all the containers
which is running on the host machine
here
and that will definitely help us to
remove all the
containers which is in stop status so
that will be simply removed over here in
this one so
this really completely removes all the
stopped containers onto the docker host
over here in this scenario
now second one is that it creates a new
image from a containers file changes now
the
way what happens that normally what we
follow is that we use the docker build
command to do the build process right so
docker build command is being used in
that particular way now if you really
want to go for a preparation of a new
you know image so all you need to do is
that you need to create a new image from
a container file
so you can run the command called docker
container commit command and you know
whatever container is there so that will
be saved or preserved as a docker image
because sometimes we also do some ad hoc
changes or modifications on the fly
inside the docker container by going
inside the docker container and doing
the steps so we really need to preserve
those steps and that is the reason why
we are converting a docker container in
the form of a docker image here so
that's what we are trying to perform
here so docker container is something
which is uh being uh done over here in
such a way that whatever the steps
whatever the changes we are trying to do
so that needs to be performed over here
in this case so docker container uh
commit command is being used so that we
can get a particular you know final
image as part of the container so the
container will be converted in the form
of a docker image over here and the last
one is that how we can remove an
existing container so we can go for the
docker rm command which is available
there using which you will be able to go
ahead and you can get a particular
container removed from your existing
system so docker arm command is pretty
much there using which we can see that
how we can remove an existing container
from your system as such
what exactly now we are going to see
that how we can perform the various
commands on the containers here
so the very first command which we want
to do here is that uh you know in order
to see that how we can actually remove
all these top containers but for this
one what we really need to do is that we
need to first of all run some couple of
containers so i'm going to quickly run a
container called docker
run hyphen d httpd
so i'm going to run a particular web
server over here and
it should be able to give me a proper
container up and running so i can just
double check or value that it has with
the help of the
docker ps command
so docker ps command should give me the
proper confirmation that whether the
container is in up and running over here
or not so you can see that it's up and
running from last 11 seconds here now we
got a command where you know for example
we have got some stopped containers but
again you have to manually remove them
one by one now if you don't want to do
that stuff if you feel that whatever the
stock containers which is available that
should be automatically removed from
your system then we have a command
called docker container prong now for
this what we really need to do is that
we need to actually stop this container
because again it will be only picked up
like whatever the containers which is
available in these tops it is only those
will be picked up
so i have copied the uh container name
here in this case and i need to stop it
so that i will be able to
remove it with the prone command over
here in this one and then i can run like
docker
container
print command which will basically
remove all the containers which is in
these top status and once that is done
you will be able to see like that is
something which is completely gone from
your system so this is a way that how it
can not only take care of these top
containers but it's actually being done
so that you can remove the multiple
containers with a single command itself
over here so this is not something which
will be
executed one by one on a different
container but yes it will definitely
take care of doing the uh changes and
performing the activities
now another thing is that how we can
actually do the uh commit of a
particular docker image let's say that
we got a docker container which is uh
running and there are some changes like
some dynamic changes which is available
there so you want to save this uh
particular container as a docker image
so that whatever the changes temporary
changes are there so that will be also
saved as a docker image so all you can
do is that let's say let again
run a particular container
of httpd here
so this will help me to get a particular
container from the http perspective
available of to us so docker ps command
will give me the option
now here i have got a container in which
it's running now if i want to save this
container let's say that i went inside
they did some modification did some
temporary changes now i want to refer it
i want to use it so how you can do that
so for that what you really need to do
is
you need to run like docker commit
that's a command or you can say docker
because you're going to do a docker
container commit over here so the commit
of the container is what we are going to
do so docker container commit and then
we are going to see like what is the
container so for container we will be
yes again copying
that particular container id and we'll
say like custom
image colon version one so we will be
giving a custom name or a name of a
docker image and a tag over here in this
one so this will basically save my
docker container which is available in
this one in the format of a particular
docker image in a format of a docker
image over here in this case
so as you can see that almost both of
them are having the same change but
the container which we got over here in
this one so this whatever the changes
are you want to wish you want to do you
can do that and you can then put up into
the uh form of a docker image a final
docker image and it allows if you want
to remove it so docker rm and container
id now this again docker arm will come
remove only those containers which is in
stop status so if you want to forcefully
remove it so you will be able to use it
with the help of hyphen f which is the
force will remove which will remove the
container completely from your system
and once it's removed from your system
you will be able to see like there is no
container running up and running over
here in this one so docker ps hyphen a
is not something which is up and running
over here in this one so they completely
completely got uh wiped out from your
system so that's how you basically work
on these commands on this uh particular
uh container related commands here so
let's go back to the main content
right so these are the commands where we
can actually do the management like how
to stop the containers how to remove the
containers and how to get a new you know
docker image out of the container here
now let's see that how we can list down
all the running containers if you feel
that you want to list down all the
running containers then you can go for
the docker containers ls command and
that will eventually help you to list
down all the containers which is
available there which is uh being there
into your system
then docker stop command is there to
stop a container
so whatever container which is there in
the running status so that will be
stored with the help of the docker stop
command and then the restart command is
there using which you can do a restart
of a container into your system
right so once the container is restart
so whatever the application running
inside the container so that will also
be restarted over here in this one so
these are the different options which is
available using which we can explore
over here in this one somewhat more
commands about the container so again i
am going to run a container over here of
http here so that i can show you some
couple of more commands over here now we
can run like docker ps or you can say
like docker container less will which
list down on all the containers which is
available to you which is being you know
present in this case now if you want to
do any kind of operations like let's say
if i want to stop it
now the moment you do the stop over here
so you will be able to
stop the container which is up and
running for you and
you can come uh you know whatever the
application is being deployed that will
also not be available to you because
that's simply uh completely gone for you
now you can see that the docker
container list is not able to show you
that particular option that whether it's
being shown or not because it's in stop
status so in fact you can do a you know
start or you can do a restart so both
the operations you can pretty much do
over here so that you will be able to
have a complete activity implemented so
restart is also something which is
available which can definitely help you
to see that how the things could really
work and how you can go for the
container uh you know the management
over here in this case so you can do
container container ls command to list
down what are the containers which is
available
then you can do a restart you can do a
stop also infect start is also there
which can help you to see that how the
containers is are really available so
this is the way that how you can manage
like you know even the restarts and all
because this really helps you to even do
the restart bounces to the application
which is present inside this container
so that also you will be able to see
with this particular component here
so that let's go back to the meat
content
and then um you know killing a running
container so if you really want to kill
a container so for that we can go for
the docker kill because rocket stop is
also going to stop the container but if
you want to forcefully kill it so in
that case you can go for the docker kill
command to do that particular
kill on the containers and then if you
really want to go inside the container
and you want to attach your terminal so
for that you can go for the docker
attach command and with this what will
happen that you can go inside the
container you can do whatever the
changes you want to perform you can do
that and you can again come back outside
that also so normally typically we use
it so that we can see some errors of
uh in the logs which is coming up in the
containers and if any kind of issues are
coming up for the applications we should
be able to know that part
now the last one is the uh particular
weight docker weight is there so that
will block a container and uh it will go
in the wait status so docker weight and
the container id or the container name
you can give so with that the particular
container will go into the block status
let's see somewhat more commands over
here so we can run like docker container
ls again to find out like what container
is available so you can see that this
particular container is available over
here in this one now if you see like if
i want to get uh attached to this
container if i want to attach my input
and output uh stream with this container
so you can run like docker
attach and the container id so your
terminal will be stuck over here because
it's taking up whatever the progress
which is going to be done in the
container that will be in you know a
kind of attached to your terminal over
here and you will be getting the output
but the moment you come out of this like
you say control c so you will see that
you know it's basically sending the
request to the container that is getting
stopped so you will be able to see like
the docker container list it's not going
to show you because the container is in
stop status so again you have to do the
restart of the container to make sure
that the container is up and running
right so the attach one will help you to
go uh and attach your standard input and
output with your container with a
running container but when the moment
you comes out you will be able to
disconnect or shut down the container
and again i had to restart that
container over here in this one then
again of course we have like docker
weight
then container is there so this will
basically put the
container into a block status because
all the requests and all will be not
sent to the container and it will be
blocked and
if you really want to like uh consume or
if you want to make use of the container
you will not be able to do that so
docker weight command will us kind of
block the container and you know if you
again uh try to come out of that so
again the request to the container will
be uh
resumed and they will be able to use on
that part so docker read command is
being used to block the container and
then we have docker attached to attach
to the container the standard input and
output and lastly is the docker kill
which is going to kill the container and
you will be able to
see that the container is in simply
killed stator so it's uh you know it's
not like a stopped over here if it's
gracefully stopped then the exit code
definitely will be zero but in this case
since it's being killed the particular
status is 137 over here in this one so
that's a non-zero status code so that's
how where you will be able to manage the
containers on different aspects let's go
back to the main container so these were
some of the commands which was there
from the docker containers perspective
let's talk about some of the commands
from the share command perspective so
how we can share the docker images
so we have a typical pull push mechanism
which is there using which we can
actually interact with the docker hub or
a docker registry so uh if you really
want to pull the docker image so in that
case you can go for the docker pull
command
if you want to push an image to the
registry so you can use for the docker
push command if you want to execute a
command inside a particular running
container or you want to
execute a command or a script or
something like that so you can go for
the docker is a command and with that
the execution will be done and you will
be able to get a response so that will
make sure that yes whatever the
execution you are trying to do so that
will be done over here in this mechanism
now let's see that how we can do a pull
and push activity to a docker image so
first of all the pull command is pretty
simple all you need to do is that you
need to say that okay i want to pull a
docker image uh if let's say that our
docker image is already present then
it's just going to say that it's already
up to date it's already available there
but if in some cases you feel that the
docker image is not available and you
want to pull it so all you can do is
that you can give that a docker image
name and that you can give the tag also
but in this case we are using the tag as
in latest
so that's the reason why even if you
provide or you don't provide it doesn't
really matter so i'm going to give like
a docker pull a mysql over here and the
moment i hit on this one what will
happen that it says this a particular
docker image is not available into my
system it's going to download it and
once it's going to be downloaded you
will be able to see that into your local
system so docker images is something
which is going to help you with the
commands and it will give you the uh
particular ways that how the docker
image is available so i can run like
docker images over here to see that what
are the different docker images which is
available in this manner
now if you really want to move any of
the docker image then of course you have
to do a docker login
and you will be doing the
uh you know the connectivity to the
docker hub and then establish the
connectivity and all so what you need to
do is that you can run the docker login
command we will also see this command in
the next particular slide but right now
we are just doing it because we want to
showcase that how the push really works
so uh you can actually give your
username that uh what username you are
holding up
so the password does not shows any
activity but yes still it will let you
know that whether the login is
successful or not so in this case it
says login is successful so all you need
to do is let's say like i got this
custom image and i want to push it to
the docker hub so
you need to rename or you need to do a
tag over here because the same if you
run
docker push
custom
image
colon version one so if you do that it
will not be pushed into these uh
particular docker hub so it's going to
throw e error over here that the access
is denied so all you need to do is that
you need to do a tag here
so you have to rename it in such a way
that you should be able to uh use uh add
your username over there because
dockerhub will identify that if it's
there with your username then only it
will be pushed otherwise it will be
simply rejected over there so that's
what you need to do you need to rename
your docker image uh the same docker
image which you have you have to append
your username of the docker hub and once
that is done so all you need to do is
that you need to just run like docker
then push is there
then this image name and then version
one
so the moment you do this what will
happen that it will start transferring
those darker image to the docker hub you
see this specifies that yes this is
going to the docker hub docker dot io
where my username is there and this is
the custom image which is available
there so if i refresh my page on the
docker hub i will be able to see like
this public repo which is available
there but again this one just requires a
credentials and the login which we did
in just a last command where we ran the
docker login command to do the login to
the portal and after that only we are
able to do the setup and the
modifications over here so that's how
you do the login and you are able to
connect on that now these are some of
the pull and push operations but let's
say that if you got a container which is
up and running like this is uh
right now we are not getting any
container which is available over here
so you can say like docker run
hyphen d httpd like i'm just running a
dummy container over here so that i will
be able to
show you this command now if you for
some reason want to go inside the
container and want to see some
processing and want to see some content
so you can run the command called docker
azik
hyphen id and there you can give the
container id this is nothing but the
full format of the container id which is
given to you so you can use this one
also or you can use the shortened also
shortened value also you can use and
then the last we can say like bash
the moment you do this you will be going
you will be going inside the container
you see that this is the host name which
is being shown as the container id you
can do a like psiphon ef command and it
will
throw an error that the ps command is
not available because you are running
this command into the docker into the
docker container so using these kind of
commands which is not available in
container will help you to identify that
yes you are not on the host machine you
are in fact into the docker container so
that's the reason why you can do it
because for you the parts and all
everything is same the terminal is also
same so you may not be able to
differentiate in that part so that's the
reason why it's preferred that we use
that uh commands which is going to fail
but that's okay it will give you that
okay this command is failing because i'm
into the docker container right now so
that's what we are performing over here
right and you can come out of that but
still the docker container is going to
be still up and running over here in
this case so the container is not going
to
be down over here in this one so that's
how we manage the container we can go
inside and we can check some
informations and get some files there
so these are some of the commands where
we can interact now in order to log into
the docker hub because before doing the
docker push you have to log in you have
to get a credentials and the
connectivity with docker hub so you can
run the docker login command where you
can see that how the execution can be
done now using the docker login command
you can interact with the particular
docker hub you can set up the
credentials once the credentials is
being set up so what you can do is that
you can go ahead and say that okay the
uh configurations is done and we can go
ahead and we can perform the execution
so docker login is the command where you
can give the credentials docker info is
the command using which you can get the
uh information about the docker tool so
whatever the docker info is available
there so those things you can actually
get it over here in the case of the
docker info so docker info is going to
give you complete information that what
exactly you have the information
available over here on this one
and then we have the docker history so
using the docker history you can see
history of the docker image that what
exactly uh the mechanisms or what are
the different image ids are available
there so this is basically giving you
the complete history on how the
docker image is prepared all the
commands is available there and that
will help you to eventually go and
understand that how the images can be
going on and you can manage on that part
so uh these are some of the couple of
options which is available there where
we can see that how the executions can
be done and we can go ahead on that
particular part so docker history is the
command again which will help you to see
that how you can go for the particular
mechanism and you can listen on on the
things over there so docker login was
already done previously when we try to
push the image but again if you try to
run docker login you will be able to do
that now docker info is something which
will give some additional information
about the docker and all the
informations about the docker will be
given back to you over here in this one
so the complete clarity
uh then let's say that you got a docker
image called
httpd now you want to check the history
of this image that how this image is
prepared what are the different layers
which is available how many layers are
there how much size is being modified in
each and every layer so you can see that
we got a layer where we have a
particular changes of 7.838 mb but
pretty much the uh company from the
complete size of this httpd the major
portion is actually of the uh this one
the basic operating system which is
being implemented and then of course
there are some packages which got
deployed due to which this uh 60 mb and
7mp size is coming up there so this
actually gives you the complete layer
wise mechanism that what are the
informations which is available that how
the modifications actually got modified
and got changed over here in this one so
this is the additional uh help which you
can get from the docker to
manage the containers here
so these are the ways where you can
interact with the docker hub if you
really want to create a volumes for the
container so you can go for the docker
volume create command so docker volume
create command is there using which you
can create the docker volumes and you
can pretty much do that uh setup so
docker volume create is the command
which is available there for that
particular part it will create a volume
for you now let's see that how we can
actually work with the volume so you can
run the command called docker volume ls
to find out what are the different
volumes which is available there now if
you really want to create a volume over
here in this one so you can say like
docker volume create and you can go for
the
volume name here
now the moment you do that what will
happen that a volume will be created and
you can validate it with the help of
docker volume ls command that whether
the volume is being created or not over
here so this is the way that how you can
manage the volumes onto the docker host
now let's talk about some of the docker
swamp commands here now docker spam
commands is there to set up a particular
mechanism where you can see that how you
can perform a setup you can actually go
ahead and see that how the setup and
modifications can be done
so docker swamp is there where we can
see that how the execution needs to be
done so
you can go for the command called docker
spam init command this will actually go
for an initialization of our docker
swamp cluster and once the docker spam
cluster is initialized then you can
pretty much go there and perform
whatever the executions you want to
perform you can do that and you can
execute as such over there so docker
swap init is a command using which you
can actually see that how the execution
needs to be done
and how we can perform the uh you know
mechanism and the changes over here so
docker sam init
hyphen fn advice uh adr address is there
which helps you to see that how the
executions can be done
now joins you have the docker swamp join
command which is available there
now if you go for docker swam join
command so
uh you can have a particular host so
dockers swam join command is there which
you can run on the node machine and in
that case what will happen that node
will be a part of the docker spam
cluster
and then if you want to leave uh from
the swamp cluster then you can go for
docker swam leave command and it will be
simply removed from the docker swamp
cluster there some of the couple of
commands which using which we can
initialize or we can
remove from the docker spam cluster here
so docker
spam is already being initialized or is
being created when the moment you do the
installation of docker so docker swam in
it is the command using which you can in
the last uh analyzer docker container
now once you analyze over here so
initial after the initialization you got
a command you which you want to add it
like you want to run it onto the docker
spam uh cluster
it will act like a worker node so that
you will be able to deploy the
containers on top of that also if you
want to join it as a manager so you can
also get the join token again so it will
give you the proper command
now if you run like docker
node ls so you will be able to see like
what are the different nodes which is
available there and for any reason if
you're not comfortable with that and you
want to re-initialize your docker spam
cluster so all you can do is that you
can say like docker
swam and leave iphone f and you will be
left out of the docker spam and now if
you want to run like knock docker node
ls you will not be able to get that
output because it's saying that there is
no uh particular swarm manager which is
available so you can run docker spam in
it or you can run the join command to
connect to that specific node but we
have already left it and nothing is
available over here so that's a way that
how you can manage like what are the
different docker spam commands we can
typically run to manage the docker spam
cluster now let's talk about the docker
compose commands now docker compose
commands is actually there using which
we can create multiple containers it's
not only one container which can we can
create we can create go for multiple
creations of the containers with the
help of docker compose file so docker
compose hyphen version is the you
command which we can give you the
version of docker compose which is being
used so here we use a particular vml
format file which will help us to create
the multiple containers we define the
services that what are the different
containers we want to create here and
then with the help of a docker hyphen
compose dot ml file we can create or we
can have that particular docker compose
file setup over here in this case so
docker hyphen compose.vml file is used
to do the setup and the modification so
that you will be able to have the
modifications done and you will be able
to find out a particular
multiple containers gets created all
together so docker compose is there is
the way that how you can do the setup
how you are going to run the docker
compose file so in that case you're
going to run the docker hyphen compose
up command which will help you to set up
like how the compose can be done and
once you are done with the docker hyphen
compose up command so using this the
compose will be done and the containers
will be up and running so these are the
commands using which we can manage
multiple containers using the docker
compose one so let's try to run some
commands related to docker compose so
docker hyphen compose iphone version
will let you know that what exactly
version of docker compose is installed
into your system so you can run typical
app command to do the installation so
docker hyphen composes the package name
which you can install so that the
executables and the package can be
installed into your system onto the
server now all we need to do is that we
need to create a docker compose file so
what we need to do is that we need to
create a docker hyphen compose dot yml
file is the default name of the vml file
which we want to create here that's a
standard name so once you create this
all you need to do is like you need to
put some values attributes the very
first one is the version value that what
version of
this particular attribute you want to
create here let's say that i want to
create a version too so i will configure
here that yes the version 2 is what i
require i want to set up over here in
this one
now again if i want to configure that
what are the different services we want
to run because services is the main
thing which we will be running on this
machine on the server here so that's
what we require so then we need to put
for a particular service called web so
web service we want to search and we
want to run and then again we need to
take care about the spacing because
that's a very important part
and we need to provide the values of the
image
and
all these configurations here so that
you should be able to set up like how
the uh images and how the docker images
can be built up over here so uh web is
the service which you want to deploy and
then of course the image is the
attribute which is there for the web
that yes engine is the one which we are
trying to build up now you can give the
ports configuration also so you can say
like ports
and inside that you can say like what
port mapping you want to perform so you
can say like
8080 so or sorry 80
is what you can dash for the engine x
because it runs on 80 port but now i
have to run like 84 i want to attach
that port over here in this one so i can
specify that 80 port should be available
in this one so i'm going to save this
one here and i'm going to run a command
called docker iphone compose up now this
will run the containers in the
interactive mode but if you feel that i
want to run in the detach mode so you
can say like hyphen d also which will of
course run these ones into the detach
mode and it will be executed so it will
process your docker compose file and
since you have used a standard name
called hyphen docker hyphen compose dot
ml so it will automatically pick that
docker or details and start creating the
container kubernetes is an open source
platform used for deployment and
management of containers so let's get
started now the first step is to install
the necessary dependencies using two of
the commands first is sudo apt get
update which gets all the updates
and then you have to enter a password
so this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport https this is basically
used to make repositories via https so
let's go ahead with that sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency using the command sudo
apt install docker dot io
you have to choose why
and this will take a few minutes
okay that's done so after installing the
docker we have to start and enable the
docker using the command sudo system ctl
start docker and sudo system cto enable
dock
so now the docker is enabled so now we
are done with the first step of
installation the next step is we have to
install the necessary components for
kubernetes before that we have to
install the curl command because current
command is used to send data using a url
syntax let's install the curl command
using the command sudo apt-get install
code
so you have to select y
and this will take few minutes
so moving on the next step we have to do
is download and add key for kubernetes
installation from a url so let's go
ahead with that sudo curl
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it using sudo apt key at
and it's done so the next step is we
have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using c or sudo chmod command
okay so the permission is changed now
let's go ahead and save this file in
that location first we have to enter
this command into the file
this is a url
save as
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to
kubernetes
dot
list now let's see
okay so here it is now moving forward
now we have to check for any updates
available
in the next command we are going to
install the kubernetes components that
is cubelet cubadium cubectel and
kubernetes cmi so let's go ahead with
that
so this is going to take a few minutes
now that's done so the next step we have
to initialize the master node and to do
this we have to first use a swap off
command to disable the swapping on other
devices so let's do that sudo swap off
hyperlink
now let's go ahead with the
initialization sudo
cube adm in it
this is going to take a few minutes
okay so before going to the next step to
start the cluster we have to use these
three commands let's just copy paste it
okay that's done
so
moving forward the next step is to
deploy paths using the following command
now the pods have been deployed to our
network to see all the pods you have to
use the command sudo cubic till get pots
[Music]
there you can see the parts that have
been deployed so why kubernetes well
kubernetes is really being built from
allowing you to be able to have a more
reliable infrastructure the tool itself
is designed to manage the containers you
have within your network it's very
modular in architecture which allows it
to be very easy to be able to maintain
and to be able to scale and meet the
demands that your current customers are
offering you today the actual ability
for you to be able to deploy and update
software at scale is really at the heart
and center of kubernetes it's really one
of the reasons why kubernetes was
created was to be able to scale up the
deployment of software into tens of
thousands of networks and servers uh
within a data center and then finally uh
when you start working with kubernetes
really what you're doing is laying the
foundation for building cloud native
applications and part of this comes from
the architecture and history of
kubernetes which we'll get to in a
little bit but it's good to know that as
you're using kubernetes and
containerized solutions that you're
really building out an infrastructure
that's designed for cloud-centric
solution delivery so let's dig into why
what kubernetes is so the history of
kubernetes is that it was originally
developed by google google actually used
the precursor to kubernetes to manage
and maintain the
data structure and data infrastructure
that they had within their network they
really liked it and one of the big
benefits that kubernete that google
provided is that they converted their
code into an open source program that
they released as kubernetes in 2014 and
made an open source this means that any
company can use kubernetes there's no
charge for it all you have to do is know
how to use the command lines to actually
get up and running the benefit of
kubernetes being open source is that
most cloud providers now support
kubernetes so whether you're using
microsoft azure you're using google
cloud or aws you'll find that you can
actually use kubernetes and kubernetes
and edit core really helped eliminate
manual processes so it allows for
deploying and scaling your
container-based solutions much more
effortless within a cloud environment so
let's jump into the features of
kubernetes and why you'd want to be
using it and we have a number of
features that we want to kind of step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes within
your network or whether you're managing
10 000 doesn't matter you have the
ability to scale that something you
simply didn't have before kubernetes
also will manage the actual containers
themselves um including the security and
the storage and the networking within
those containers the great uh benefit of
working with kubernetes is that not only
is it a cloud-centric solution but it
was really built from a core
need of a secure solution so security is
at the heart and center of all the work
you're doing which really helps benefit
any teams scaling out containers your
kubernetes environment will be
constantly monitored so that when you
have nodes that have your containers the
health of those nodes is being
constantly communicated back to
the kubernetes environment so that the
entire environment is always being
managed and checked so if you have any
um additional hosting and launching that
needs to be done uh kubernetes will help
you automate those manual processes uh
if something does go wrong you can
actually set up your kubernetes
environment to do an automatic roll back
again this is just allowing you to have
that confidence that when you're
deploying a solution that everything is
going to work within that environment
and then finally kubernetes will allow
you to mount and add the storage needed
to run your apps so whether you have
storage such as a local ssd storage
device physically on the hardware or if
you're connecting to storage via the
cloud kubernetes will allow you to
access the storage you need how you're
accessing it so let's look a little bit
into the differences between kubernetes
and docker swarm so if we just step back
a little bit kubernetes and docker often
get connected with each other uh largely
because kubernetes manages containers
and docker is really famous for creating
the most popular uh container management
solution which is called docker if
you're a developer you're probably
already using docker today so one of the
things that kubernetes is really really
good at is that it manages containers at
scale just massive volume of containers
docker swarm is docker's alternative to
kubernetes it's a tool that allows you
to also manage large number large
numbers of containers um there are
differences between the two of them and
right now without doubt the most popular
open source solution out there is
kubernetes from google it just has a
massive community behind it and the
community
really have embraced kubernetes and yes
the original product was by developed by
google but google has been great steward
and they've allowed the community to
drive the future evolution of the
product uh docker swarm is actually
managed and developed by docker um there
is a smaller community but it is also a
very passionate community and the reason
being is that both products are actually
pretty good and you just really kind of
have to choose which one you want to go
with without doubt there is more
customization and extensions built for
kubernetes simply because community is
just so much bigger than the docker
swarm community um but with that said
docker swarm is really easy to set up so
if you are used to working within the
docker environment you'll be able to set
up docker swarm very very quickly
whereas kubernetes does require some
heavy lifting to get up and running now
with that said if you are using
microsoft azure or google cloud very
often those environments will actually
set up kubernetes for you so you don't
have to do it and you can actually then
focus on writing the instructions to
maintain your kubernetes environment
kubernetes um has extremely high fault
tolerance again
it's because kubernetes is has been road
tested the foundation for kubernetes is
based on managing sites such as gmail
google.com youtube i mean just
incredibly robust environment compared
to docker swamp which has lower fault
tolerance um and this really kind of
leads into
the final areas where kubernetes does
guarantee um strong clusters and
management just a really reliable
environment docker swarm however is able
to
take containers and deploy them into
large casters very very quickly two
interesting differences is that with
kubernetes the load balancing is still
manual and be interesting to watch how
kubernetes matures that skill set uh in
contrast uh load balancing is automatic
within docker swarm so let's dig into
the kubernetes architecture and just
kind of expose some of those key
elements um if you're interested in
actually having a very deep dive into
kubernetes architecture we have already
got another video and we should have a
link in the comments that you can select
that will take you to that video as well
but this will provide you an overview as
well um so the way that kubernetes runs
is that it uses nodes to actually manage
all the individual hardware within a
specific unit and so a node is really a
physical machine
in a data center or a virtual machine
and when you're setting up an
environment on a cloud environment such
as microsoft azure or google cloud or
aws kubernetes will be managing the
containers within that node so it's
important to know that kubernetes itself
doesn't work with the individual nodes
but actually works with the cluster as a
whole and and why that's important is
that it's a tool to manage your entire
environment it's not going to come down
and manage the individual node itself
it's going to match the entire
environment the actual control of data
within a cluster um it's very very
flexible within kubernetes you can have
local storage such as an ssd
card or a traditional local storage or
you can actually connect to the cloud
and use cloud-based storage and the
benefit that cloud-based storage offers
you is that you are increasingly moving
your solution into more of a
hardware free environment cloud-based
architecture where you're not reliant on
a physical piece of hardware within your
data center and why that's important is
that it gives you the opportunity to
scale up your solutions much more
effectively so if you need to increase
the hard drive space you can do that
very easily from the cloud whereas local
hardware is a little bit harder to
manage great news kubernetes gives you
both options to be able to uh choose
from and so the the next layer down is
the actual management of the application
that's within a container and as
mentioned earlier docker is the most
popular container solution out there and
again if you're a developer you're
probably already using docker as it was
a natural maturity from using a virtual
machine but kubernetes itself will
actually manage the containers that you
have within your nodes and so you have a
collection of containers working
together and then you pull those
together into what's called a pod and
what's great is kubernetes will actually
manage the health of that part so if a
container or a pod fails kubernetes will
automatically deploy out a replica so
your entire environment can stay running
and being efficient and so the pods
themselves will actually be managed by
kubernetes and you really want to
let kubernetes um do this because it's
allowing you to
step away from the manual management of
parts your environment is just going to
be healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the parts
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to from services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called ingress and
going back earlier we talked about how
security is a key part of all the work
that goes into kubernetes and this is a
great example of where you can use an
external service but still have that
layer of security that is vital for your
solution because to be able to provide
the ingress connection kubernetes
requires an ssl connection which um
automatically allows for a secure data
transfer absolutely fantastic so here we
have an overview of the actual
architecture on the right hand side we
have our nodes and the pods within our
nodes and within those pods are the
containers on the left hand side we have
the master architecture and the master
architecture is the actual brains behind
the work that you're doing it's actually
managing the schedules the controllers
for all of the nodes and then at the
bottom left-hand side we have commands
which are written on a local workstation
and those commands are pushed up to the
master so let's kind of dig a little bit
further into the architecture of the
master um so the master itself is
comprised of a number of key components
and again this is the tool that's going
to manage your uh entire kubernetes
infrastructure the key components that
you have are the
etcd control manager scheduler api
server and the key four components are
etcd
or the cluster store the controller
manager the scheduler and the api server
the cluster store is the tool where all
the details of the work that you're
doing is stored and it's going to manage
the rules going to manage all the
instructions and this is where you're
going to post that information the
controller is actually going to then
perform the tasks that are stored in the
cluster store and as you'd expect the
schedule is the tool that actually
controls when instructions and tasks are
pushed out to
all the pods and nodes within your
network and then finally you have an api
server which allows you to be able to
control all the operations the actual
operations themselves are all
instructions written um as rest
instructions and which allows you to
take advantage of the security that has
been built into rest and so you end up
with a worker slave architecture and
slaves are all the different nodes and
pods within your network and so a part
itself will have multiple one or more
multiple containers and then each
container and then each part will have a
docker container a kubelet and a
kubernetes proxy and the these are tools
to allow you to communicate back up to
the master layer so the docker is the
actual container itself and this is
going to actually run your application
and
the instructions here are to pull down
the correct container from the docker
images that you have within your library
the cubelet is going to manage your
containers and your container
instructions that will be deployed to
the cubelet are going to be written in
either yaml or json format yaml is just
great if you haven't had a chance to
start working with yaml i certainly
encourage you to do so it's very easy to
pick up if you know any xml you'll pick
up yaml very quickly and finally the
kubernetes proxy is the tool that
interacts with the master environment
within the kubernetes network and allows
all the instructions from that are
pushed to the kubelet and to docker to
be able to perform effectively so let's
have a look at some of the companies
using kubernetes there are a lot and if
you're doing any work today in the cloud
and even if you're just starting off and
doing some simple
work in the cloud there's a really good
chance that you are using kubernetes but
some of the companies that you would are
probably not surprised at using
kubernetes are spotify sap ebay
and of course some of the the big
companies out there google with their
entire network of solutions and
microsoft with office and their tools so
let's take a a step into a youtube now
let's have a look at a kubernetes use
case and in this example we're going to
look at the new york times and how they
use kubernetes to solve a problem that
their iit department was struggling with
so when a new york times started working
out of their data centers their their
actual deployments were small and the
applications were managed across vms but
the problem is is that as new york times
became more of a digital company they
started building more digital solutions
and at some point they realized that uh
what they needed to do was to embrace
the cloud and move all their solutions
to the cloud however their first step of
using the cloud and this is i think
typical for a lot of companies is they
treated the cloud hosted provider in the
same way as they would with a data
center and they at some point they
realized they had to take a change and
this is where the development team came
in and they said look how about we stop
thinking of our solutions as a data
center even though they're being run in
amazon and start thinking them as cloud
first solutions and so what they
proposed and what they ended up doing
was using google cloud platform with
kubernetes as a service um to
provide greater efficiency and so by
using kubernetes they have the following
advantages they're able to deliver
solutions at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they're able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time that
uptime for the actual infrastructure um
updates began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you do the deployment it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the new york times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to do solutions through a more
traditional ticket-based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
new york times website so let's finally
kind of look into some of the important
terminologies before we take our time to
do a demo so we have six terms that
we're going to look through um and uh
we'll let you uh uh read through this
but uh we have a cluster which is a set
of machines physical vertical in which
applications are managed and run we have
a node that are the working machines
that run containerized applications and
other workloads there is the pod which
is within a node and is a group of
containers that are deployed together on
the same host we have replication
controllers and a replication controller
is used to define a pods life cycle
rather than to create the pods directly
we have a selector which is an
expression match label to filter
specific resources labels are key value
pairs that are attached to objects such
as parts and the key value pair or the
label can be filter organize and perform
operations on resources replication sets
define how many replicas of each pod
will be running and manage when you want
to either replace a pod when it dies
annotation is a label with much larger
data capacity a name is a resource as it
is identified volume is the direction
which data is accessible to a container
namespaces provide additional
qualification to resources name and then
finally service is an abstraction of a
top tier pods which provide a single iep
address and dns name by which the pods
can be accessed so at this time what we
want to do is take you through
kubernetes demo actually runs through
some of these basic controls so i'm
going to take you through a video of how
to actually install kubernetes um and to
use some of the basic instructions so
kubernetes is the most widely used
platform for mac container management
the first step is to actually install
the necessary dependencies so let's see
if there's any updates first so the
first so to check if there's any updates
we'll use the command sudo app dash get
update i'm going to enter in our
password and this looks like it's going
to take a few minutes because we've got
a few updates that need to be running
all right we're done all right next
we're going to write sudo apt-get
install dash y apt
transport https and this will install
all the dependencies we need to actually
start installing the solutions needed
for kubernetes all right that was quick
now we're going to put in the docker
dependency and the way we do that is
write the command sudo apt install
docker dot io i'll go to typo correct
that quickly and put in y so for yes and
we continue and it's going to take a
while because we're going to download
and install docker off the internet and
it's quite a large installation now
would be a good time to go get a cup of
coffee because it'll take us about a
minute to get this all done once we
actually have docker installed we'll let
you go ahead and we'll start docker and
enable docker using our sudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start to enable docker we're using so
we're going to use sudo systemctl start
docker and sudo systemctl enable docker
this will be quite quick
so the next step is to install all the
components for kubernetes and we're
going to
install the curl command and then
kuberlette cube c
and then cube adm and we're going to
install all the necessary tools we'll do
the curl command cubelet cubic c2 and
cube adm and so let's go ahead and put
in the sudo apt-get install curl we're
going to get a prompt we can say yes for
that
and then after this we'll go ahead and
install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be pseudo curl dash s
and then we have
long url which is https packages.cloud
google.com apt doc apt
key.gpg
apt dash key there we go and create my
typo there
okay now we have to go ahead and change
permissions of like folder so we do that
with sudo chmod
777 slash etcetera slash apt
sources dot list dot d all right we're
good okay now you wanna go ahead and
open up your text editor and we're gonna
make um an actual edit um and we're
going to create a simple file and so
what we're going to type in is the the
following command db http
apt
dot kubernetes dot io slash kubernetes
xenial
main and we're going to save this file
in the etc folder and then look for and
then a apt which is going to be down a
little bit and there we have it and
we're going to save it in the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file as
kubernetes dot list and we'll save that
and then we can close out the notepad
and go back to the terminal window and
let's look and see if there are any
updates again so we're gonna go ahead
and run apt-get update and it's going to
run any updates from what we've created
and we want to check what's in the
folder and so we do
cat slash except
etc
apt sources dot d slash kubernetes dot
list and there we are it shows what we
have in that text file and so we're
gonna go ahead and we're going to uh
install uh cubelet cubic cubic 2 and q
adm but first we're going to have to
initialize the master i'm going to show
you what an error you would get if you
were to install cubelet um and the other
files too quickly you get the following
error
all right so we have installed cubelet
qbadm cubex tool and kubernetes cni and
so we're going to go ahead and use sudo
swap
dash hyphen a and now we're going to
initialize the master node and we're
going to do that with sudo cube
adm in it and this will take a few
minutes for it to initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the pod to a
network and we have two commands that
we're going to use we use sudo kubu cube
ctl apply and then we have a long
pathway to type out which is dash f
https raw github's
content.com choreos final master
documentation cube dash final dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by now
creating
mktr
p
and then we have
dollar sign home dash dot cube we'll
create that new directory and sudo cp
dash i and then the path will be uh etc
slash kubernetes admin dot conf and then
dollar sign home slash dot cube dot
slash config
and then final one will be
sudo c-h-o-w-n dollar sign open brand id
dash u close paren colon dollar sign
brand id slash dash g close paren dollar
sign home slash dot cube
config all right now we're going to go
ahead and uh deploy and uh let's see uh
oh yeah i think i have a typo in my
command here yep oh yeah i did have a
typo and so um i've got that incorrect
now so documentation is actually spelt
with a t not an s and then we're going
to go ahead and we're going to put in
the next
line which is pseudo cubic
cube ctl apply
dash f and then we're just going to
change a little bit of the um actual
link here and that runs great and now we
want to be able to see all of the parts
that we have in our network and so we're
going to do that by
writing the command sudo
cubic c tcl uh get pods dash all dash
dash name spaces and it should list all
of our pods we only have one
there we are there's all our content now
we're going to so there's only one node
so let's see what we have here so we're
going to use the command sudo uh cubic
tl get nodes there we are just one node
so our final step is to actually go
ahead and deploy a service and so what
we're going to go ahead is deploy the
nginx service and we're going to do that
with the command sudo cubexctl run
dashbash image equals nginx and we're
going to put this into port 80 so it's
going to be nginx
app dash dash port equals 80 dash
environment emd equals uh ubun cone open
quotes uh domain equals cluster close
quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is sudo cube ctl expose
deployment nginx dash app dash dash port
equals 80
name equals nginx dash http and once
we've done this we'll be able to then
run the command to actually see our
services and there'll be quite a few of
them
and our final command is sudo docker ps
dash a
there we have quite a lot of lists quite
a lot of services listed so there you
are that's the instructions on how to
get docker up and running and uh with
some basic commands um it it's worth
going through a few times to
get right um but
once you actually have um the
kubernetes environment up and running
and managing your docker environment in
containers it's extremely powerful we're
going to take a deep dive into the
kubernetes architecture so let's have an
overview of the kubernetes architecture
so kubernetes is really broken up into
three key areas you have your
workstation where you develop your
commands and you push out those commands
to your master and the master is
comprised of
four key areas um which essentially
control all of your nodes and and the
node contains multiple pods and each pod
has your docker container built into it
so consider that you could have a really
almost an infinite number of pods sorry
infinite number of nodes are being
managed by the master environment so you
have your cluster which is a collection
of servers that um maintain the
availability and the compute power such
as ram cpu and disk utilization and you
have the master which is really
components that control and schedule the
activities of your network and then you
have the node which actually hosts the
actual docker virtual machine itself um
and be able to actually control and
communicate back to the master the
health of that pod and we'll get into
more detail in the architecture later in
the presentation so
you know you keep hearing me talk about
containers but they really are the
center of the work that you're doing
with
kubernetes and can the concept around
kubernetes and containers is really just
a natural evolution of where we've been
with internet and digital technologies
over the last 10 15 years so
before kubernetes you had tools where
you're either running virtual machines
or you're running uh data centers that
had to maintain and
manage and notify you of any
interruptions in your network kubernetes
is the tool that actually comes in and
helps address those interruptions and
manages them for you so the solution to
this is the use of containers so uh you
can think of containers as that natural
evolution from you know uh 15 20 years
ago you would have written your code and
posted it to a data center more recently
you probably post your code to a virtual
machine and then move the virtual
machine and now you actually just work
directly into a container and everything
is self-contained and can be pushed out
to your
environment and the thing that's great
about containers they're they're
isolated environments very easy for
developers to work in them but it's also
really easy for
operations teams to be able to move a
container into production so let's kind
of step in and back and look at a
competing product to kubernetes which is
docker swarm now one of the things that
we have to remember is that uh daca um
containers which are extremely popular
um built by the company docker and made
open source and docker actually has
other products one of those other
products is docker swarm and docker
swarm is a tool that allows you to be
able to manage multiple containers so if
we look at some of the uh the benefits
of using docker swarm versus kubernetes
and one of the things that you'll find
is that both tools have strengths and
weaknesses but it's really good that
they're both out there because it helps
keep it really kind of justifies the
importance of having these kind of tools
so kubernetes was designed originally
from the ground up to be auto scaling
whereas docker swarm isn't the load
balancing is automatic on docker swan
whereas with kubernetes you have to
manually configure load balancing across
your nodes the installation for docker
swarm is really fast and easy i mean you
can be up and running within minutes a
kubernetes takes a little bit more time
is a little bit more complicated
eventually you'll get there um i mean
it's not like it's going to take you
days and weeks but it's it is a tool
that's a when you compare the two docker
swarms much easier to get up and running
now what's interesting is that
kubernetes is incredibly scalable and
it's you know that's its real strength
is its ability to have strong clusters
whereas with docker swarm its cluster
strength isn't um as strong when
compared to kubernetes now you compare
it to anything else on the market it's
really good um so this is kind of a
splitting hairs kind of comparison but
kubernetes really does have the
advantage here if you're looking at the
two compared to each other for
scalability i mean kubernetes was
designed for by google to scale up and
support uh google cloud network
infrastructure they
both allow you to be able to share um
storage volumes with docker you can
actually do it with um any container uh
with um that is managed by the docker
swamp whereas with kubernetes it manages
the storage with the pods and a party
can have multiple containers within it
but you can't take it down to the level
of the container interestingly uh
kubernetes does have a graphical user
interface um for being able to control
and manage uh the environment the
reality however is that you're likely to
be using terminal uh to actually make
the controls and commands to control
your um either docker swarm or
kubernetes environment um it's great
that it has a gui and to get you started
but once you're up and running you're
going to be using terminal window for
those fast quick administrative controls
that you need to make so let's look at
the hardware components for
kubernetes so and what's interesting is
that kubernetes is extremely light of
all the systems that we're looking at
it's extremely lightweight um it's um
allows you to have if you compare it to
like a virtual machine which is very
heavy it you know
kubernetes is extremely lightweight and
hardly uses any resources at all
interesting enough though is that if you
are looking at the usage of cpu it's
better to actually take it for
the cluster as a whole rather than
individual nodes because the nodes will
actually combine together to give you
that whole compute power again this is
why kubernetes works really well in the
cloud where you can do that kind of
activity rather than if you're running
in your own data center um so you can
have persistent volumes such as a local
ssd
or you can actually attach to a cloud
data storage again kubernetes is really
designed for the cloud i would encourage
you to use cloud storage wherever
possible rather than relying on physical
storage uh the reason being is that if
you connect to cloud storage and you
need to flex your your storage the cloud
will do that for you i mean that's just
an inherent part of why you'd have cloud
storage whereas if you're connecting to
physical storage you're always
restricted to the limitations of the
physical hardware so let's kind of pivot
and look at the software components as
compared to the hardware components so
the main part of the components is the
actual container and all of the software
running in the container runs on linux
so if you um have docker installed as a
developer on your machine it's actually
running inside of linux and that's what
makes it so lightweight and really one
of the things that you'll find is that
most data centers and cloud providers
now are running predominantly on linux
inside of the um the container itself is
then managed inside of a pod and a pod
is really just a group of containers
bundled together and
the kubernetes scheduler and proxy
server then actually manage what how the
pods are actually pushed out into your
kubernetes environment the the pods
themselves can actually then share
resources both networking and storage so
parts aren't um pushed out manually
they're actually managed through a layer
of abstraction and part of their
deployment and and this is the strength
of kubernetes you use use um to find
your um infrastructure and then
kubernetes will then manage it for you
and there isn't that problem of um
manual management of pods uh if you have
to manage the deployment of them and you
that's simply taken away and it's
completely automated and the the final
area of software services is on ingress
and this is really the secure way of
being able to have communication from
outside of the cluster and passing of
information into that cluster and again
this is done securely through ssl layers
and allows you to ensure that security
is at the center of the work that you
have within your kubernetes environment
so let's dive now into the actual
architecture before we start looking at
a use case of how kubernetes is being
employed so kubernetes again is um we
looked at this uh diagram at the
beginning of the presentation and there
are really three key areas there's the
workstation where you develop your
commands and then you have your master
environment which uh controls the
scheduling the communication um and the
actual
commands that you have created and
pushes those out and manages the health
of your entire node network and each
node has various pods so we like break
this down so the master node is the most
vital component and with the master uh
you have four key controls you have etc
controller manager scheduler and api
server the cluster store etc this
actually measures the details and values
that you've developed on your local
workstation um and then we'll work with
the out the control schedule and api
server to communicate that out those
instructions of how your infrastructure
should look like to your entire network
the control manager is really an api
server and again um this is all about
security so we use restful apis um which
can be packaged in ssl to communicate
back and forth um across your
pods and the master and indeed the
services within each of them as well so
um at every single layer of abstraction
uh the communication is secure uh the
schedule as the name would imply really
schedules uh when tasks get sent out to
the actual nodes themselves the nodes
themselves are are done nodes they just
have uh the applications um running on
them the master in the sperm is really
doing all of the work uh to make sure
that your entire network is running um
efficiently and then you have the api
server which has your rest commands and
the communication and back and forth
across your network so that is secure
and efficient so your node environment
is where all the work that you do with
your containers gets pushed out too so a
work is really a it's a combination of
containers and each container will then
logically run together on that node so
you'd have a collection of containers uh
on a node that all make logical sense to
have together within each node you have
docker and this is your isolated
environment for running your container
you have your kubelet which is a service
for conveying information back and forth
to the service about the actual health
of the kubernetes node itself and then
finally you have the proxy server and
the proxy server is able to manage the
nodes the volumes the the creation of
new containers um and actually helps
pass the communicate the health of the
container back up to the master to see
whether or not the containers should be
either killed stop started or
updated so finally let's look and see
where kubernetes is being used by other
companies so you know kubernetes is
being used by a lot of companies and
they're really using it to help manage
complex existing systems so that they
can have greater performance and with
the end goal being able to delight the
customer and increase value to the
customer and enhance uh increased value
and revenue into the organization so an
example of this is a company called
blackrock where they actually went
through the process of implementing
kubernetes so they
so blackrock had a challenge where they
needed to be able to have much more
dynamic access to their resources and
they were running complex installations
on people's desktops and it was just
really really difficult to be able to
manage their entire infrastructure so
they actually went and pivoted to using
kubernetes and this allowed them to be
able to be much more scalable and
expansive in the in the management of
their infrastructure and as you can
imagine kubernetes was then hooked into
their entire existing system and has
really become a key part of the success
that blackrock is now experiencing of a
very stable infrastructure um and the
bottom line is that uh blackrock is now
able to have confidence in their
infrastructure and be able to give that
confidence um as back to their customers
through the implementation and more
rapid deployment of additional features
and services cooperate is specific to
aws cloud platform what are
orchestration tools
the application development and the life
cycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has the requirement
that it has in terms of the hardware the
features of fault tolerance self-healing
capabilities auto scaling all this has
complicated over the last few years as a
part of devops one thing that everyone
is interested in is managing all this
application dependency or lifecycle
management using some or the other kind
of a tool so that's where these
orchestration tools have become very
very popular so what kind of features
that they provide is you'll have to just
let them know what are the kinds of tool
sets that is required what are the fault
tolerance mechanisms that it has to be
adopted to what kind of a self-filling
capabilities that application will have
to need and if at all there is any auto
scaling features that is required if at
all you can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
orchestration tool becomes a one-stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where this orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management docker swarm and
kubernetes many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with apache
missions there are many other container
management systems but i'm going to pick
docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two frameworks for the sake of
comparison i picked up docker swarm and
kubernetes just because of the reason
that both of them operate in the space
of container management they do
something very very similar to
containers that's the similarity that
exists between these two orchestration
tools however there's a big difference
that exists when it comes to the types
of containers that both of them cater to
and also the capacity of workloads they
can be used for docker swarm is a
cluster management solution that is
provided by docker container docker is
one of the very very popular containers
of recent times and in case you have
your applications that is totally
powered by only docker containers if you
have a need where you want to run a
cluster of servers which are running
only docker containers docker swarm
should be your choice for your
orchestration tool kubernetes on the
other hand can cater to any other types
of containers other than docker and
including docker as well so in case you
have your applications which have got
docker in them which have got rkt in
them which they have got alex in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
too a docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 max
nodes so in case your application is
totally written in docker containers and
the load or the expected cluster size is
about 50 60 nodes docker swarm should be
your choice of orchestration tool on the
other hand kubernetes is something that
was open sourced by google and the kind
of the scale of operations that
kubernetes can cater to is google scale
so if in case your applications are more
than a thousand nodes that is where
kubernetes comes into play that's the
big difference that exists between
docker swarm and kubernetes putting
those differences aside let me compare
docker swarm and kubernetes based upon
other features which are similar in
nature the first and important feature
that kubernetes provides is something
called as auto scaling if at all the
load on your cluster is too high an
application is experiencing more load so
kubernetes can add new nodes to your
cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new vms or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the fly
based upon the load that exists at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify a
few of those nodes which have got less
number of replicas or less number of
application containers running on it it
can move them to some other node and
also scale down by deleting few nodes
from your cluster so that is the
powerfulness of auto scaling which is
provided by kubernetes and this
unfortunately does not exist in docker
swarm the other feature of load
balancing specifically application node
balancing so docker swarm gives you an
application level auto load balancing
however kubernetes gives you the
flexibility of manually configuring any
other type of load balancer of your
choice for application load balancing
installation as i mentioned earlier
docker swarm is a loose cluster of
containers which are running on nodes it
is very easy to spin up a new node and
then connect them to a swarm and this
can be done in a very very loosely
coupled way where you can create swarms
of your choice notes are allowed to
connect to swarms and quit or leave the
swamps on the fly so in and all the
installation is pretty easy and fast
kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes is the way
to spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node how many masternodes
how many config planes that you want how
many nodes that you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes strength is very
very strong they are very tightly
coupled and even they have the
capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the fly based upon the requirement on a
docker swarm the cluster strength is
weak as compared to cobra days worker
notes can be added to a swarm worker
notes can be asked to leave us form or
can be taken out of a swarm based upon
the requirement so this is kind of a
loosely coupled architecture for docker
swarm while kubernetes the cluster is
very tightly coupled since docker swarm
runs only docker containers containers
find it very easy to share data and lot
of other things with each other because
they all have the same signature they
are all from the same family so it's
very easy for them to share not just
volumes but lot of other things however
for kubernetes since it manages
containers of different types if your
application has to share some data
across different containers there's a
little bit of a complexity in how you
would want your containers to share data
also when it comes to kubernetes
kubernetes groups containers in
something called as pods while a pod can
have either one container that's the
preferred choice or multiple containers
and the idea of pod is like each part
can run in any other node it's not
guaranteed that you would want to have
two or three parts to be running on the
same node that makes data sharing a
little bit of a different thing compared
to docker's form
gui so there's not a good enough ui tool
in docker's form at least the ce edition
of it which will allow you to get to
know what is running on your containers
what is the size of the containers what
is the volume of the containers and all
that stuff there are some free and open
source tools like portainer which gives
you a good visibility into your running
docker containers however there's
nothing at a swarm level that is
provided by docker kubernetes gives you
an out of the box dashboard which is
easy to configure and set up you can
also club it with some metrics services
and you can also get information about
the size of the cluster that is running
what is the load on the nodes and stuff
like that all this across your cluster
in a very beautiful dashboard
perspective so that way um this is
little bit of a good ui for kubernetes
while for docker's form there isn't
anything that is provided out of the box
let me spend some time in explaining a
little bit about the kubernetes
architecture what comprises of the
kubernetes cluster what resides in a
master or a control plane and what
resides in a worker node this is a very
high level uh depiction of a kubernetes
cluster so this is the master node which
has got something called as a cluster
store a controller a scheduler component
and an api server and these are the
bunch of nodes that are connected or
administered by the master node the
master node can be 1 3 5 typically an
odd number this is as per the typical
cluster management thing where you would
need the master nodes to be in odd
numbers so that whenever there's any
contention in terms of what needs to be
deployed where or where to give the job
to whom and stuff like that all the
masters would cast their vote and they
would decide on the outcome so that's
the master node and there are a bunch of
nodes which can be connected and
administered by the master node cubic
ctl or the command from using which
anybody can assign some workloads to the
cluster can also be run either on the
same node or on a separate node so
cubectl is the command line tool that we
will be installing and using in order to
fire up our commands to our cluster so
if at all i have to put up a job on our
cluster if i have to give out any
specific commands to my cluster all this
is done using cuba ctl there's a bunch
of rest apis which is used by cuba ctl
and cubectl will talk to the api server
and fire up the commands specific to my
cluster what runs in the master node
master node without saying it's the most
important component of any of the
cluster if at all you're running um
cluster with only one master node if
your master node goes down there's no
other way that you know you can or any
user can talk to the different nodes in
the cluster so master node is the most
vital component responsible for the
complete kubernetes cluster there's
always one node that should be running
as a master node that's the bare minimum
requirement for your cluster so what are
the other components in the master node
the most important one is called etcd so
this is nothing but a data store a value
of key value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which
node is up which worker node is down all
this information is stored in the
cluster store so all the managers would
access this cluster stored before they
go ahead and decide any other work item
or anything else that has to be done
specific to your cluster what's in the
controller as the name says controller
is something it's like a daemon server
that is running in a continuous loop all
the time it is responsible for
controlling the set of replicas the kind
of
workloads that is running based upon the
configuration that the user has set in
so if at all if you are aware of
something called as replication
controllers endpoint controllers
namespace controllers all these
controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asked
for some three replicas of a particular
pod or a service to be running and if at
all any of the nodes goes down or the
part goes down for whatever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the part
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what and in the cluster and
places the workload on whoever is the
available resource at that time all
right api server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster where how would the end user
deploy or give out any sort of a
workload onto your cluster all the
requests come to the api server so this
is an entry point for all your
requests that come into your cluster
anybody wants to deploy something
anybody want to scale up a controller
anybody who wants to bring down a few
services anybody wants to put in a
service all this will have to come in as
a part of a rest
api endpoint and api server is the enter
point in case you don't want uh you know
somebody to access your cluster in case
you want only specific people or
specific users to be running some
specific workloads you can set all those
role-based access control for this apa
server so this is the entry point for
anyone who wants to submit any job to
your cluster so that's a quick overview
about the master node what what are the
important components of a master node
now let's go over to what runs in a
worker or a slave node as i mentioned
earlier slave nodes are something where
the job that is submitted to your
cluster is eventually run as a pod as a
service as a container so in kubernetes
world there is something called as a pod
a pod is nothing but a combination of a
container it is a wrapper around your
running containers so slave nodes or the
worker nodes typically run these parts
so that is where the whole workload
typically gets run but there are a bunch
of other components in the in the node
which also manages what runs in the pod
who has to have access to the pod what
is the state of the pod is it in a
running state is it going down for some
reason and all the stuff so let's
quickly go over those components that is
there in the slave node the most
important component in my opinion that
should be on the on the node should be
the container runtime as i mentioned
earlier kubernetes can run any different
types of containers not just docker so
in case you want to have a node which
wants to have docker running on it rkt
running or lkc running on it or any
other container environment that is
running on it you have to ensure that
the specific container runtime
environment is available on that
specific node so that whenever a job is
submitted description of what needs to
be run as a part of the pod what should
be the image with it should be powered
and what kind of a container to spin up
so that's what you know when the job is
finally assigned to this particular node
it would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker node okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cubelet as the name says cubelet or
cubelet is a small subset which talks to
the cube api server so any node which
has to run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qbps server to the cubelet and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists
in the worker node is the cube proxy or
kubernetes proxy this plays a very very
important role acting as a load balancer
and a network proxy so what typically
happens is whenever the pods are running
in nodes the parts can be typically
running in any node there is no
affinity towards any node on which these
parts are running because pods or
containers are something called as
ephemeral they can run anywhere so how
would somebody reach out to these
applications that is running in some pod
which is running in one container now
and running in probably another
container another node altogether
tomorrow so that is where your
kubernetes proxy contains a picture and
this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these parts and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a dns server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the part on which the service
is typically running so that plays a
very very important role by acting as a
load balancer and a network proxy now
that at a very high level we know what
are all the components that make up of
our kubernetes cluster let's go ahead
and create a small cluster and spin up
this cluster on aws platform finally we
get to the demo section of my tutorial
now that you guys are aware as to what
is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes you also know at a very very
high level what are the components of a
cluster what is a master node or a
control plane what are the components of
a master node and what should be
existing in a worker node you're
probably thinking that it's maybe pretty
hard to kind of set this up so let me
demystify that by running you with a
quick demo of how to set up a simple
pre-node kubernetes cluster using a tool
called cops and i will be doing this
whole setup on my aws cloud okay so what
is cops cops is nothing but a simple
tool this is an admin tool that allows
you to bring up production grade
kubernetes environments as i said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why i would use something called as a
cops and i will use this on my cluster
which i'll spin up on my aws instance so
i have an aws account and what i will do
first is i will first spin up an ec2
server i will power this with one of the
linux amis and i will install cops on it
now this will be my starting point from
where i'm going to trigger running up a
big cluster in our case i'll try to keep
it little small i don't want too many
nodes in my cluster i'm going to have
one master node and two worker nodes
this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know aws is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what i
would do is i will create an iam role
which will attach to my ec2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that i'm going to specify
all right so once i have my cluster set
up i will also install cubicctl which
you would probably know by now is
nothing but a command line utility using
which i can kind of connect to my
cluster give it some jobs put some parts
and stuff like that so i will use cube
ctl i will also have a pair of ssh keys
so that from this machine i would be
able to successfully get onto the master
node and submit jobs on my behalf so let
me begin by first logging into my aws
account all the steps that i will be
following to bring up my aws cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and i'll be sharing you this document in
a github repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that i would need is to
launch an aws ec2 instance now this is
an instance where i'm going to install
cops and i will use it as a base server
from where i'm going to find some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me log into my
aws account and um let me stick to one
particular region and let me bring up
some one ec2 instance all right so let
me launch my instance let me choose
doesn't matter in the ways but in case
you want to try it on your free tire i
would recommend choose free tire only
and choose an ami of your choice let me
choose
this instance i will make it t2 micro
that is good for me configuration
instance details all right i don't want
to change anything here that looks good
maybe i will change this
30 gig that's good for me let me add a
tag to my instance i will name this as
my cops server all right i would need a
bunch of posts to be opened up so what
i'll do is i'll create a new security
group
called open to the word i would not
recommend that you do this since i don't
want to it will take a long time for me
to specifically
to pick and choose um the ports that has
to be open for running my cluster i
don't want to do that i will open up all
the http and https ports so that it's
quicker so i will say all tcp i would
say from anywhere just to be on the
safer side also open http and https and
i will make this anywhere and anywhere
this is good for me i will say review
and launch all right so i chose a t2
micro instance
just for the sake of easiness i've
opened up all the ports and um the
instant details are you've seen what is
that i've chosen all right now important
part is like i would need a keyboard i
need to create a new keyboard i will
call this as simply learn
keys i will download this
keypair and then i will launch the
instance it will take some time for my
ec2 instance to come up in the meanwhile
what i'll do is i will convert i have
this pen file which is the pair of keys
ssh keys with which i need to log into
my ec2 instance so i'll need to convert
this because i'm trying to connect from
my windows box i would need to convert
this into a ppk file so i have puttygen
i'm going to load my set of keys here
and convert that key into a ppk key all
right open all right i would say save
hang on save private key yes i would say
simply learn or simply learn private
private key i will save this here and
that that's all so this is my public key
which is the pem file and this is my ppk
or my private key now using the private
key i will log into my ec2 instance okay
now my ec2 instance is up and running it
is running in this ohio region and this
is the ip address of my public ipads of
my machine so let me connect to it so i
use a moba x term which is nothing but
an ssh emulator you can use putty or any
of these sessions which allow you to do
an ssh this is my ip address of my
machine and since i've spun up an amazon
ami the user this is the default user i
would need to specify the private keys
for my session and this is the private
key for my session say okay i am in my
amazon ec2 instance so let me look at
what are the other things that i need to
do all right so as i said i just brought
up my ec2 instance but i would need my
ec2 instance to
run few things on my behalf so that it
can spin up easy to other ec2 instances
it can also talk to an s3 bucket where
i'm going to store the instant state of
my kubernetes cluster also some sort of
an auto scaling group because i want to
spin up more and more instances i also
want to have a private hosted zone using
my route 53 so i would need my ec2
instance to have all these sort of
permissions for my server so what i
would do is i will go and create a
permission a rule in the ec2 rather in
the aws im role and i will attach this
im rule to my ec2 instance all right so
let me go to my iam which is nothing but
the identity and access management i
will create a rule called as possibly
cop's role i will create a role this
role will be used by my ec2 so i'm going
to click on ec2 and say next permissions
they would need a lot of permissions uh
specific permissions to be very honest
and the permissions are all listed out
here s3 ec2 and all this stuff just to
keep it pretty simple what i would do is
i'll create a role with the
administrative access all right so i
don't want any tags i will review i'll
create a role name i will say cops role
for ec2 all right so i'm going to create
a rule which has got administrative
access rules i'm going to create a role
so this would ensure that my ec2
instance from which i'm going to run my
cluster would have all the prerequisite
permissions so that it can go and spin
up instances talk to s3 buckets and all
that stuff all right now let us have our
running instance get powered by this
role so i will connect this role to my
running instance all right so this is my
um easy to instant that is running
transaction attach attach attach attach
replace im rolls so there is no rule as
of now i would want my cops roll for
easy this row that i created so i want
this new rule to be assigned to my ec2
all right great now my ec2 instance
which is my cop server has got all the
required permissions so that he can
create a cluster on my behalf great now
before this let me do a sudo yum update
iphone y so that any of the because this
is a newly provisioned vm i just want to
ensure that all my library system
libraries are all updated so that when i
do install cop and cube ctl and all
those things none of them will fail
because of some dependency or package
issues so i'm just running a sudo update
iphone y so that all the libraries are
updated okay looks like it is done so
let me go ahead and
install cops cops is a pretty simple
installation it is available in a
particular location i have to just copy
this and ensure that i do a curl and i
install this particular stuff all right
so it is fetching uh the corpse tool
it's installing for me once it is copied
down let me change the mode so that i
can execute it and then also let me move
it to my user local bin so that it is
available for me in my path okay that's
pretty much the corpse installation let
me also do one other thing let me
install something called as cuba ctl so
this is what would be you know a tool
using which i'm going to be firing my uh
commands to my kubernetes cluster once
it comes up right this is a pretty
smaller executable so
ctl all right so i have cuba ctl as well
as cops installed on my ec2 server now
okay now what i'll do next is i'm going
to create an s3 bucket in aws so that
the kubernetes cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name s3
bucket with this name so let me go to s3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name i will just say create a
bucket okay so the simply learn
kubernetes is the bucket that i created
so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
go and create a dns entry or a dns zone
or aws route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know i can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that i'm coming up so
i will create a private hosted zone and
possibility possibly i will call this as
uh simplylearn.in so this will be my
name of my private hosted zone in case
you already have any other public hosted
zones in your name you can always put a
route 53 hosted zone specific for your
domain name since i don't have anyone
i'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to route
53 click on any of these and you'll get
these hosted zones out here so i'm going
to create a hosted zone here i'm going
to create a hosted zone click on create
hosted zone um this would be simply
learn lot in i want to create a public
no i don't want public i want a private
hostess zone and i'm going to associate
my vpc id for this hosted zone since i'm
going to try out all my exercises in the
ohio region i will associate the vpc of
the wire region for this all right so
this is the one that is specific to the
ohio region so i will say this one i'll
say create a hosted sum great now let me
come back to my ec2 box my ec2 is all
powered with whatever it needs in order
to go ahead with the installation of my
cluster only few things that i need to
take care of is that you know now that i
put a name for my cluster i also have an
s3 bucket that i've configured for my
cluster i will have to ensure that i
need to put in these two configurations
as a part of my cluster building
activity so i will open my bashrc file
and i'm going to export these two
variables if at all you remember well
these two variables are nothing but the
cluster name which is nothing but the
public uh sorry the private hosted zone
that i created and the s3 bucket where
i'm going to create or rather i'm going
to store my cluster state so let me copy
these two and open up my
bash rc file all right so i will just
add these two and copy these and export
them out as my ah variable i'm going to
save this here now let me ensure that
this gets picked up all right i've got
these two that have configured and i
also ensure that these environment
variables are set now let me create a
pair of ssh keys this is to ensure that
i can log into the box that i'm going to
be provisioning as a part of my cluster
ssh hyphen keygen i don't want to give
any parameters let it go to the home
directory with the default name and
without any passphrase all right so i
created a bunch of my keypair now i'm
all set to go ahead and run my cops now
cops will ensure that this will take
some time for the cluster to come up but
this is exactly how i would define my
corpse command how do i have copied here
so corpse create cluster the state of
the
cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what i have
exported out the number of node count is
two node count is the worker node count
if at all i don't specify configuration
for specifying the master or the control
pane as well if i don't specify that the
default one is one so i'm going to
create one primary or the master node
and two
worker nodes size of my master node size
of the worker nodes uh what are the
zones where i want this to be created
and where do i store the cluster
information and okay i've already added
this master count this is actually not
required but this is the command that
i'm going to fire off so that i bring up
my cluster all right that went off uh
very fast but um this actually did not
create a cluster it is just the
definition of a cluster and uh and
that's why this came out very fast
now that everything looks good with uh
whatever configuration that i specified
now let me go ahead and create the
cluster by saying corpse update cluster
iphone iphone 8 yes now this will take
some time a good five to ten minutes for
it to because this will actually start
provisioning the servers and as i
mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration i'm gonna come up with one
master server and uh two nodes or the
worker nodes all right so this is the
command for me to validate the cluster
and i'm going to try it out first i'm
pretty sure that it'll fail because all
my servers are not up yet it is taking
some time the validation everything
failed but let me try to look at my ec2
instances and
see how many servers do i have running
as of now if you see i had only one
server that i had started which was my
cop server and automatically the other
three instances one is called not start
simply not in this these two are the
nodes and this is the master node so
these three got automatically
provisioned by the cops command that i
ran all right so this may take a while
for it to get validated a good five to
ten minutes so what i'll do is i'll
pause the video now and i'll come back
once uh the server the cluster is up and
running it's been a good uh eight to
nine minutes uh since i started my
cluster so let me validate now okay
seems good so there's a master node
minimum one max one some nodes which are
nothing but the slave nodes or the
worker nodes there are two of them due
to micro
subnet so my clusters seem to be up and
running and my cluster name is simply
learn.n so what i would want to do is
now let me just log into the master and
see if i can run some parts so let me
get back to my install installation
steps here the validation cluster is
done so let me login into my since my
cluster name is simply non dot and this
is the way to log into my box so let me
get into my box so if you see here this
is the host name of the machine that i'm
currently in if you see this this is
nothing but our this cop server this is
the 7th now from here i'm trying to get
into the master box all right so if you
see the ip address has changed i was in
a different box i'm in a different box
now if i see host name you'll find a
different host name so this is 153 which
is nothing but the master node yep it's
153 this is the particular host so i'm
getting into this machine now so i
started the cluster from my cop server
here it ran and brought up three nodes
so i'm actually getting into my master
node and see if i can run some parts on
it all right so let me try cuba ctl uh
get cluster info try cube ctl get nodes
all right so there are three nodes here
master node and um one master node and
two worker nodes so let me see if i have
some pods here cubicle get pods so
there's no port as of now so what i'll
try to do is let me just pin up a very
very simple part just to check if my
connections is everything is correct or
not correct i have a simple
node.js application that i've built uh
i've got a container for that this is
already pushed to the docker i've
registered is called simply learn docker
hub and the image name that i have here
is called my node app and i will use
this image to power one of my parts that
i will run so this is the way in which
i'm going to launch my pod let me show
you these commands cube ctl run the name
for my deployment that i'm going to run
hyphen iphone image and this is the
image that is going to be powering my
container so this is simply learn docker
hub forward slash my node app hyphen f1
replica is equal to i want two replicas
to be running and the port that i want
to expose this particular part is on
eight zero eight zero so let me run this
as soon as this is run it creates
something called as a deployment all
right now let me just say um i'm not
really interested in the deployment i'm
interested in checking if all the parts
are up and running so i will say cube
ctl get but all right so that was pretty
fast so i have two parts that are
running here these are two replicas
because i asked for two replicas these
parts are running so i can run cube ctl
describe pod pickup all right i can pick
up any of the pod name and see what is
the pod what is the information does it
contain from what is the image that is
pulling what is the image image name id
this is actually running my pod which is
actually spinning up a container great
so far so good so in kubernetes the pods
can are ephemeral so they can be there
at any time cannot beat in time if i
need to expose my pod outside i will
have to create a service for my part so
what i'll do is i'll create a very very
simple
service by exposing this particular
deployment before that let me check cube
cdl get deployment so there's a
deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply an app so i
will expose my deployment simply learn
app as uh yeah i'll just expose this let
me see all right i'm not specifying what
type and all i don't want to get into
the complications of uh what are the
different types of exposing the service
and all that stuff so if i don't specify
anything it gives me something closer
cluster ip so this is where my pod is
actually exposed so let me just check if
at all this part is up and running i'll
just try a simple curl command curl http
colon this is my cluster ip and the port
is 8080 if at all i hit this it's
actually hitting my application and
giving me whatever
i put a simple uh sys dot out kind of a
thing where i'm just printing um the
container id of whatever pod is serving
uh being sold out of so i'm actually
hitting my container and i'm getting
this output from the content so
everything looks good my content is up
and running uh so let me just go and
clean it up i'll say cube ctl
delete deployment simply learn app this
should get rid of all the parts that i
created cube ctl get pod all right these
spots are intimidating things let me
just check cube ctl get services there's
one service i don't want this service
let me delete that keep ctl delete
service i want this all right that
sounds good so let me come back to my
host my cop server from where i'm
running so i managed to successfully
verify this part see if everything is up
and running so what i'll do is i'll just
go ahead and complete this demo by going
and
getting rid of my cluster so corpse
delete cluster hyphen f1 yes all right
so this will ensure that it will clean
up my complete cluster that i created so
i had three or four running instances if
you see that all the three are shutting
down because you know the cop server
which had cops installed on it uh it's
now got a mandate to go ahead and shut
down and clean up the whole instances
and all those things that are created as
a part of my deployment in this video
we're going to cover a common
conversation which is kubernetes versus
darker so let's go through a couple of
scenarios let's do one for kubernetes
and then one for docker and we can
actually go through and understand what
the problem specific companies have
actually had and how they're able to use
the two different tools to solve them so
our first one is with bose and bose
had a
large catalog of products that kept
growing and their infrastructure had to
change so the way that they looked at
that was actually establishing two
primary goals to be able to allow their
product groups to be able to easier more
easily catch up to the scale of their
business so after going through um a
number of solutions they ended up coming
up with a solution of having kubernetes
running their iot platform as a service
inside of amazon's aws cloud service and
what you'll see with both these products
is they're very cloud friendly but here
we have
bose and kubernetes working together
with aws to be able to scale up and meet
the demands of their product catalog and
so the result is that we're able to
increase the number of non-production
deployments significantly by taking the
number of services from being large
bulky surfaces down to small micro
services being able to handle as many as
1250
plus deployments every year an
incredible amount of time and value has
been opened through the use of
kubernetes now let's have a look at daca
and see what a similar problem that
people would have so uh the problem is
with paypal and paypal and processes
something in the region of over 200
payments per second across all of their
products and paypal doesn't just have
paypal they have braintree and venmo so
the challenge um that uh paypal was uh
really being given is that they had
different architectures which resulted
in different maintenance cycles and
different deployment times and an
overall complexity from having a
decades-old architecture with paypal
through to a modern architecture with a
venmo through the use of docker paper
was able to unify the application
delivery and be able to centralize the
management of all of the containers with
one existing group the net net result is
that paypal was able to migrate over 700
applications into docker enterprise
which consists of over 200 000
containers this ultimately opened up a
50 percent increase in availability for
being able to
add in additional time for building
testing and deploying of applications
just a huge win for paypal now let's dig
into kubernetes and docker so kubernetes
is an open source uh platform and it's
designed for being able to maintain a
large number of containers and what
you're going to find is that your
argument for kubernetes versus docker
isn't a real argument it's kubernetes
and docker working together so
kubernetes is able to manage the
infrastructure of a containerized
environment and docker is the number one
container management solution and so
with docker you're able to automate the
deployment of your applications being
able to keep them in a very lightweight
environment and being able to
create a nice consistent experience so
that your developers are working in the
same containers that are then also
pushed out to production so with docker
you're able to manage multiple
containers running on the same hardware
much more efficiently than you are with
a
vm environment the productivity around
docker is extremely high you're able to
keep your applications very isolated the
configuration for docker is really quick
and easy you can be up and running in
minutes with docker once you have it
installed and running on your
development machine or inside of your
devops environment so we look at the
deployment between the two
and the differences kubernetes is really
designed for a combination of pods and
services in its deployment whereas with
docker it's around about deploying
services in containers uh so the the
difference
here is that kubernetes is going to
manage the entire environment and then
and that environment consisting of pods
and inside of a pod you're going to have
all of your containers that you're
working on and those containers that can
control the services that actually power
the applications that are being deployed
kubernetes is by default an auto scaling
solution has it turned on and is always
available whereas uh docker does not and
that's not surprising because docker is
a tool for building out solutions
whereas kubernetes is about managing
your infrastructure kubernetes is going
to
run health checks on the liveness and
readiness of your entire environment so
not just one container but tens of
thousands of containers whereas docker
is going to limit the health check to
the services that it's managing within
its own containers now i'm not going to
kid you
kubernetes is quite hard to set up it's
if of the tools that you're going to be
using in your devops environment it's
it's not an easy setup for you to use um
and for
this reason you want to really take
advantage of the services within azure
and other similar cloud environments
where they actually will do the setup
for you docker in contrast is really
easy to set up you can as i mentioned
earlier you can be up and running in a
few minutes as you would expect the
fault tolerance within kubernetes is
very high and this is by design because
the architecture of kubernetes is built
on the same architecture that google
uses for managing its entire cloud
infrastructure in contrast docker has
lower fault tolerance but that's because
it's just managing the
support kubernetes but the reality is is
that today google amazon and many other
providers are having first level support
for kubernetes it's just become
extremely popular in a very very short
time frame the company's using both
kubernetes and docker is fast and every
single day there are more and more
companies using it and you should be
able to look and see whether or not you
can add your own company to this list
let's go through and you're going to be
asked to explain what the architecture
of docker is and docker really is the
most popular containerization
environment so docker uses a client
server architecture and the docker
client is a service which runs in a
command line and then the docker daemon
which is run as a rest api and within
the command line will accept the
requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
together and then finally the docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
what are the advantages of docker over
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact um you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a docker
or docker-like environment and really
the the arguments for docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all docker does contain and occupy
socket containers occupy significantly
less space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
docker is significantly faster than a vm
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single docker image docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation uh docker data volumes
can be shared and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your arguments for docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is leverage the power of
docker swarm so docker swarm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the darker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
manager node as you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed
so what are the commands to create a
docker swan and so here we have an
example of what a manager node would
look like and once you've created a
swarm on your magic node you can now add
worker nodes to that swarm and again
when you're stepping through this
process be very precise in the execution
part that needs to be taken to be able
to effectively create a swarm so start
with the manager node and then you
create a worker node and then finally
when a node is initialized as a manager
node it can immediately create a token
and that token is used for the worker
nodes and associating the ip address
with the worker nodes question 17 how to
run multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers a single service by using
docker compose and docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the compose files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yamos
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a docker file so
docker file actually is used for
creating docker images using the build
command so let's go through and show on
the screen what that would look like and
this would be an opportunity where if
you're actually in a technical interview
you could potentially even ask hey can i
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like um again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things i really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as an architect this
should be something that you're
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and certainly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
drawings so back to the question of
creating a docker file so we go through
and we have a docker file that actually
then goes ahead and creates the docker
image which then in turns creates the
docker container and then we are able to
push that out up to a docker hub and
then share that docker hub with
everybody else as part of the docker
registry with the whole network so what
are the differences between docker image
and docker containers so let's go
through the docker image so the docker
images are templates of a docker
container an image is built using a
docker file and it stores that docker
file in a docker repository or a docker
hub
and you can use docker hub as an example
and the image layer is a read only file
system the docker container is a
collection of the runtime instances of a
docker image and the containers are
created using docker images and they are
stored in the docker daemon and every
container is a layer is a read write
file system so you can't replace the
information you can only append to it
so while you can actually use yaml or
our writing your so a question you can
be asked is instead of yaml what can be
an alternate file to build docker
compose so yaml is the one that is the
default but you can also use json so if
you are comfortable working with jason
and my that is something that you should
be uh get comfortable with is you want
to be able to use that to name your
files and as a frame reference json is a
logical way of being able to do value
paired matching using a javascript like
syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a my mysql docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a docker image or pull
from an existing docker image from a
docker repository or hub and then you
want to be able to then use docker to
create a new container which has my
sequel from the existing docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image and below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the commands
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have a docker
registry is an open source server-side
service used for hosting and
distributing docker images whereas in
contrast for repositories a collection
of multiple versions of a docker image
in a registry a user can distinguish
between docker images with their tag
names and then finally on the registry
docker also has its own default retreat
called docker hub for the repository it
is a collection of multiple versions of
docker images it is stored in a docker
registry and it has two types of public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own enterprise registry so
you're gonna be asked you know what are
the cloud platforms that uh support
docker really you know lists them all
and we have listed here amazon web
services microsoft azure google cloud
rackspace but you could add in their ibm
bluemix you could put in red hat really
any of the cloud service providers out
there today do support docker it's just
become an industry standard so what is
the purpose of expose and publish
commands in docker so if we go through
expose is an instruction used in docker
file whereas publish is used in docker
run command for expose it is used to
expose ports within a docker network
whereas with publish it can be used
outside of a docker environment for
expose it is a documenting instruction
used at the time of building an image
and running a container whereas with
published is used as to map a host port
to a running container port for expose
is the command used in docker whereas
for publish we use the command-p for
when we're doing our command line used
in docker and examples of these are
expose 8080 or with docker we would put
in or for publish we'd do the example
docker run dash d dash p and then
0.0.0.80
a colon 80 as our command line in this
video we're going to take you through
the 13 most common questions that you
are likely to be asked in a kubernetes
interview we're going to break up the
interview questions into three
categories it's going to be beginner
intermediate and advanced and the
beginner questions are really going to
cover about three quarters of the
questions that we're going to ask here
and then the intermediate and advanced
will finalize out the will finish out
the final quarter and and the reason is
is that quite typically
most interviews um you'll be asked you
know intermediate to beginner level
questions mainly beginner level
questions just so you can demonstrate
your understanding of kubernetes and
then there's always one advanced
question that gets thrown out just to
make sure that you really do know what
you're talking about and you've done at
least one or two kubernetes environment
uh setups to be able to validate your
experience so let's kind of jump into
that first section which is you know why
is kubernetes widely used and your
answer to this really comes into the
fact that kubernetes is widely used
because of three distinct areas one is
that kubernetes is an open source
platform that is readily available for
the management containers and allows you
to manage the deployment scaling and
management of those containers and so
the first area is that it allows you for
easy deployment of your containers the
ability to scale effectively within
kubernetes not just vertically but
horizontally for your containers and
then finally the kubernetes environment
itself was really designed to make it
easy to manage containers um in small
parts other key areas of why kubernetes
is popular is that kubernetes is the
single largest open source project out
there since its launch in 2014 is just
grown in leaps and bounds um around that
project there is just a huge community
both an online and physical community
there are just a large number of online
groups that are supporting kubernetes
and allow you to get fast access to
information but in addition to that
there are also a lot of
local meetup groups that cover
specifically kubernetes whether as part
of a devops group or as part of a
dedicated kubernetes group the actual
environment itself is a really robust
way of being able to manage your
containers containers are becoming the
most popular way of being able to deploy
cloud-based applications kubernetes is
an effective and persistent storage
environment so kubernetes is also able
to effectively manage persistent storage
whether it's local storage as a ssd
drive or a local hard drive or whether
it's cloud-based storage and because of
the way that kubernetes architecture is
really designed for the cloud from the
ground up so it's a great way to get
started in building out your cloud
solutions and then finally the actual
tools within kubernetes are designed to
help and manage the health and
monitoring of the environment itself so
what is google container engine so the
google container engine is another open
source solution but it's designed for
managing the docker containers and
clusters and so kubernetes is a
container management solution and docker
is the most popular container solution
out there and this is just a way of
being able to bring the two effectively
with into each other so that you can
have docker containers manage the
application and then kubernetes manage
the scale of your applications as
they're vertically and horizontally
scaled across your network so what is
the difference between kubernetes and
docker and this is important because
kubernetes and docker are often dropped
in the same
sentence and there's a lot of people
that get confused between the two so
fundamentally kubernetes is about
taking pods which contain containers
which have applications in and deploying
them at scale across a cloud network
docker is the container solution itself
so the actual application itself is put
into the docker container because of
this difference uh kubernetes is
designed for auto scaling is highly
available whereas docker simply isn't
because it doesn't have to worry about
that within the container itself the
kubernetes environment will check for
liveness and readiness of the health of
the entire infrastructure whereas with
docker it's just really going to check
the services that are coming in and out
of the actual application itself within
the container kubernetes is complicated
to set up it really is just simply
complicated setup and what you'll find
is a lot of cloud services will actually
do the setup for you whereas docker is
very easy to set up the as you would
expect with a tolerance ratio there is
high fault tolerance river kubernetes
whereas with docker is low fault
tolerance again this is fundamental in
the two different types of strategy that
kubernetes and docker have they're both
connected tightly with each other but
they both do different things so what
are the notable features of kubernetes
and one is the ability to do container
bands kubernetes always knows where to
place a container within its entire
network within the pods and with its
infrastructure the services are managed
for security network and storage uh it
is self monitoring so it goes in and is
able to check its own nodes for health
and the containers within the nodes so
it makes sure that the applications are
always running effectively you can do
the scaling effectively both vertically
and horizontally within kubernetes the
solution is open source so there's no
actual fee for the actual kubernetes
service itself and kubernetes allows for
storage orchestration what does that
mean by storage orchestration now
storage orchestration is that you're
able to
access and share either local storage
such as a hard drive or ssd drive or a
cloud-based drive and my preference is
always to go with cloud-based drive
because then you're really positioning
your solution to be a true cloud-based
uh application so what are the main
advantages of kubernetes uh well you get
automatic rollback for changes that go
wrong the a you're able to automate a
lot of the processes that would have
been manual processes previously you're
able to scale the resources both
vertically and horizontally easily and
quickly and then these three areas the
roll back automating roll bank
automating services and being able to
scale indirectly allows you to save
money by reducing the amount of time and
people working on your operations
environment so let's break out the
architecture of kubernetes so you're
going to be explaining us to explain
how is kubernetes architecture
structured and there are three key areas
there's the application layer there's
the kubernetes layer and then there's
the infrastructure layer we're going to
start off with the infrastructure layer
and so the infrastructure layer is our
base layer and this is where all your
where you make your clusters for your
collections of storage and networking
resources within kubernetes and this is
where you would have if your databases
are your data stored locally on a hard
drive or in the cloud your core network
and the vms that you'd be building out
your infrastructure on these allow you
to group many machines together into a
single unit so that you're able to scale
up and down very easily to meet customer
demand so let's talk about the middle
layer which is the kubernetes layer now
so if we're looking at our architecture
for our kubernetes layers really broken
down for the the core operating system
the docker container environment and the
kubernetes code itself and this is where
you're able to take machines and pull
them together as a cluster so that they
work within that kubernetes system you
have a master controller within the
kubernetes that actually then will go
ahead and manage the scheduler control
manager the api server and then you'll
be able to cluster all of these
kubernetes together so that they're all
working and processing as one single
unit and then finally let's look at the
application layout where you actually
have your apps and so the application
layer where you have your pool and your
services you know kubernetes will use
api to connect in and out of this layer
it's to run your applications within
containers and you use instructions that
are written in yaml or json to actually
set up those containers and you actually
have the environment running on a plan
that examines these instructions so it
keeps the entire environment healthy api
ecosystem is used to interact with the
cluster it's so you don't have to uh do
that by yourself so make sure that
you're referencing that the apis are
secured and connecting in and out of the
system and so you have your schedule and
control manager actually from the
kubernetes environment doing the hard
work and then the workers themselves
execute the commands that are coming
from kubernetes so you will be asked to
kind of dig into some of the key areas
such as explaining the master node and
listing its components so the masternode
is comprised of four key components
there's the
cluster store the controller manager the
scheduler and the api server so four key
components remember four fingers four
components and then you're gonna be
asked to maybe dig deeper into what is a
cluster within kubernetes and so a
customer is really a combination of
resources such as machines into a single
node and then
those nodes are pulled together and work
as a single cluster as a whole
kubernetes will work with that whole
cluster and then once you're actually
working with that whole cluster if a
node fails or needs to be removed
kubernetes is able to do that quickly
and effectively so let's talk a little
bit about what are the different types
of controllers in kubernetes and there
are five types of control manager you
have the node controller the service
account the token controller the
endpoint controller and the replication
controller and so the node controller
controls and handles the node in the
system the service account enables
access controls in the system the token
controller cleans up any tokens for
non-existent service accounts the
endpoint controller joins services in
pods to the endpoint objects and the
replication controller manages the port
lifecycle so what is the role of the
cloud controller manager within this
environment and so the role of the cloud
control manager is really to help manage
persistent storage and so persistent
storage uh is storage that's either
local storage to the physical machine
such as an ssd or hard drive or
cloud-based storage and this allows the
storage to be shared across the entire
network what is the role of the cube api
server and the cube scheduler so the
cube api server responsible for the
establishment communication between the
kubernetes nodes and the master
components and and it does this through
the through apis the apis themselves are
all commands that are rest based
commands and it implements an interface
which means different tools and
libraries can communicate effectively
with each other so what is the role of
the cube api server and the cube
scheduler so the cube's capture actually
does the distribution of work across the
entire infrastructure so the actual
yaml scripts that you've written are
executed appropriately at the right time
so you can be asked to explain
persistent volumes in kubernetes so a
persistent volume is just a place where
you can store data again this can be
local data as in a hard drive local to
the physical machine or it can be
cloud-based data so what is a cube light
and a cube proxy so a cube light is a
service responsible for conveying
information to and from the control plan
itself the process and the cue proxy
itself is responsible for maintaining
the work and the standards within the
node server in addition uh every node in
the cluster runs a simple network proxy
and cue proxy routes requests to the
correct container in that node in
addition you'll have some basic and
primitive load balancing and management
of the node from the proxy itself and
there's additional layers of management
that get done outside the proxy but the
proxy is also there to help do some
localized load management so what is
cube ctl so cube ctl is your command
line or terminal window interface that
allows you to execute commands and later
in this video we'll actually go through
some of those commands etcd is the store
that configures the details and
essential values such as key value pairs
that are distributed across your entire
network it also manages the network
rules and the post forwarding of
activity so what are the disadvantages
of kubernetes well the first is it's
really hard to install and configure and
this is why azure and many cloud
services such as google cloud will
actually do the installation and
configuration of kubernetes for you it
does take a long time to get up and
running with kubernetes not so much for
the actual software but your own
experience of being able to use
kubernetes it is not simple to manage
the service you actually have to have a
lot of experience and this is why people
get paid a lot for kubernetes skills
it's a difficult environment to get up
and running and be effective in that
management again kubernetes is just not
an easy platform to learn it takes a lot
of time and effort and
one of the disadvantages is that while
kubernetes itself is free because it is
an open source project getting the
people who are skilled you to using
kubernetes is expensive all right so
those were kind of the introductory um
questions that you can expect to be
asked in your interview the next set of
questions are really going to be on an
intermediate and advanced level and
these are the questions that will be
thrown out you know you see these as
being the trick questions which are
really there to test that you have the
skill set to be able to implement and
manage kubernetes within a company so
what happens if a master node fails what
happens if a worker nerd fails how would
kubernetes manage that well kubernetes
is really designed for this kind of
scenario and so you can actually look at
it and the response would be is that the
pod itself does not get affected
kubernetes will actually respond and fix
the
the failed node whether it is uh needs
to be repaired whether it needs to be
restarted or needs to be replaced so
what is a service role in kubernetes so
a service role is an abstraction for all
the pods it provides a virtual ip
address that allows clients to connect
to containers running in the pods using
that virtual ip address and the command
that you would use to get that we would
use some of these cube ctl commands it's
quite a simple one it's cube ctl get
services and you get a full list then of
all the services that are available so
how do i do a rollback in deployment and
so there's a couple of ways you can do
the rollback and the first is if you
want to see the rollout history
deployment you'd write cube ctl rollout
history deployment and then in square
brackets deployment if you want to just
restore to the previous rollout the
command would be cube ctl rollout undo
deployment and then in square brackets
deployment and that would take you back
to the previous deployment so what is an
ingress controller so an ingress
controller really is a pod that manages
that inbound traffic and a prominent
feature of that traffic is that it is
secured with an ssl termination and so
what we're going to do to now address
some of the key ways in which you can
provide api securities on kubernetes and
we have eight of those so the first four
are
implementing tl tls for your security
the second would be api authentication
the third is to make the cubeless
protection the cubeless
protected via authorization
mode equals webhook command the fourth
is to monitor rbac failures the fifth is
to remove those default service account
permissions
six would be to filter egress to cloud
api metadata apis the seventh is to use
pod security policy to restrict
container policies and protect the node
and the eighth and final is to keep the
cube at the latest version all right
let's go into some of the more advanced
commands and so the advanced questions
you're going to get are all going to be
commands that you're going to be asked
to write now my advice for you for these
questions is to make sure that you have
some of these basic commands
memorized they don't have to be perfect
when you're in the interview
environment but it's good to be able to
get up to a whiteboard and actually
write out what these commands are just
so you can actually demonstrate that you
know what the commands are the interview
isn't going to ask you questions on how
would you
apply kubernetes to the company that
you're being hired for because you
simply don't have that knowledge but
they do want to be able to see clearly
that you understand
the commands and terminal window
instructions that will be able to
demonstrate how you would actually go in
and access some of that information so
one of the first questions you might be
asked is how do you package kubernetes
applications and so you would use the
package manager within kubernetes to be
able to manage to pl and configure and
deploy applications uh into your cluster
and so here we have the the helm command
that you would use so what are in it
containers and any container gets
executed before any other containers can
run on the pod and so you want to be
able to illustrate what the init
instructions would look like and here we
have an example and i would again use
this example and maybe memorize it for
when you have this question come up in
your interview so what is the difference
between a config map and a secret and
these are more uh fundamentals so a
config map just has the instructions
that are clearly available in plain text
on what the uh cube is supposed to do
whereas uh the secrets are actually
encrypted and these are
like passwords and other sensitive data
that you don't want to have
easily available these are encrypted
information have to be decrypted to
access the content so if a node is
tainted is there a way to schedule the
pods to that node and the answer is no
there isn't and so what you have to do
then is schedule the pod to be
fixed and so that schedule the pod to
fix the tainted node to allow for
tolerations to that and we have here the
example code that you would use to do
that so how do you deploy a feature with
zero downtime in kubernetes well
kubernetes is designed to be able to
roll out um applications with zero
downtime and here we have four examples
using the rolling update as a strategy
for zero downtime deployments in
kubernetes again memorize one of these
so you can actually illustrate how you
use rollout to be able to deploy a zero
downtime solution so how do you monitor
a pod that is always running and so to
do that you would use the liveness probe
to check um the health of the
application within the pod and see
whether or not
there are any failures or whether or not
the part itself needs to be restarted so
how do you drain traffic from pot during
a maintenance so again um this is a
simple command for you to remember but
to be able to drain an application so
that it's easy for you to be able to do
maintenance on the application you would
use the cube ctl grain and then in
square brackets the node name and that
would then uh temporarily drain uh that
particular part so you can actually do
maintenance on it what you have to then
and this would probably give you bonus
points with your in an interview is then
reference the uncorden command so that
you can uncordon the actual
node itself so that the part itself can
come back up into life and work as a
fully functioning solution so to be able
to tie surfaces to a positive to a set
of parts is that you can apply labels to
the actual parts themselves and then use
the labels as selectors to be able to
glue surfaces to that pod and again we
have here an example of how you'd
actually do that and again this is one
of those where you can probably won't be
asked to write this out but it'd be good
to have this memorized how would you get
all pods on a node and so the following
command will actually go ahead and bring
all the pods into a kubernetes cluster
um this is quite lengthy and you know
maybe you want to like talk to how this
would be done uh but we have the
instructions on how to do that right
here the important part is to make sure
that you uh when you're talking about
the node name that you reference to
whoever you're interviewing that you
would what you would switch out to uh
reference the actual nodes that you're
trying to pull together into the
kubernetes cluster so how do parts mount
nfs volumes and so in these examples
here we actually define the nfs server
and then the pod and how you'd actually
mount two together and again what you
want to be able to do is illustrate why
you would use yaml and
how you'd actually then point to
specific ip addresses within your
kubernetes environment within either the
production or test environment to be
able to illustrate how you would mount
up those nfs volumes and with that we
have reached the end of day two so far
we have learned the dockers and
kubernetes on day three of devops
learning week we will reveal the next
stage where you will master the devops
testing
so stay tuned and don't miss it out
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and stay tuned for more from
simply done
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you